ALL RIGHT GOOD MORNING WILL
BEGIN AT TODAY'S HEARING THIS
NEW COMMITTEE ROOM ANY DAY OVER
HERE AT THE STATE CAPITOL SWING
SPACE A TODAY WERE HEARING THE
ASSEMBLY. BUDGET COMMUNITY
EDUCATION FINANCE- A VARIETY OF
ISSUES LATEST STUDENT CAREER
COLLEGE READINESS EDUCATOR
PIPELINE AND THE INTER AGENCY
DATA OVERSIGHT WELL THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSALS- WE
WILL HEAR FROM PEOPLE IN PERSON
AND- YOUR WEBEX TODAY- THE FIRST
TWO ISSUES. ARE RELATED TO- THE
EDUCATOR PIPELINE IN SHORTAGE
AND THEN WE'LL GET INTO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE RELATE TO THE
EDUCATOR PIPELINE JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSALS. A SERVER THAT- WE
WILL BEGIN OF COURSE WE KNOW
THAT SINCE THE PANDEMIC-
TEACHERS HAVE BEEN ON THE FRONT
LINE TRYING TO MAKE SURE WEGET
ITS BACK IN THE CLASSROOM AND
LEARNING AND WE DO HAVE A
SHORTAGE ACROSS. OUR STATE AND
FRANKLY OUR NATIO REPLACING
THAT RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
OUR OWN. SEXY SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND TEACHERS ON LABOR ISSUES-
RELATE TO OF COURSE COMPENSATION
AS ALWAYS BUT- THE EDUCATOR WORK
FORCE SHORTAGE WHICH I'M- WE
KNOW IS SECURED RIGHT HERE IN MY
HOMETOWN OF SACRAMENTO BUT ALSO
ACROSS THE STATE. SO WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN TODAY'S
HEARING WITH ISSUE NUMBER ONE
AND BRING UP THE FIRST PANEL WE
HAVE THE L. A. O. YOUR IN PERSON
AND EVERYBODY ELSE I BELIEVE IS
PARTICIPATING VIA. WEBEX.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BIRDS
ANNUALLY WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO THIS MORNING
I WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATOR WORKFORCE CAPACITY AND
ASSOCIATED RECOMMENDATIONS. I
WILL PLAN TO BRIEFLY DESCRIBE
WHAT THE TEACHER PIPELINE LOOKS
LIKE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND
THEN GIVE YOU A SENSE OF HOW
THINGS MAY HAVE CHANGED
SUBSEQUENTLY. SO PART OF THE
PANDEMIC I THINK WE ARE ALL
AWARE OF THE CHRONIC AREAS OF
TEACHER SHORTAGE THAT WE HAD IN
THE STATE THAT WERE SUBJECT
SPECIFIC AND AFFECTED CERTAIN
SCHOOLS MORE. SO IN TERMS OF
SUBJECTS WE KNOW THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION THE STEM FIELDS OF
SCIENCE AND MATH AND BILINGUAL
EDUCATION WERE MORE LIKELY
CHALLENGING TO STAFFORD
DISTRICTS. IN TERMS OF THE
SPECIFIC SCHOOLS ARMORED
AFFECTED LOW INCOME URBAN
SCHOOLS AS WELL AS RULES SCHOOLS
HAVE THE MOST CHALLENGES
RECRUITING AND RETAINING
TEACHERS. NOT TWO YEARS HAVE
PASSED AND- THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA HAS
UNDERGONE A FAIR AMOUNT OF
STRAIN AND STRESS THE QUESTION
THEN BECOMES WHERE DO WE STAND
NOW. THE FIRST YET THERE IS A
LOT OF UNCERTAINTY FOR THIS
QUESTION AND NO SATISFACTORY
ANSWERS YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD A
LOT OF MEDIA REPORTS AND TALKING
TO THE TEACHERS THAT WE'RE
FAMILIAR WITH WE KNOW THERE HAS
BEEN A LOT OF. A PANDEMIC
RELATED WORK STRESS- BUT I THINK
WILL ALSO GO THROUGH. SOME
PIECES OF DATA TODAY THAT KIND
OF SUGGESTS THAT. CONCERNS ABOUT
MASSIVE ACCIDENTS OUT OF THE
TEACHER WORKFORCE MIGHT NOT
NECESSARILY BE GROUNDED IN THE
DATA THAT WE SEE RIGHT NOW. SO
AND TO SORT OF INFORMAL
CONVERSATION I WANT TO DISCUSS
SOME FACTORS THAT MAY BE DRIVING
UP DEMAND FOR TEACHERS AS WELL
AS DRIVING DOWN DEMAND AND THEN
WE'LL DISCUSS SOME INDICATORS
THAT WE USUALLY LOOK AT WHEN.
GAUGING I TEACHER SUPPLY AND
DEMAND. SO FIRST ON FACTORS
DRIVING DEMAND- THEIR TWO KEY
FACTORS THAT I WANT TO DISCUSS
TODAY. THE FIRST IS WE KNOW THAT
KUBICA CELEBRATED SOME TEACHERS
LEAVING THE WORK FORCE EARLY I
THINK THIS FALLS INTO GROUPS SO
FIRST TO TEACHERS THAT LEAVE THE
PROFESSION EARLY. BEFORE
RETIREMENT AND THEN SECOND IS.
COMMENTS SO AGAIN A LOT OF STE
WORKING CONDITIONS A LOT OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERNS BURN
MAY HAVE CAUSED A LOT OF
TEACHERS TO JUST WANT TO LEAVE
I'M LOOKING FIRST AT THE PERFECT
TEACHERS THAT LEFT THE
PROFESSION EARLY SO THAT THE
STATE DOESN'T REALLY COLLECTED
DATA ON TEACHERS THAT LEAVE THE
WORK FORCE EARLY SO IT'S A BIT
UNCLEAR AT IN TERMS OF THIS AREA
BUT THERE IS A RECENT SURVEY
DATA FROM JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THAT REPORTS THAT THERE IS A
7% INCREASE IN TEACHERS WHO WERE
MORE LIKELY TO LEAVE THEIR
CURRENT JOB DUE TO PANDEMIC
RELATED STRESS THAT IN TYPICAL
YEARS- ADDITIONALLY THERE'S ALSO
FEDERAL DATA THAT. IT COLLECTS
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS AND
RATES OF INDIVIDUALS LEAVING
CERTAIN INDUSTRIES WE KNOW THAT
PUBLIC EDUCATION ACTUALLY HAS ON
THE LOWER END OF QUICK RATES
COMPARED TO OTHER INDUSTRIES AND
SO THAT SORT OF HELPS SET THE
GROUND SOME OF THE CONCERNS
ABOUT- TEACHERS LEAVING AND IN
THESE TWO PIECES I THINK THERE'S
KIND OF MIXED EVIDENCE THEY'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT TEACHER
RETIREMENT DATE AT SO LAST YEAR-
THE CALIFORNIA AS SEATED TEACHER
A PENSION SYSTEM CAL STIRS
RELEASED A BLOG POST THAT
SUGGESTED THAT IN THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
SAW A 26% INCREASE IN TEACHERS
RETIRING IN THE FIRST HALF OF
THE YEAR. BECAUSE A FAIR AMOUNT
OF CONCERN WE SINCE CHECKED IN
WITH POSTERS AND IT SOUND AND IT
LOOKS LIKE A TEACHER RETIREMENTS
WERE UP 8% AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
OVER PAST YEARS- WE INTERPRET
THE EARLIER DATA- OF 26% AS MANY
TEACHERS WERE PLANNING TO RETIRE
LATER ON IN THE YEAR INSTEAD DID
SO DURING THE YEAR MOST LIKELY
RETIRING WAS A LITTLE BIT EASIER
THAN DEALING WITH THE LOGISTICS
OF DISTANCE LEARNING AND
ASSOCIATED CHALLENGES- THE EARLY
TRANSFER TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO YOU ARE ON
TRACK WITH PRIOR TRENDS- SO
AGAIN TEACHER RETIREMENT DATA
WAS HER. ACTED BUT NOTHING TO
INDICATE MASSIVE AT CONCERNING
CRISIS LEVELS AT THIS POINT. THE
SECOND FACTOR I WANTED
DISCUSSING OF DRY UP TO ME. IS A
PROGRAM EXT. SO WE'VE ALREADY
DISCUSSED IN THE SUB COMMITTEE
THAT TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
WILL BE EXPANDED IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS AND DISTRICTS
WILL BE EXPECTED TO HIRE NEW
TEACHERS. WITH LOWER CLASS SIZES
AND THAT CREATES A DEMAND FOR
MORE TEACHERS AND ADDITIONALLY
THERE MIGHT BE OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT MIGHT PUT STRESS ON THIS
TEACHER SUPPLY FOR EXAMPLE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUT JANUARY BUDGET
INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
PROP NINETY EIGHT FOR LITERACY
COACHES SOME OF THESE LITERACY
COACHES MIGHT HAVE BEEN TEACHER
CLASSROOM TEACHERS. AND SO THAT
MIGHT ALSO DRIVE UP DEMAND FOR
MORE TEACHERS. I'M NEXT MOVING
ON TWO FACTORS THAT MIGHT REDUCE
DEMAND I'M SO THEIR TWO FACTORS
THAT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT.
BRIEFLY HERE THE FIRST IS
DECLINING ENROLLMENT- OBVIOUSLY
THIS TREND PREDATES KOBE BUT
DURING COVE IT IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS WE HAVE SEEN AN
ACCELERATION OF DECLINING
ENROLLMENT TRENDS. THE QUESTION
THEN BECOMES ARE THESE SHORT
TERM TRENDS THAT ARE LIKELY TO
REBOUND IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS AS WE SEE. MORE STUDENTS
COMING BACK INTO PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM. OR ARE THERE
GOING TO BE LONGER TERM
STRUCTURAL IMPACTS TO PUBLIC
EDUCATION THAT WERE NOT ENTIRELY
CLEAR ABOUT YET- AS DATA BECOMES
MORE AVAILABLE WE ARE CONTINUING
TO MONITORING THIS ADD TO
SPECIFIC FACTOR. I'M THE SECOND
FACTOR IN TERMS OF REDUCING
DEMAND MIGHT JUST BE BETTER
MANAGEMENT OF CODEPENDENT MAKE
STATE WIDE- IDEALLY AS- I SAID
SCHOOLS. UNDERSTAND HOW TO
HANDLE CASES AND OPERATES A
LITTLE BIT MORE. THAT SHOULD
HELP ALLEVIATE SOME TEACHER
STRESS RELATED TO HEALTH AND
SAFETY CONCERNS AND- HOPEFULLY-
KIND OF ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS
ABOUT LEAVING THE PROFESSION
PROFESSION EARLY BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. NO NEXT MOVE INTO
INDICATORS OF THE TEACHER MARKET
AND THEY'RE TO DATE INDICATORS
THAT WE USUALLY LOOK AT HERE.
THE FIRST IS ESTIMATED TO
TEACHER HIRES VERSES NEWLY
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS. SO
ESTIMATED TEACHER HIRES THIS IS
WHAT DISTRICTS REPORT TO CDP ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS IN TERMS OF. HOW
MANY VACANCIES AND NEW TEACHING
POSITIONS THEY EXPECT IN THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR- THIS IS
USUALLY AN INDICATOR OF DEMAND.
IDEALLY THIS REFLECTS FACTORS
SUCH AS TEACHER RETIREMENTS
CHANGES IN STUDENT ENROLLMENT
DEMAND IN DIFFERENT SUBJECT
AREAS AND SO ON. THAT WHEN WE
MATCH. THE DATA FOR DEMAND
ESTIMATED HIRES WITH SUPPLY FROM
NEWLY CREDENTIALED YOU'RE- A
CRITIC NEW ISSUE CREDENTIALS
FROM CDC FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WE DO SEE A CONVERGENCE OF
TRENDS WITH ESTIMATED HIGHER IS
DECREASING AND NEWLY ISSUED
CREDENTIALS INCREASING. SO THIS
DATA ACTUALLY COULD SUGGEST THAT
THE GAP BETWEEN SUPPLY AND
DEMAND IS. ACTUALLY NEARING IN
RECENT YEARS. I'M THE NEXT DATA
INDICATOR THAT WE LOOK AT IS
EMERGENCY CURRENT-
PREMIERLEAGUE. THE OF WEAVERS
AND PERMITS AS IT SHARE OF TOTAL
WORK FORCE WHEN IT DISTRICTS
CANNOT HIRE FULLY PREPARE
TEACHERS FOR OPENINGS THE
USUALLY REQUEST EMERGENCY
CREDENTIALS FROM CDC. THE NUMBER
OF EMERGENCY CREDENTIALS ISSUED
ACTUALLY DROPPED BY 27% BETWEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. HOWEVER THIS MAY NOT
BE REFLECTIVE OF ACTUAL DEMAND
GIVEN THAT TWENTY TWENTY ONE WAS
AN EXTRAORDINARY AND HECTIC
SCHOOL YEAR AND- ALL SCHOOLS ARE
STILL IN DISTANCE LEARNING.
LASTLY SHORT OF ANY DATA WE DO
HAVE AN ADULT DAUGHTER REPORTS I
THINK WE'RE ALL AWARE OF AT THIS
POINT. I SCHOOLS HAVE REPORTED
WIDESPREAD STAFFING SHORTAGES
AND VACANCIES IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND SOME
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS.
HAVE REPORTED INCREASES IN
PROGRAM ENROLLMENT- SO WHAT I
THINK THAT'S JUST A QUICK RUN
THROUGH OF THE DATA INDICATORS
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE AT THIS
POINT I THINK THE KEY TAKE AWAY
HERE IS THAT. THE DATA WE HAVE
AVAILABLE NOW DOESN'T SUGGESTS
THAT THERE IS A MAJOR TEACHER
SHORTAGE CRISIS BUT WE DON'T
HAVE THE FULL PICTURE GATT AND
IT'S- HARD TO TELL WHAT IMPACT
CORBETT HAD AND WILL HAVE ON THE
TEACHER MARKET- I THINK WE'LL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
SITUATION. AS MORE DATA BECOMES
AVAILABLE. IN TERMS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS- WE MENTION IN
OUR EDUCATOR WORKFORCE ANALYSIS
THAT IT MIGHT BENEFIT THE STATE
TO TAKE PROACTIVE STEPS IN CASE
THERE IS A LARGER DEMAND FOR
TEACHERS THAN SUPPLY. IN THE
NEAR TERM DUE TO CODE IT I'M THE
STATE HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
CHANGING TEACHER RECRUITMENT
APPROACHES EVERY FEW YEARS. AND
WENT ACTUALLY A FEW YEARS
WITHOUT ANY STATEWIDE TEACHER
RECRUITMENT INITIATIVES BEFORE
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN. THE STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE AT SO THE STATE
CAN SWITCH BETWEEN TARGETED
RECRUITMENT FOR THE CHRONIC
SHORTAGE AREAS AND LARGE SCALE
EFFORTS SUCH AS POST KOBE. MIGHT
BENEFIT THE STATE AND WITH THAT
I'LL CONCLUDE MY- TESTIMONY. BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU COME BACK
TO YOU NEXT WE HAVE. MERRY SANDY
WITH THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. YOU SO MUCH GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS MERRY
BIXI SANDY AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING I'M JOINED
TODAY BY TWO MEMBERS OF MY TEAM
WHO WILL HOPEFULLY HELP I ANSWER
QUESTIONS A LITTLE BIT LOOK AS
WE AS WE MOVE FORWARD. STAFFING
SHORTAGES HAVE BEEN ONGOING OF
FOR SEVERAL YEARS BUT WORSENED
DURING THE PANDEMIC THE
COMMISSION'S ANNUAL TEACHER
SUPPLY REPORT WILL BE RELEASED
THIS FRIDAY WITH A FIVE YEAR
DATA THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CREDENTIAL
APPLICATION VOLUME SHRINK
OVERALL BY ALMOST 11% ACROSS ALL
CREDENTIAL AREAS. DESPITE THIS
OVERALL DOWNTURN HOWEVER
PRELIMINARY TEACHING IN SERVICES
CREDENTIALS ISSUED LAST YEAR
REFLECTED AN INCREASE OF ABOUT
15% OVER THE PRIOR YEAR. THE
NUMBER OF EMERGENCY PERMITS
ISSUED DECREASED BY ALMOST HALF
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHICH COULD
BE DUE TO THE INCREASED
AVAILABILITY OF FULLY PREPARED
AND CREDENTIALED TEACHERS AS
WELL AS THE REDUCED NEED FOR
EMERGENCY PERMIT HOLDERS. DURING
THE CALL WITH YEAR OF SCHOOL
CLOSURES. I THINK IT IS TOO
EARLY TO TELL WHETHER THIS COULD
BE THE BEGINNING OF A TREND- THE
VOLATILITY OF STAFFING DURING
THE KOBE PANDEMIC HAS MADE IT
MORE DIFFICULT THAN EVER TO MAKE
PREDICTIONS. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES FOUR
POSITIONS FOR THE COMMISSION TO
SUPPORT DATA GATHERING RESEARCH
AND ANALYSIS OF TEACHER
ASSIGNMENT CALIFORNIA'S PK
TWELVE EDUCATION WORKFORCE
TRENDS AND TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAMS IN ADDITION TO
PARTICIPATION IN THE CRADLE TO
CAREER SYSTEM. IT IS OUR HOPE
AND EXPECTATION THAT THE SUPPORT
WILL ENABLE THE COMMISSION TO
PROVIDE GREATER INSIGHT INTO THE
EMPLOYMENT RETENTION MOBILITY
AND ATTRITION OF EDUCATORS IN
THE COMING YEARS. WHAT WE DO
KNOW IS THAT OVER SEVERAL YEARS
ABOUT HALF OF THE NEW TEACHING
CREDENTIALS AND PERMITS ISSUED
ANNUALLY BY THE COMMISSION HAVE
BEEN FOR EMERGENCY PERMITS AND
WAIVERS AND INTERNS AND THE
OTHER HALF TO FULLY. PREPARED
AND CREDENTIALED TEACHERS. THE
SITUATION IS WORSE IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION WE'RE ONLY ABOUT ONE
THIRD OF THE CREDENTIALING
DOCUMENTS ISSUED GO TO FULLY
PREPARE TEACHERS. CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF TEACHERS IS
PREPARING A CREDENTIALING AND
FOCUS MORE INTENTIONALLY
INTENSELY ON THE RETENTION OF
THE TEACHERS WE HAVE IN THE
CLASSROOM. IN ORDER TO TURN THE
CHRONIC PROBLEM WITH TEACHER
SHORTAGES AROUND. WE ALSO NEED
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
COMPLETION PATTERNS OF
CANDIDATES AND ROLLING IN
TEACHER EDUCATION. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. TWENTY NINETEEN
IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
YEAR JUST UNDER THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND CANDIDATES WERE
ENROLLED IN TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS AND JUST OVER FOURTEEN
THOUSAND OF THEM COMPLETED THEIR
PROGRAMS. AND- TEACHING
CREDENTIALS THAT YEAR. CSU IN
ROLE JUST OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND
CANDIDATES IN TEACHER
PREPARATION AND RECOMMENDED JUST
OVER SIXTY THREE HUNDRED
TEACHERS FOR CREDENTIALS THAT
YEAR. THE NUMBERS ARE SMALLER
AND CLOSER IN THE UC SYSTEM WITH
ENROLLMENT JUST UNDER A THOUSAND
CANDIDATES IN CLOSE TO EIGHT
HUNDRED CANDIDATES RECOMMENDED
FOR A TEACHING CREDENTIAL. IN
THE PRIVATE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES JUST OVER NINETEEN
THOUSAND CANDIDATES WERE
ENROLLED THAT YEAR AND FOURTEEN
THOUSAND WENT ON TO EARN A
CREDENTIAL. MANY OF THESE
CANDIDATES MAY BE ENROLLED IN
PROGRAMS THAT TAKE LONGER THAN
ONE YEAR TO COMPLETE FULL TIME
AND THAT'S AN IMPORTANT FACTOR
TO CONSIDER. MAYBE MAY ALSO BE
ATTENDING PART TIME AND SOMEBODY
OF DETERMINES THE TEACHING IS
NOT FOR THEM. IF MORTARBOARD
CANDIDATES COMPLETED PREPARATION
AND- CREDENTIALS HOWEVER WE
COULD INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
TEACHERS WHO POTENTIAL ANNUAL
IN. THE NEXT THREE SPEAKERS ON
THE PANEL MAY HAVE GREATER
INSIGHT INTO THE ISSUES THAT
IMPACT RETENTION AND COMPLETION.
PROGRAMS LIKE THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT AND THE RESIDENCY
GRANT PROGRAM PROVIDES
SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT FOR
CANDIDATES SEEKING TO COMPLETE
PROGRAMS AND MOVE INTO TEACHING.
ENABLING MORE TO WORK AT IT FULL
TIME AND IDEALLY FINISH EARLIER
SO THEY CAN MOVE INTO TEACHING.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
INCLUDES IMPORTANT TARGETED
FUNDING IT WILL COMPLEMENT
INVESTMENTS MADE IN PRIOR YEARS
TO SUPPORT AND DEVELOP THE
TEACHING WORKFORCE. I'M SO THE
FUTURE IS BRIGHT- I WILL
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS HERE AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU I
CERTAINLY WILL COME BACK TO YOU
AT NEXT WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
CSU. GOOD MORNING IT IS AN HONOR
AND A PLEASURE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS TEACHER
PREPARATION WITH YOU TODAY. MY
NAME IS DECLINE AND I AM THE
INTERIM ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR EDUCATION
PREPARATION OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
PROGRAMS HERE AT THE CSU
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. THIS IS
YOUR IS TWENTY TWO CAMPUSES WITH
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE SOME
OF THE GREAT THINGS WE ARE
DOING. OUR CAMPUSES ARE GEARING
UP FOR THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS ARE
INTEGRATED PROGRAMS ARE GROWING
AND MANY CAMPUSES HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY GRANTS TO CREATE
PROGRAMS. THE CALIPHATE SYSTEM
IS CURRENTLY ENROLLING
APPROXIMATELY TWELVE THOUSAND
TEACHER CANDIDATES PER YEAR
MULTIPLE SUBJECTS SINGLE SUBJECT
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION. OVER THE
PAST FIVE YEARS ENROLLMENTS HAVE
BEEN STEADILY INCREASING FROM
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED CANDIDATES FIVE YEARS
AGO TO APPROXIMATELY TWELVE
THOUSAND. THIS YEAR WE PREPARE A
LITTLE UNDER HALF THE TEACHERS
OF THE STATE. WITH EVERY
INCREMENTAL A MOMENT GROWTH
FIRST PROVIDED BY THE STATE THEN
DIVIDED THAT THEN DECIDED BY
EACH CAMPUS LEADERSHIP TEAM MOST
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF INCOMING
CANDIDATES. EIGHTEEN CAMPUSES
ACCOMMODATED ALL ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO ACADEMIC YEAR.
SOME CAMPUSES THAT REPORTED THEY
COULD ACCOMMODATE ALL CANDIDATES
ARE REACHING CAPACITY AN
APPOINTMENT THEY WILL NEED TO
ADD STAFF AND FACULTY IN ORDER
TO KEEP ADMITTING ALL QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES. FOR OF OUR CAMPUSES
MONTEREY BAY NORTHRIDGE SAN JOSE
AND SACRAMENTO COULD NOT
ACCOMMODATE ALL ELIGIBLE
CANDIDATES. THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS TURNED AWAY WENT FROM A
HIGH OF TWENTY TO ALLOW A HIGH
OF TWO HUNDRED. TO A LOW OF
TWENTY OF THE FOUR CAMPUSES THE
REASONS VERY FROM CHANGES AN
ADMISSIONS REQUIREMENTS THAT
ENABLE STUDENTS TO BE ADMITTED
WITHOUT HAVING TO PASS A NUMBER
OF STANDARDIZED TESTS. LARGER
THAN ANTICIPATED GROUP
INTEGRATED PATHWAYS CANDIDATES
CSU RESOURCE LIMITATIONS
TRADEOFFS BETWEEN ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS NEED TO INCREASE STAFF
SUPPORTS FOR LONG TERM GROWTH.
ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES IN THE
PROGRAM ALL OF OUR- CAMPUS
PROGRAMS NEEDS TO STAND
RESOURCES FOR STAFF HELP. WITH
MEETING ALL OTHER REQUIREMENTS
FOR BECOMING A TEACHER INCLUDING
STATE TEACHING SO. STAFF FOR
ADVICE CANNOT RECORD. AND WITH
VERIFYING BASIC SKILLS AND
SUBJECT MATTER COMPETENCY. HOW
CAN THE STATE HELP WE BELIEVE
THE STATE IS ALREADY WELL DOWN
THE ROAD IN HELPING BY
COMMITTING TO GROW ENROLLMENT AT
THE CSU THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNMENT COMMITTED LAST YEAR
TO GO ON ROMIT BY. OVER NINE
THOUSAND F. TES IN JANUARY THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED FUNDING FOR
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE THAT
WOULD SUPPORT THAT ENROLLMENT
GROWTH COMMITMENT I WOULD THE
FOUR CAMPUSES I MENTIONED THAT
COULD GROW THEIR TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS THIS ISSUE
HAS ALREADY COMMITTED TO PASS
ALONG TO THOSE CAMPUSES
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FUNDING IF
INDEED THAT FUNDING IS INCLUDED
IN THE FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT
THE SUMMER. THIS WOULD IMPROVE
THE PROSPECTS OF THOSE FOUR
CAMPUSES UNDER DISTRICT
LEADERSHIP TEAMS AND POTENTIALLY
EXPANDING THOSE TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS TO MEET
PROSPECTIVE STUDENT DEMAND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SHARE A
LITTLE ON THE CSU TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS AND I AM
WILLING TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
. THANK YOU WE'LL COME BACK TO
YOU NEXT WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
THE UC OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT.
YES HI GOOD MORNING JERRY
MCCARTY AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CLAUDIA MARTINEZ AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATOR PROGRAMS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT. I'M I'M
ALSO JOINED THIS MORNING BY MY
COLLEAGUE DR ANNA MARIE FRANCE
LAW WHO'S THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CENTER EXIT UCLA. AND THE UC
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSIN ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING WHO IS AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU THIS MORNING.
ABOUT THE UC'S ROLE IN
SUPPORTING THE PREPARATION OF
EDUCATORS AND SCHOOL LEADERS.
THE RECRUITMENT PREPARATION AND
RETENTION OF HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATORS HAS ONLY BEEN MADE
MORE URGENT AS TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS. CONTINUE TO BE
TREMENDOUSLY CHALLENGED BY THE
EFFECTS OF THE CODE PANDEMIC
CRISIS AND ITS MANY ONGOING
DISRUPTIONS TO TEACHING AND
LEARNING. THE UC HAS A LONG
TRADITION OF PRODUCING
EDUCATIONAL LEADERS FOR OUR
STATE AND THE WORK OF EDUCATOR
PREPARATION OF PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING FOR TEACHERS AS ONE
THAT ALIGNS SQUARELY. WITH THE
UC'S MISSION OF RESEARCH
TEACHING AND SERVICE. OUR
EDUCATOR PROGRAMS RECRUIT
PREPARING SUPPORT PRE SERVICE
AND PROFESSIONAL EDUCATORS AND
SCHOOL SITE LEADERS. WHO ARE
COMMITTED TO THE PRINCIPLES OF
ACADEMIC EXCELLENCE EQUITY AND
ARE DEDICATED TO MEETING THE
NEEDS OF ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE STUDENTS. THIS WORK AND
EDUCATE UC'S EDUCATOR PROGRAMS
IS ORGANIZED ORGANIZED ALONG A
CONTINUUM THAT BEGINS AT THE
UNDERGRADUATE LEVEL THROUGH
CREDENTIALING THROUGH DOCTORAL
TRAINING INTO LIFELONG
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT SUPPORT
FOR TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. AT THE
UNDERGRADUATE PREPARATION
LEVELER CAL TEACH PROGRAM WHICH
HELPS TO ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE IN
THE SUPPLY WELL QUALIFIED K.
TWELVE MATHEMATICS AND SCIENCE
TEACHERS. MY SUCCESSFULLY
RECRUITING PREPARING AND MOTOR
INTELLIGENT UNDERGRADUATE STEM
MAJORS TO PURSUE CAREERS AS
EDUCATORS. ON TODAY THE CAL
TEACHPROGRAMS PREPARED SIX
HUNDRED MATH AND SCIENCE
TEACHERS. AND NOTABLY ONE OUT OF
FOUR SINGLE SUBJECT TEACHING
CREDENTIALS AND STEM FIELDS WERE
AWARDED IN CALIFORNIA WERE
AWARDED IN CALIFORNIA. WAS
AWARDED TO A CAL TEACH GRADUATE.
AT THE POST. SKEWS ME AT THE-
BACCALAUREATE ARE. TEACHER AT.
PROGRAMS AND TO PRINCIPALLY TO
SHIP INSTITUTES PREPARE NEARLY A
THOUSAND TEACHER CREDENTIAL
CANDIDATES AND APPRXIMATELY
SEVENTY FIVE ADMINISTRATOR
CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES PER YEAR.
AND FOR IN SERVICE TEACHERS THE
CALIFORNIA SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECT THE STATE'S INTERSECT
METAL NETWORK OF TEACHER
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
SUPPORTS OVER THIRTY THOUSAND K.
TWELVE EDUCATORS ANNUALLY. BY
CULTIVATING STRONG CLASSROOM
LEADERSHIP SKILLS PROVIDING HIGH
QUALITY DISCIPLINE BASED
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING NETWORKS
WHILE MAINTAINING LONG TERM
COLLABORATIONS WITH UNIVERSITY
FACULTY FOR OVER FORTY YEARS. IN
ADDITION TO THE PREPARATION OF
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS YOU
SEE IS ALSO ACTIVELY ENGAGE IN
DOCTORAL EDUCATION AND RESEARCH
YOU SEE PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE IN
THE PREPARATION OF EDUCATION
FACULTY AND TEACHER EDUCATION
SCHOLARS BY WAY OF ITS DOCTORAL
PROGRAMS. MANY OF THESE
GRADUATES EVENTUALLY BECOME
FACULTY AND TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS NOT ONLY AT UC CAMPUSES
IN A DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE CSU
AND ELSEWHERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
LASTLY YOU SEE CONDUCTS RIGOROUS
RESEARCH AND TEACHER EDUCATION
DEVELOPING PROGRAMS AND BEST
PRACTICES FOR EDUCATORS AND THEN
IS ABLE TO RESEARCH THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND PRACTICAL
SCHOOL BASED SETTINGS. HOW WAS
YOU SEE RESPONDING TO THE
CURRENT EDUCATIONAL LANDSCAPE
FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS WE'VE
BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGE IN
INNOVATING AND MODIFYING OUR
TEACHER EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND
CURRICULUM IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THE PREPARATION TEACHERS NEED TO
TEACH EFFECTIVELY IN A POST COLD
IN ERA AND RESPOND TO THE
EDUCATIONAL INEQUITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED. BY SOCIETAL
RECKONING AROUND PROFOUND RACIAL
AND SOCIAL INJUSTICES YOU SEE
TEEPEES ARE EXPANDING ACCESS TO
TEACHER RESIDENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE FOR EXAMPLE THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAM AT UCLA
RECRUITS ARE PREPARES ASPIRING
TEACHERS DISTURBANCE STEM
COMPUTER SCIENCE AND BILINGUAL
CLASSROOMS ALL AREAS OF HIGH
NEED AND STATE. NOTABLY THIS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE AT ATTRACTING IN
GRADUATING HIGH PERCENTAGES OF
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES AND
OTHER TEACHERS OF COLOR. UC'S
PRINCIPLE LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECT IS DESIGNING INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS FOR SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS TO PROVIDE THEM
WITH THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
GUIDANCE AND RESOURCES THEY WILL
NEED. ON TO STRENGTHEN THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS THIS IS THROUGH
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY CALIFORNIA STATE
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY STATE CENTER
WHICH IS A STATEWIDE INITIATIVE
OF. THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. CALIFORNIA SUBJECT
MATTER HAS ENGAGED. IN A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CAL
COLLABORATIVE FOR. EXCELLENCE TO
CREATE INNOVATIVE ONLINE
RESOURCES AND TOOLS THE
SCIENTISTS PROVIDE CONTENT AND
PEDAGOGICAL SUPPORT- INCLUDING
THOSE FOR SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
STATE AND OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
AND K. TWELVE PARTNERS TO HELP
CALIFORNIA DEVELOP A STATE WIDE
SUSTAINABLE PLAN FOR THE FUTURE
OF TEACHER PREPARATION THAT WILL
MITIGATE CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATOR
SHORTAGE WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
ENSURING TEACHER QUALITY. AT
THIS TIME INCREASING THE
INVOLVEMENT OF OUR TEACHER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AT ALL POINTS
ALONG THE CONTINUUM A TEACHER
PROFESSION AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT IS LIMITED ONLY BY
THE AVAILABILITY OF RESOURCES.
ON AN ONGOING RESOURCES FOR TWO
CRITICAL PURPOSES FIRST FUNDING
IS NEEDED TO RECRUIT AND SUPPORT
APPLICANTS FROM LOW INCOME RURAL
AND OTHER UNDERSERVED REGIONS OF
THE STATE. AND SECOND FUNDING IS
NEEDED TO HIRE THE FACULTY AND
STAFF NECESSARY TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS IN HIGH NEED
SUBJECT MATTER AREAS- SEWING.
UC'S TEACHER EDUCATION
INITIATIVES ARE RESEARCH BASED
AND CLINICALLY ROBUST THEY'RE
GROUNDED IN THE BELIEF THAT
EDUCATED DIVERSITY QUALITY AND
RETENTION DEPENDS ON THE
CULTIVATION OF AN ECOSYSTEM OF
HIGH QUALITY. TEACHER
PREPARATION OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT DOCTORAL PREPARATION
AND RESEARCH RECRUITING
PREPARING AND RETAINING A
DIVERSE QUALIFIED WORK FORCE OF
EDUCATORS TO TEACH AND LEADING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS IS CRITICAL
TO OUR STATE'S FUTURE. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
TO DEVELOP SOLUTIONS FOR
ENSURING THAT ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY TEACHERS THANK YOU. YES
THANK YOU I WILL CERTAINLY COME
BACK TO YOU LASTLY WE HAVE. A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE LEARNING
POLICY INSTITUTE. GOOD MORNING
I'M DESIREE CARVER THOMAS I'M A
RESEARCHER AND POLICY ANALYST AT
LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE AND I
STUDY TEACHERS APPLYING BUT IN
DEMAND BOTH IN CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONALLY- TODAY I'M SHARING
RESULTS FROM OUR MOST RECENT
STUDY TEACHER SHORTAGES DURING
THE PANDEMIC HOW CALIFORNIA
DISTRICTS ARE RESPONDING. I JUST
CAME OUT IN JANUARY AND BUILT
UPON FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM A PREVIOUS
TWENTY TWENTY ONE REPORT WHICH
IS REFERENCED IN THE HEARING
AGENDA. BUT FIRST WHY DO TEACHER
SHORTAGES MATTER TEACHER
SHORTAGES IMPACT STUDENT
LEARNING HAVING MORE FULLY
PREPARED TEACHERS IS ASSOCIATED
WITH BETTER STUDENT OUTCOMES
ESPECIALLY FOR BLACK AND LATINO
STUDENTS UNDERPREPARED TEACHERS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO TURN OVER NEW
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT 42% OF
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS WHO BEGAN
TEACHING ON EMERGENCY STYLE.
PERMITS LEFT WITHIN THREE YEARS
THIS CREATES CHAU. HAS FINANCIAL
COSTS AND NEGATIVELY IMPACTS
STUDENT LEARNING. FINALLY
TEACHER SHORTAGES ARE KEY DRIVER
UP EDUCATIONAL INEQUITY STUDENTS
OF COLOR AND FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES ARE MORE LIKELY TO BEAR
THE BRUNT OF SHORTAGES. THE
NUMBER OF SUBSTANDARD
CREDENTIALS IN PERMITS TRIPLED
BETWEEN TWENTY TWELVE THIRTEEN
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN I
THESE CAN ONLY BE ISSUED AS AS
MENTIONED BEFORE I WANT TO FULLY
CREDENTIALED TEACHER IS NOT
AVAILABLE MAKING THEM A KEY
INDICATOR OF SHORTAGES.
EMERGENCY STYLE PERMITS AND
WAIVERS ISSUED TO ARE LEAST
PREPARED TEACHERS HAVE GROWN
SEVEN FOLD THESE NUMBERS TELL US
THAT SHORTAGES HAVE BEEN
PERSISTENT AND GROWING AND THAT
THE INDIVIDUALS WITH THE LEAST
PREPARATION ARE INCREASING IN
NUMBER AT THE VERY FASTEST RATES
IN SOME. AT THE TEACHER SHORTAGE
WAS ALREADY A DIRE SITUATION
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WE DECIDED
TO LEARN HOW CALIFORNIA
DISTRICTS WERE EXPERIENCING
RETIREMENTS RESIGNATIONS
VACANCIES AND HIRING DURING THE
PANDEMIC IN SUMMER TWENTY ONE WE
SURVEYED DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENTS AND
ADMINISTRATORS FROM TWELVE
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING EIGHT. OF THE LARGEST
AND FOR SMALL RURAL DISTRICTS.
AS WE KNOW THAT THEIR CHALLENGES
CAN BE DISTINCT IN TOTAL THESE.
ARE ONE ANSWER CAL STUDENTS.
COMPARED TO PRE COPING YEARS WE
FOUND THE DISTRICTS HAD MORE
TEACHER VACANCIES BEFORE THE
BEGINNING OF THIS SCHOOL YEAR
AND THOSE VACANCIES WERE HARDER
TO FILL. WE FOUND TWO PRIMARY
REASONS FOR THIS FIRST MANY
DISTRICTS ATTRIBUTED HIGHER
VACANCY RATES TO INCREASE
RETIREMENTS OR RESIGNATIONS OVER
PRE COOK YEARS. IN ONE LARGE
DISTRICT RESIGNATIONS INCREASED
BY ABOUT TWO THIRDS THAT'S
NEARLY 70% COMPARED TO BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC SMALL WORLD
DISTRICTS TOLD IS THAT LOSING
EVEN ONE TEACHER HAD A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON STAFFING
OF COURSE OFFERINGS. THE SECOND
REASON DISTRICTS EXPERIENCED
GREATER VACANCIES THIS YEAR WAS
BECAUSE THEY WERE ABLE TO CREATE
ADDITIONAL TEACHING POSITIONS
WITH RECOVERY FUNDS THESE
POSITIONS WERE CRITICAL TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS COMING
BACK TO SCHOOL AFTER. AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OF DISRUPTED
LEARNING ONE ADMINISTRATOR TOLD
US. WE TYPICALLY HIRE AROUND A
HUNDRED FORTY EACH YEAR THIS
YEAR WE'VE HIRED THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE SO FAR. EVERY
DISTRICT IN OUR STUDY HAD HIRED
AT LEAST SOME TEACHERS ON SUB
STANDARD CREDENTIALS AND PERMITS%
WITH THE MOST DIFFICULT
POSITIONS TO FILL BEING THOSE
CHRONIC SHORTAGE SUBJECTS MATH
SCIENCE SPECIAL EDUCATION
BILINGUAL EDUCATION. HOWEVER
MANY DISTRICTS WERE ALSO WORKING
TO MITIGATE THE SHORTAGES FIRST
DISTRICTS WERE INCREASING
COMPENSATION FOR TEACHERS AND
SUBSTITUTES SECOND DISTRICTS FOR
INVESTING IN STUDENT SUPPORTS
LIKE- HIRING COUNSELORS AND
OTHERS OTHER US SUPPORT STAFF
FOR STUDENTS- AND ALSO TO EASE
THE WORKLOAD ON TEACHERS WE KNOW
THAT WORKLOAD. AND STRESS
INFLUENCE TEACHERS FEELINGS
ABOUT STAYING IN THE PROFESSION.
THIRD DISTRICTS REPORTED TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF STATE GRANT FUNDS
TO CREATE HIGH RETENTION
PATHWAYS INTO TEACHING THEY USED
A CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
FUNDS AND FUNDS FOR TEACHER
RESIDENCIES- DISTRICTS WITH
ESTABLISHED RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
EXPLAINED THAT THEY HELP THEM
NAVIGATE. THE UNCERTAINTY OF THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE THEY COULD
COUNT ON HAVING A CERTAIN NUMBER
OF NEW TEACHERS IN HARD TO STAFF
SUBJECTS AND LOCATIONS. FINALLY
DISTRICT MITIGATED SHORTAGES BY
INCREASING THE RECRUITMENT AND
HIRING CAPACITY TO BE MORE
COMPETITIVE. IN RECENT YEARS THE
STATE HAS TAKEN IMPORTANT STEPS
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES
RAISED IN OUR PREVIOUS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TEACHER SHORTAGE
REPORT DESCRIBED IN THE AGENDA
FOR THIS HEARING. AND YOU'LL
HEAR ON A LATER PANEL JUST LAST
YEAR THE STATE INVESTED OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS IN BUILDING THE
TEACHER PIPELINE WITH FUNDS FOR
TEACHER RESIDENCIES TEACHER
SCHOLARSHIPS AND MORE THE STATE
HAS ALSO INVESTED IN SUPPORTING
THE WORK FORCE WE HAVE WHICH IS
EQUALLY IMPORTANT. FOR
ADDRESSING SHORTAGES THERE ARE
INCENTIVES FOR NATIONAL BOARD
CERTIFIED TEACHERS AND FUNDS ARE
FOR THOSE PURSUING THAT
CERTIFICATION THIS WILL HELP
BUILD A POOL OF TEACHER MENTORS
TO SUPPORT NEW TEACHERS COMING
INTO THE FIELD. THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN OUR MOST
RECENT JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
REPORT SUGGEST WAYS TO BUILD
UPON THESE INVESTMENTS AND
STRENGTHEN THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN WELL
PREPARED TEACHERS. ON THE
RECRUITMENT SIDE A STATE WIDE
RECRUITMENT INITIATIVE IS
CRITICAL BECAUSE NAVIGATING THE
PROCESS OF BECOMING A TEACHER IN
CALIFORNIA CAN BE COMPLEX. AND
DAUNTING. THERE ARE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF PREPARATION PROGRAMS
CREDENTIALING REQUIREMENTS. TEST
SPEEDS. AND MORE IT WILL BE
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE TO LOOK
BEYOND PROMOTIONAL OR MARKETING
CAMPAIGNS- AND TO REALLY ENSURE
THAT THERE ARE TOUCH POINTS FOR
CAREER COUNSELING THAT HELP
PEOPLE NAVIGATE THE PROCESS AND
ADDRESS POTENTIAL BARRIERS.
HIGHER ADIPOSITY BUILDING IS
ALSO CRUCIAL TEACHER PREP
PROGRAMS WILL NEED TO WILL NEED
SUPPORT TO ENROLL MORE
CANDIDATES IN HIGH DEMAND FIELDS
LIKE MATH AND SCIENCE. TO
IMPLEMENT THE STATE'S NEW
STANDARDS FOR GENERAL AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS AND
TO PREPARE MORE EARLY EDUCATORS-
WHICH WILL BE CRITICAL AS THE
STATE WORKS TO CHEAP UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL. I THE STATE COULD
ESTABLISH CAPACITY BUILDING
GRANTS- SYSTEM A SIMILAR PROGRAM
FUNDED TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN- AND WAS
SUCCESSFU. IN LAUNCHING NEW
FOUR YEAR INTEGRATED TEACHER
PREP PROGRAMS IN CERTAIN HIGH
NEED FIELDS. THE STATE COULD
ALSO CONSIDER SUPPORTING TO PUSH
TO PROGRAMS THAT MAKE A TEACHER
PREP MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
CANDIDATES WHO MIGHT NOT ALREADY
HAVE. ACCESS TO TEACHER
EDUCATION THIS CAN SUPPORT RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND CAN HELP WITH
TEACHER DIVERSITY. INCREASING
ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE
PREPARATION IN THESE WAYS ALSO A
RETENTION STRATEGY TEACHERS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO STAY IN THE
FIELD. WHEN THEY'VE HAD ROBUST
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE AND COURSE
WORK BEFORE BEGINNING TEACHING.
I'M IN ADDITION COMPENSATION
MATTERS TEACHER SALARIES ARE
LOCALLY BARGAINED BUT THE STATE
CAN IMPROVE- TEACHER INCOME BY
REDUCING DEBT AND IT DRAFTING
HIGH HOUSING COSTS THE STATE HAS
TAKEN SOME OF THE STEPS FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE GOLDEN STATE
PROGRAM. BUT A DIGITAL STEPS
COULD BE TAKE- RECENT OR ANTI
HOUSE AND HEALTH RECORD
PROVIDING FUNDS FOR PLANNING AND
CAPITAL COSTS FOR PROJECTS TO
PROVIDE SUBSIDIZED HOUSING FOR
SCHOOL STAFF. IN ACCORDING TO
THAT REPORT SANTA CLARA UNIFIED
HAS HIGH DEMAND FOR ITS HOUSING-
AND TEACHERS WHO RECEIVE THIS
HOUSING HAVE ATTRITION RATES.
TWO THIRDS LOWER THAN THEIR
COUNTERPARTS WHO DO NOT. FINALLY
IMPROVED WORKING CONDITIONS ARE
KEY TO RETAINING TEACHERS
SEVERAL STATES NORTH CAROLINA
KENTUCKY OHIO OREGON AND SO ON
ADMINISTER REGULAR. TEACHER
TEACHER WORKING CONDITIONS
SURVEYS TO UNDERSTAND THE
FACTORS. IMPACTING TEACHER
RETENTION IN ORDER TO INFORM
IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS IN
CALIFORNIA COULD CONSIDER A
SIMILAR EFFORT. TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU-
YEAH SO THIS IS AN OVERVIEW OF
THAT OF THAT WORK FOR SHORTAGE
CRISIS AND THEN ISSUE NUMBER TWO
IS AN OVERVIEW OF THE ACTIONS
FROM THE FROM THE LAST YEAR ON
THIS ISSUE AND THEN THREE IS THE
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSALS SO
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR AN ISSUE TO
NOW AND THEN HAVE A CHANCE TO
ASK QUESTIONS ON BOTH THESE TWO
ISSUES COMBINED. I ISSUE NUMBER
TWO IS THE OVERVIEW. OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
pMAY RELATE TO THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHERS PROGRAM TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAM IN THE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM. THE FIRST
L. A. L. IN CITY THROUGH NAY
COMMISSION AND CTC. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AMY LEE WITH THE L.
A- AGAIN- I WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF THE EDUCATOR
PIPELINE PROGRAMS THAT RECEIVED
FUNDING AND CURRENT YEAR
ALTOGETHER THERE ARE SIX
PROGRAMS I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
MENTIONED IN YOUR AGENDA ARE THE
FIRST THREE ARE DESCRIBED IN THE
TOP ROWS OF THE TABLE ON PAGE
FOUR OF YOUR AGENDA- AND THEN
THE SUBSEQUENT THREE I THINK
I'LL JUST ADD THIS DESCRIBE EVER
PLAY. SO- THE GOLDEN STARTING
WITH THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER
GRANT PROGRAM THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET PROVIDED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND THIS PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED BY C. SACK AND
PROVIDES TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS WHO AGREE
TO TEACH FOR FOUR YEARS IN HIGH
NEED SUBJECT AREAS AT SCHOOLS
WHERE ARE THERE ARE MORE THAN
55% OF STUDENTS LOW INCOME OR
ENGLISH LEARNERS. AND TEACHERS
ARE WHO ARE UNABLE TO MEET THIS
FOR YOUR TEACHING REQUIREMENTS
ARE REQUIRED TO PAY BACK A
PORTION OF GRANT FUNDS- MOVING
ON TO THE TEACHER. GRANT PROGRAM
SO THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET PROVIDED THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION ONETIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT OVER
FIVE YEARS. THIS PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED BY CTC- OF YOURS
PANELS HAVE ALREADY DISCUSSED.
ASPECTS OF THE TEACHER RESIDENCY
PROGRAM I'LL JUST MENTION THAT
THERE ARE TWO TYPES OF GRANTS
GRANTS THAT ARE PROVIDED FIRST-
PLANNING GRANTS OF UP TO TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THIS ISTO BUILD
CAPACITY FOR THE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN ALLEY AS AND HIGHER AT
INSTITUTIONS. RUNNING TEACHER
PREP PROGRAMS IN THE SECOND-
RESIDENCY GRANTS OF UP TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
RESIDENT- BUT THAT IS. IN AND
ROLLED IN A NEW OR EXPANDED
PROGRAM- UNDER THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET PACKAGE. I
LIAISE RECEIVING GRANTS ARE NOW
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE AN EIGHTY
CENT MATCH FOR EVERY DOLLAR
GRANT STE- FUNDING FROM THE
STATE. OTHERS ALSO ADDITIONAL
PRIORITY GIVEN TO APPLICANTS WHO
DEMONSTRATE A COMMITMENT TO
INCREASING DIVERSITY AND THE
TEACHING WORK FIRST. AND HAVE A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE THAN OTHER
AFRICANS OF UNDUPLICATED PUPILS
AND HAVE ONE OR MORE SCHOOLS
THAT EXHIBIT ONE OF THE
FOLLOWING. AB CHARACTERISTICS
INCLUDING A SCHOOL WHERE 50% OR
MORE OF THE- PEOPLES ARE
ENROLLED IN FREE OR REDUCED
LUNCH. OR AT A SCHOOL THAT IS
EITHER LOCATED IN A RULE OR
DENSELY POPULATED AREA. NEXT
MOVE ONTO A CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PROGRAM. THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET PROVIDED ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
PROP NINETY EIGHT OVER FIVE
YEARS. . D. C. A COMPETITIVELY
AWARDS THESE GRANTS. ON THESE
THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE OF GRANTS UP TO
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
PARTICIPATE OVER FIVE YEARS TO
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEE OR
EMPLOYEES SUCH AS- INSTRUCTIONAL
AIDES BUS DRIVERS CAFETERIA
WORKERS TO PURSUE THEIR TEACHING
CREDENTIAL. IN ADDITION TO
EXISTING PROGRAM CRITERIA- THAT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
PACKAGE GIVES PRIORITY TO LBJ'S
MEETING ANY OF THE FOLLOWING.
INCLUDING NOT HAVING PREVIOUSLY
ROOF RECEIVED FUNDING HAVING A
HIGHER SHARE THAN OTHER
APPLICANTS UNDUPLICATED PUPILS
AND HAS A PLAN TO ADDRESS
STAFFING NEEDS FOR EXPANDED
LEARNING PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
KINDERGARTEN AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION FOR. THE NEXT THREE
PROGRAMS ARE DISCUSSED IN YOUR
AGENDA AND WE'RE ALSO NEWLY
FUNDED IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET. THESE INCLUDE AT THE
NATIONAL BOARD CERTIFICATION
INCENTIVE PROGRAM- THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET PROVIDED
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT OVER
FIVE YEARS. THIS PROGRAM IS IT
ADMINISTERED BY C. D. E. AND
PROVIDES TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR AWARDS FOR IT NATIONAL
BURKE BOARD CERTIFIED TEAHERS.
WHO COMMIT TO WORKING IN A LOW
INCOME SCHOOL OVER FIVE YEARS.
AND ALSO PROVIDES TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR ANY TEACHER
AT A LOW INCOME SCHOOL WHO NEWLY
COMPLETES THAT NATIONAL BOARD
CERTIFICATION PROCESS. NEXT IS
COMPUTER SCIENCE SUPPLEMENTARY
AUTHORIZATION GRANT PROGRAM THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
PROVIDED FIFTEEN MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. AND
THIS PER I'M- TO FIVE STOP
THOUSAND TWENTY SORRY TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED GRAND PER TEACHER
TO PURSUE A SUPPLEMENTARY
AUTHORIZATION FOR COMPUTER
SCIENCE. DISSIPATING ALLEYS ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR MATCH RURAL AND LOW
INCOME DISTRICTS RECEIVE
PRIORITY FOR FINDING. LASTLY IS
THE DYSLEXIA GRANTS TO PARTY
YOUR PREPARATION PROGRAMS AT THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
PROVIDED TWO MILLION GENERAL
FUND. AND THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES
GRANTS TO TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS TO ALIGN CURRICULUM
WITH NEW EXPECTATIONS FOR
TEACHING STUDENTS. WITH
DISABILITIES INCLUDING DYSLEXIA
ANSWER THAT CONCLUDES THIS
OVERVIEW BUT I'M SURE THAT THAT
SUCH COMPOUNDS WILL BE PROVIDING
PROGRAM UPDATES ASKING FOR EACH
OF THESE PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
AHEAD WITH THE. WE CAN GO AHEAD
WITH THE NEXT PANELISTS PLEASE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M CHERYL COTTON DEBBIE
SUPERINTENDENT OF IN THE
INSTRUCTION MEASUREMENT
ADMINISTRATION BRANCH AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I'M PRESENTING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. THE
PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT MANY EARLY
RETIREMENTS AND RESIGNATIONS
FROM TEACHERS WHICH IS
INTENSIFIED THE PERSISTENT
NATIONAL TEACHER SHORTAGE. TWO
THIRDS OF CALIFORNIA DISTRICTS
HAVE REPORTED HAVING MORE
TEACHER VACANCIES AND
DIFFICULTIES ATTRACTING NEW
TEACHERS THIS YEAR. ADDITIONAL
CREDENTIAL PROGRAMS FOR
CANDIDATES IN CALIFORNIAINCLUDE
AN ADDITIONAL TWO TO THREE
SEMESTERS AFTER COMPLETING A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. TWO OF THE
SEMESTERS MUST BE SPENT DOING
UNPAID STUDENT TEACHING. FOR
MANY THIS OPTION IS UNREASONABLE
FROM A FISCAL STANDPOINT. THIS
IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR SECOND
CAREER CANDIDATES THAT MAY HAVE
ALREADY THAT MAY ALREADY HAVE
HOUSEHOLDS SUPPORT. CALIFORNIA
HAS DEVELOPED ALTERNATIVE
PATHWAYS FOR TEACHERS TO EARN
TEACHING CREDENTIALS AS WELL AS
OTHER FISCAL SUPPORTS IN AN
ATTEMPT TO ALLEVIATE THE
TEACHERS' SUPPORT DID THE
TEACHER SHORTAGE. IN PARTICULAR
. TEACHER RESIDENCIES HAVE BEEN
INEFFECTIVE MEANS TO PROVIDE
TRAINING AND SMOOTHER
TRANSITIONS TO TEACHING IN HIGH
NEED SCHOOLS MANY DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE FORMED
PARTNERSHIPS WITH TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS WHERE
TEACHERS CAN BE COMPENSATED FOR
THEIR STUDENT TEACHING THIS
ALLOWS THE DISTRICT TO GAIN
ACCESS TO NEW TEACHERS ENTERING
THE PROFESSION AND HIRE THEM
STRAIGHT OUT OF THEIR TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS. THE
TEACHER CAN'T IS IN TURN ARE
ALREADY ACCUSTOMED TO THE
DISTRICT PROCEDURES AND POLICIES
AND OF ALSO EXPERIENCE WITH
STUDENTS IN THE CULTURE OF THE
SCHOOL. ASSESSMENTS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT ENROLLMENT IS
STRONG AND TEACHER RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION-AT 41% IN SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY
ENGINEERING MATH OR STEM AT
THIRTY FOUR PERCENT. THE LARGEST
PERCENTAGE OF ENROLLEES ARE
HISPANIC OR LATIN NEXT AT 46%
AND FEMALE 73% HOWEVER HE
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE EMERGED
INCLUDING A MAJORITY OF
RESIDENTS REPORT EXPERIENCING
FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS DURING THE
RESIDENTS HERE AND RESIDENTS OF
COLOR ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED. MOST RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS ARE OFFERING DISTRICT
BASED EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
TO RESIDENTS SUCH AS HAVING THEM
SERVICE SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS PARA
PROFESSIONALS OUR TUTORS. BUT
FEWER THAN HALF OF RESIDENTS ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THESE
OPPORTUNITIES. MOST PROGRAMS ARE
NOT YET BROADENING THEIR FUNDING
SOURCES AND STRATEGIES TO ENABLE
FINANCIAL SUSTAINABILITY BEYOND
THE GRANT PROGRAM AND MANY
PROGRAMS COULD STRENGTHEN THEIR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH PARTNER
ELEAZAR AND BUILD INTERNAL
CAPACITY TO SUPPORT
SUSTAINABILITY. WE KNOW THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD OFF
OF THESE EXISTING WORK FORCE
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ASSISTING THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE CTC
AND OTHER RELEVANT ENTITY
ENTITIES. TO ADDRESS THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE WITH ME TODAY IS
KRISTIN CHRIS ALLEN FROM THE
EDUCATOR EXCELLENCE AND EQUITY
DIVISION AND WE ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT PANELIST JAKE
RUNNER. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION WILL BE
JOINING US REMOTELY. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS JAKE REMEMBER HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
AID COMMISSION AND VERY HAPPY
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE- I
UPDATE ON WHERE WE ARE WITH
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP OUR STATE
ADDRESSED THE TEACHER PIPELINE
ISSUES THAT- PRIOR PANELISTS
HAVE RAISED AND- TO PROVIDE A
PATHWAY FOR ASPIRING EDUCATORS
TO EARN A CREDENTIAL. AND THEN
GO ON TO SERVE IN OUR SCHOOLS
SERVING THE MOST LOW INCOME
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNER AND
FOSTER YOUTH STUDENTS- ARE L. A.
O. COLLEAGUE ALREADY PROVIDED
YOU WITH A SHORT A RECAP OF WHAT
THIS PROGRAM DOES- WHAT I'LL
NOTE IS THAT. THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATION
FROM LAST YEAR'S STATE BUDGET
WAS A ONE TIME INVESTMENT BUT
BUILT ON TOP OF A PRIOR YEAR
INVESTMENT OF FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES EDUCATION ACT
FUNDING. ALLOWED US TO START
SERVING STUDENTS WERE ENTERING
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS AND
COMMITTED TO SERVING AS A
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER. SO
WE'RE IN YEAR ONE STILL OF THIS
EXPANDED VERSION OF THE PROPOSAL
IT'S TAKEN ON OTHER HIGH
PRIORITY SUBJECT AREAS BUT WE
ARE HERE TO. OF THE FUNDING FOR
IDEATE AND FOR STUDENTS ENTERING
SPECIAL EDUCATION. TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS. AFTER THE
ENACTMENT OF THE BUDGET AND THE
APPROPRIATION OF FUNDING THE
STUDENT COMMISSION UTILIZED OUR
EMERGENCY REGULATORY AUTHORITY
THAT WAS PROVIDED TO US IN THE
TRAILER BILL TOO QUICKLY
DEVELOPING ISSUED GUIDELINES FOR
THIS PROGRAM AS WE ARE EXPANDING
ITS SCOPE. NOT ONLY IN TERMS OF
THE- HIGH PRIORITY SUBJECT AREAS
BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF THE
PROGRAMMATIC ELIGIBILITY- TO
INCLUDE PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES.
THERE'S NO APPLICATION DEADLINE
FOR THIS PROGRAM SO THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS ON A ROLLING BASIS
SO WE ARE CONTINUING TO PROCESS
APPLICATIONS AND A WAR- STUDENTS
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE AND- QUALIFIED
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS.
YOUR AGENDA MATERIALS PROVIDES
DATA FROM LAST MONTH ON HOW MANY
APPLICATIONS THIS TECHNIQUE
COMMISSION HAS RECEIVED SO FAR
FOR THIS YEAR. WE'VE RECEIVED
EVEN MORE APPLICATIONS FROM THE
SPRING TERM AND THE TIME SENSE.
SO AS OF THIS WEEK- THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION HAS RECEIVED
APPROXIMATELY. THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED TOTAL APPLICATIONS- AND
WE ANTICIPATE WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE A FEW MORE APPLICATIONS-
BEFORE THE CLOSE OF THIS YEAR
AND AGAIN WE ARE CONTINUING TO
PROCESS THOSE APPLICATIONS AND
ISSUE CHECKS. ON THAT ULING
BASIS. I'M PLEASED TO SHARE- I'M
UPDATE ON WHERE WE ARE IN
EXTENDING HE FUNDS THAT HAVE
BEEN APPROPRIATED TOWARD THIS
PROGRAM I'LL START WITH THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
EDUCATION ACT FUNDING TO IDEATE
FUNDING THAT WAS FIRST
APPROPRIATED IN THAT TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT. AND ACTUALLY
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION NOW
HAS OR WILL IN THE NEXT WEEK I
HAVE EXPENDED ALL OF THAT
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATIONS. BILL SPONSORED
BEEN AWARDED TO A ONE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
STUDENTS THAT MADE- THEIR
TEACHER COMMITMENT TO ENTER THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION SUBJECT OR
AREA. AT A HIGH PRIORITY SCHOOL
AS DEFINED IN STATUTE SERVING
THOSE LARGE NUMBERS OF ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND FOSTER YOUTH
STUDENTS. ON THE GENERAL
APPROPRIATION- MADE LAST YEAR-
COMMISSION HAS BEEN ASKED TO A
WORD TO QUALIFIED STUDENTS OVER
A FIVE YEAR PERIOD. SO FAR WE
HAVE EXPANDED ABOUT SEVENTEEN
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS OF
THAT APPROPRIATION. WELL THIS IS
A SMALL FRACTION OF THE TOTAL
AVAILABLE FUNDS AGAIN WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT THIS OVER THAT
FIVE YEAR PERIOD AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE'RE STILL IN
YOUR ONE OF THIS PROGRAM AND
WORKING TO STRENGTHEN. MARC
OUTREACH PARTNERSHIPS
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE NEW
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ELIGIBLE. AND
MAY NOT BE ADMINISTERED BY AN
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER EDUCATION
ARE COLLEGE OF EDUCATION BUT
WHAT PRIORESS TO PARTNER WITH
OUR LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES. SO
FAR ABOUT SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND IT'S BEEN AWARDED TO
STUDENTS I'M NOT REPRESENTS
ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS
WILL RECEIVE SOME KIND OF A WAR
AND THOSE- CHECKS CONTINUE TO BE
ISSUED ON A WEEKLY BASIS. MOVING
FORWARD WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TO
MAKE THE APPLICATION AVAILABLE-
FOR THE FUTURE HERE- STARTING
ACTUALLY IN JUST A COUPLE WEEKS
IN APRIL I'M HOWEVER CURRENT
STATUTORY LANGUAGE WOULD NOT
ALLOW THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
TO INFORM US YOU CAN THAT
THEY'RE AWARDED A GRANT. UNTIL
THEY ACTUALLY ENROLL IN THERE A
TEACHER CREDENTIAL PROGRAM- THIS
WOULD REQUIRE AN AMENDMENT YOUR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AS WELL AS
ARE CURRENTLY APPROVED
REGULATIONS. AND WE PROVIDED
LANGUAGE TO THE COMMITTEES OF
THE BUDGET COMMITTEES AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT WOULD
ADDRESS. THOSE ISSUES.
ADDITIONALLY WE SUGGESTED
ANOTHER TECHNICAL MODIFICATION
THAT WILL HELP US BETTER SERVE
STUDENTS WHO WERE SPEAKING TO US
SERVICE EDUCATORS AND BILINGUAL
OR CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
FIELDS. AS I MENTIONED OUTSIDE
OF THE STATURE. CHANGES THAT YOU
NEED COMMISSION LOOKING DEEPEN
OUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH K. TWELVE
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BETTER PROMOTE
THE AVAILABILITY OF THESE AWARDS
AND WHILE WE HAVE EXISTING
COMMUNICATION CHANNELS WITH OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION PARTNERS IN
COLLEGES OF EDUCATION. IF THOSE
NEW NEWLY ELIGIBLE ELLIE A
PROGRAMS WHERE WE KNOW WE CAN
PARTICULARLY- DEEP AND OUR REACH
. AND OF COURSE WE RECOGNIZE HOW
CUTE THE TEACHER STAFFING
SHORTAGES AS CHAIRMAN MCCARTY
AND OTHER PANELISTS NOTED IN THE
EARLIER REMARKS SO- WERE OF
COURSE A VERY MOTIVATED TO WORK
WITH ANYONE WHO'S INTERESTED TO
HELP. GET THE WORD OUT ACROSS
THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM ABOUT THE
AVAILABILITY OF THESE AWARDS A
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THAT WE HAVE
SEVERAL MORE YEARS OR WE CAN
EXPAND THESE BONDS AND CONTINUE.
TO PROVIDE THIS FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
THAT OUR PANELISTS HAVE
MENTIONED AROUND THE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES AND HARDSHIPS
PARTICULARLY DURING THE
RESIDENCY PERIOD. SO WITH THAT
AT ALL- STOP MY COMMENTS THERE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO ANY OF YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU LASTLY WE'LL GO BACK TO THE
CTC. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
VERY BIG SEE SANDY WITH
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING THE STATE HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
EDUCATED WORKFORCE INITIATIVES
THAT SHOW GREAT PROMISE IN THEIR
ABILITY TO DRAW PROSPECTIVE
TEACHERS INTO THE PROFESSION AND
SUPPORT THEIR PREPARATION FOR
CREDENTIAL. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THESE INVESTMENTS ESTABLISHED
SIXTY ONE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE CREDENTIALED THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN TEACHERS
TO DATE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN OF THEM IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE AND STEM THIRTY ONE IN
MULTIPLE SUBJECTS IN SEVENTY
FIVE IN BILINGUAL EDUCATION. 70%
OF THESE RESIDENTS SELF IDENTIFY
AS BILINGUAL INDIGENOUS FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR. INVESTMENTS IN
THE CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING PROGRAM
HAS SUPPORTED FIFTY THREE GRANTS
YEAH AND TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SLOTS. ARE AND HAVE LED TO
THE ISSUANCE OF 10003100403% NOT
PRELIMINARY CREDENTIALS EARNED
SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN MORE THAN
HALF OF THESE HAVE BEEN IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION. ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY ONE OF THEM HAVE BEEN
IN STEM AND CLOSE TO FIVE
HUNDRED AND MULTIPLE SUBJECTS
AND OVER A HUNDRED IN BILINGUAL
EDUCATION. AS WITH RESIDENCIES
THIS PROGRAM IS ATTRACTING A
MORE DIVERSE POPULATION OF
FUTURE TEACHERS WERE EFFECTIVE
GROW YOUR OWN LOCAL STRATEGIES.
WITH THIS YEAR'S INVESTMENT OF
JUST UNDER FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
A YEAR THESE TWO PROGRAMS ARE
POISED TO BRING TO BUILD ON THIS
EARLY BEGINNING. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE INCLUDES SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND FIVE POSITIONS AT
THE COMMISSION WHICH WILL ENABLE
THE COMMISSION TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE GRANT
PROGRAMS. OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS. COMMISSION IS OFFERING TO
SUBMISSION WINDOWS PER YEAR FOR
ELEAZAR SEEKING THESE GRANTS AND
THE OPERATIONAL SUPPORT PROVIDED
TO THE COMMISSION IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. WILL ENABLE US TO
ENGAGE WITH THE- YEAH I AM
TEACHER PREPARATION COMMUNITIES
TO SUPPORT PARTNERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT AND EXTEND THE REACH
OF THESE PROGRAMS STATEWIDE.
WITH RESPECT TO THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER ADDITIONAL ONGOING
FUNDING IS NEEDED IT MAY BE TOO
EARLY TO TELL. SUSTAINING AND
PROTECTING THE INVESTMENT IN
THESE PROGRAMS WILL BE IMPORTANT
HOWEVER IN THE COMING YEARS TO
ENSURE STABILITY AND THE HELP
THE STATE SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED
TEACHER SHORTAGES. THANK YOU I'D
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. OKAY THANK YOU
WE'LL HAVE IT A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS NOW FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BEFORE WE GET TO THE
SHOULD NUMBER THREE WHICH IS THE
THAT PROPOSAL'S GOING FORWARD
I'M A START OFF WITH MR MEDINA
AND THEN MISTER O'DONNELL AND
ALL THAT MR LEE WITH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- THANK YOU TO THE
PALACE I THINK THERE
PRESENTATION IS- TIMELY AND VERY
INFORMATIVE. AND I CANNOT HELP
BUT MKE A NOTE THAT IT SEEMS TO
ME AS A FORMER TEACHER OF
SITTING HERE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
FROM LONG BEACH ALSO A FORMER
TEACHER HOW MUCH EDUCATION IS
CHANGED IN JUST THE LAST YEAR
AND EVERYTHING THAT THE STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS HAVE BEEN THROUGH
AND WHAT THIS COUNTRY HAS BEEN
THROUGH IN THE LAST YEAR. SO I
FOUND IT VERY INFORMATIVE BUT I
WANT TO DOUBLE LITTLE BIT DEEPER
INTO SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE BROUGHT UP- I HEARD ABOUT
THE NUMBERS I HARD NUMBERS AND
THE NUMBER OF TEACHERS THAT ARE
NEEDED THE NUMBER OF THE
SHORTAGE YOU KNOW IT WHEN I WAS
A TEACHER I REALIZE THAT MANY
TEACHERS WERE LIKE ME OLDER AND
READY TO RETIRE AND NOW WE'VE
SEEN THAT. NUMBERS INCREASE- BUT
MORE THAN JUST THE NUMBERS.
KEEPING IN MIND HOW MUCH
EDUCATION IS CHANGED IN THE LAST
YEAR- BOTH. BECAUSE OF COVERT
AND THE- ONE YEAR THAT WE
EXPERIENCE- THE BLACK LIVES
MATTERS IN THE- OFFICES ON
SOCIAL JUSTICE ONE THING THAT I
DID NOT HEAR. VERY MUCH ABOUT
AND I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR MORE IS
THE DIVERSITY OF THE TEACHING OF
FIELD. I THINK OF THE PRESENTER
FROM- UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND IT ALLUDED TO THAT YOU KNOW
HOW WELL TEACHERS ARE PREPARED I
KNOW. IS I WAS A FIRST YEAR
TEACHER AT ONE TIME AND ALSO THE
FACT THAT STUDENTS. WE KNOW AND
THE DATA SHOWS DO BETTER. WHEN
THEY HAVE TEACHERS WHO LOOK LIKE
THEM STANDING IN FRONT IN THE
CLASSROOM. SO THOSE ARE A COUPLE
OF THINGS I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM
MOST OF THE PANELISTS FROM UC
FROM CSU FROM DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT. TONY THURMOND IN
HIS FIRST YEAR SAID IT WAS GONNA
BE A BIG EFFORT ON HIS PART TO
CHANGE THE- THE COME WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE WITH THE WHO THE
TEACHERS ARE. SO I'D LIKE TO
HEAR MORE ABOUT HOW WE'RE DOING
DO WE HAVE DATA FROM THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHING
CREDENTIALING AND WHAT WHAT IS
THE WHAT IS THAT WHAT ARE THE
NUMBERS- ETHNICALLY WHAT WHAT
ARE THE NUMBERS RACIALLY HOW ARE
WE DOING. AND IMPROVING THE
NUMBER OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
TEACHERS ARE WE DOING WITH
LATINO TEACHERS AND I LAST THING
AND I DO WANT TO HEAR FROM CSU
UC- WHERE ARE WE IN PREPARING
TEACHERS. WHO WILL BE- GOING TO
THE HIGH SCHOOLS TO TEACH ETHNIC
STUDIES I KNOW THERE ARE SOME
PROGRAMS AT UC AND I BELIEVE CSU
HAS A PROGRAMS AS WELL SO I KNOW
THAT'S A LOT BUT I DO WANT TO
HEAR- RESPONSE. UC CSU A
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
COMMISSION OF TEACHING
CREDENTIALING AND ANYBODY ELSE
WHO MIGHT WANNA. CHIME IN. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING- I CAN SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT TO THE EFFORTS THAT
THAT- CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS MAKING AS FAR AS
DIVERSIFYING THE TEACHER
WORKFORCE- SO THE
SUPERINTENDENT- GATHERED A
COMMITTEE- TO COME TOGETHER AND
TO SEEK RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW
TO DIVERSE BY THE TEACHER
WORKFORCE I THINK CDC MAY BE
ABLE TO GIVE US- NUMBERS AND
STATISTICS AS FAR AS WHAT OUR
WORKFORCE LOOKS LIKE IN
CALIFORNIA- BUT PRIMARILY IT'S
FEMALE- AND IT'S WHITE. SO WE
KNOW THAT- AND WE DID GIVE YOU
SOME SOME NUMBERS THOUGH THAT
TEACHER RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
ACTUALLY ARE INCREASING- ALLOWED
MAX A NUMBER OF TEACHERS WHICH
IS EXCELLENT- AND BUT THEY'RE
NOT SEEING A HUGE RISE- AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN I THINK ABOUT
5% OF PARA MEMBER FROM THEIR
REPORT- ARE IN THOSE RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS- BUT GETTING BACK TO
OUR OUR COMMITTEE THAT WE- HAD
TRAVIS DR TRAVIS BRISTOL-
OVERSEE WE BROUGHT TOGETHER ALL
KINDS OF DIFFERENT PANELS- FROM
THE HIGH LEVELS AND- DISTRICTS
AT COUNTY LEVEL AND AT THE
TEACHER LEVEL. AND TO FIND OUT
WHAT PEOPLE ARE DOING STATEWIDE
TO DIVERSIFY THEIR TEACHER
WORKFORCE THEY PUT TOGETHER A-
RECOMMENDATION A REPORT THAT
WILL BE POSTING VERY SOON AND
WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
HOSTING A WEBINAR AT THE END OF
THIS MONTH ABOUT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS- AND THEN
SUBSEQUENTLY WE CREATED- THROUGH
OUR OFFICE OUR BRANCH- A
COMMUNITY OF PRACTICE- SO WE ARE
GATHERING REPRESENTATIVES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OUR FINDING
OUT WHAT THEY'RE DOING LOCALLY
TO DIVERSE BY THE TEACHER
WORKFORCE AND WE HOPE TO PUT OUT
A NUMBER OF. RESOURCES FOR OTHER
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA- TO IF
THERE'S NOT FUNDING AVAILABLE
WHAT ARE SOME DIFFERENT METHODS
THEY CAN USE TO DIVERSE BY THE
TEACHER WORKFORCE STATEWIDE.
THANK YOU. YES CSU OR UC. YES
HI- ARE MEMBER MEDINATHANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION- YES THAT YOU
SEE- THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
TEACHER PREPARATION STUDENTS AND
ADMINISTRATOR PREPARATION
STUDENTS ARE IS OF ONE OF THE
HIGHEST PRIORITIES THAT WE- THAT
WE- WE'VE SOUGHT AND WORKED HARD
TO- TO ADDRESS. CURRENTLY RIGHT
NOW ABOUT 34% OF OUR TEACHER
CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES COME FROM
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
BACKGROUNDS THAT INCLUDES
AFRICAN AMERICAN. HISPANICS
LATINOS NATIVE AMERICAN FILIPINO
WITH THE LARGEST GROUP ABOUT 30%
BEING CHICANA LATINA X. AND OVER
IF YOU IF YOU INCLUDED ON NON
UNDER REPRESENTED- ASIAN
BASTIONS FROM ANONYMOUS. SKEWS
ME STILL FROM NON UNDER. ASIAN
BACKGROUNDS- ON OVER HALF OF OUR
TV CANDIDATES OUR STUDENTS OF
COLOR BUT WE WANTED TO WE WANT
TO DO MORE- WE THINK WE NEED TO
DO MORE TO ADDRESS- A DIVERSE
ENGINES HELP SUPPORT A DIVERSE
TEACHER WORKFORCE- AND ONE OF
THE- STRATEGIES THAT WE'VE BEEN-
UNDERTAKING HAS BEEN MORE
INTENSIVE RECRUITMENT. AND
OUTREACH AND- IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND UNDER REPRESENTED
AREAS IN THE WORLD COMMUNITIES-
IN ORDER TO FAMILIARIZE THEM
WITH THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU SEE
HAS TO OFFER- AND THE OTHER IS-
AND MENTION THIS IN MY TESTIMONY
THE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS. WE'RE
SEEING EVIDENCE OF MUCH GREATER
DIVERSITY THAT- IS REPRESENTED
IN THOSE PROGRAMS UCLA PROGRAM-
IS HIGHLY DIVERSE AND WHERE WE
SEE THAT AS A PROMISING PRACTICE
THAT WE CAN SCALE UP ACROSS ALL
OF OUR PROGRAMS AND ALL OF OUR
CAMPUSES. AND SECONDLY- THIRDLY-
YOUR YOUR QUESTION REGARDING
ETHNIC STUDIES PATHWAYS YES WE
DO HAVE ETHNIC STUDIES PATHWAYS
THAT HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED IN
OUR UC RIVERSIDE UCLA- AND YOU
SEE MORE SAD AND I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE THE OTHER UC CAMPUSES
ARE EXPLORING WAYS TO. INTEGRATE
ETHNIC STUDIES. PATHWAYS INTO
THEIR CURRICULUM. THANK YOU AND
IT MAYBE WE COULD HEAR FROM CSU
. YES THIS IS A CLIMB FROM THE
CSU FOR THE EQUITY DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION. QUESTION WE HAVE A
GROUP OF OUR COLLEGE OF ED AND
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION DEAN'S THAT
HAVE CREATED AN EQUITY IN CLARET
AND EQUITY DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION GROUP AND THEY LOOK
SPECIFICALLY TO THIS. ISSUE ON
HOW TO DO GROW YOUR OWN AND HOW
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER IN ALL OF
THE SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES EVENTS
SO THEY ARE WORKING TOGETHER TO
DO THAT. WE HAVE A COMMUNITY OF
PRACTICE FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
WHO ARE GRADUATES AND WE BRING
THEM TOGETHER AND CREATE A
COMMUNITY OF PRACTICE TO HELP
WITH THE RETENTION ISSUE OUR
RECRUITMENT OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
STILL REMAINS. EXTREMELY SMALL
AND ABOUT 3% WE DO HAVE ABOUT
48% OF OUR CURRENT ENROLLEES ARE
LIKE YOU KNOW LIKE IN US AND SO
THE IMPROVE THE RECRUITMENT FOR
LATINOS AND LATINAS HAS BEEN
REALLY GOOD AND HAS BEEN
INCREASING OVER TIME. AND AS FOR
ETHNIC STUDIES WE ARE ON OUR WAY
TO DEVELOPING ETHNIC STUDIES
PATHWAYS AND MOST OF OUR SITE-
SINGLE SUBJECT PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU N. NOT SURE IF WE WANNA HEAR
OF- EITHER- DESIREE OR- DOCTOR
RIXEY SANDY MIGHT HAVE- ANYTHING
THAT THEY'D LIKE TO AT. YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN IF WE DO HAVE
DATA THAT WE COLLECT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION STAFF DEMOCRATIC THE
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA THAT IS
REPORTED ANNUALLY- SO IN TERMS
OF THE GENDER RACE AND ETHNICITY
ETHNIC ETHNIC DISTRIBUTION OF
TEACHERS. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FIFTY NINE POINT 1% OF THE
TEACHERS- SOUTHWARD AS WHITE. OF
THREE POINT 9% AFRICAN AMERICAN
TWENTY TWO POINT 8% IN SPANISH
OR LATINO. IN THE CURRENT
WORKFORCE ARE IN TERMS OF
ENROLLMENT IN TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAMS IN THE NINETEEN TWENTY
HERE. THIRTY NINE POINT NINE
PERCENT. OF THE ENROLLED
CANDIDATES SELF DECLARED AS
WHITE. THREE POINT 9% LACK OF
THIRTY TWO POINT 5% HISPANIC.
AND THAT'S KIND OF THE BROAD
BREAKDOWN IN TERMS OF AS BIG A
DISTRIBUTION IN THE EXISTING
ENDING INCOME WORKFORCE. AND IF
I COULD I'D LIKE TO JUST ADD ADD
ON TO WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN STATED
I'M WE HAVE LOOKED AT SOME DATA
SHOWING THAT- BLACK TEACHERS IN
PARTICULAR ARE MORE LIKELY TO
ENTER THE TEACHING PROFESSION IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH. ALTERNATIVE
CERTIFICATION PATHWAYS OR- WITH
EMERGENCY STYLE CREDENTIALS AND
PERMITS IN FACT- FEWER THAN HALF
OF BLACK TEACHERS RECEIVE ANY
STUDENT TEACHING BEFORE BECOMING
A TEACHER IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
REALLY A SOBERING FACT. WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THAT I'M HAVING THAT
COMPREHENSIVE PREPARATION IS KEY
TO BEING RETAINED AND THE
TEACHER WORKFORCE AND SO WHAT WE
SEE IS THAT ACCURATE MANY
TEACHERS OF COLOR COME INTO THE
FIELD BUT THEN THAT- THAT LACK
OF PREPARATION CAN CREATE HIGH
TURNOVER RATES THAT UNDERMINE
THAT GROWTH- AND SO YOU KNOW
IT'S IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER WHAT
THE RESEARCH SAYS ABOUT WHY.
TEACHERS OF COLOR AND BLACK
TEACHERS IN PARTICULAR MORE LIKE
TO LEAD TO ENTER THROUGH-
ALTERNATIVE CERTIFICATION
PATHWAYS IN THE KEY. FACTOR
THERE IS THE COST OF PREPARATION
AND BEING ABLE TO ACCESS TEACHER
EDUCATION- AND SO I THINK THIS
GOES BACK TO SOMETHING I
MENTIONED BEFORE WHICH IS THE
IMPORTANCE OF THOSE NAVIGATION
SUPPORT SO THAT- POTENTIAL
CANDIDATES OF COLOR CAN ACCESS
IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS THAT THE
STATE HAS MADE. IN THE
PRESIDENCIES AND THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM AND
SO ON- IN ADDITION TO POST TWO
PROGRAMS ARE THESE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS THEY CAN
CREATE A PATHWAY FROM WHERE WE
ALREADY HAVE TEACHER OR WHERE WE
ALREADY HAVE DIVERSITY IN THE
STATE WHICH IS IN OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. I'M INTO THAT IS YOU
KNOW POTENTIAL OUT OF PLACE TO
FOCUS- YOU KNOW TO INCREASE OUR
DIVERSITY. THANK ARE AND I JUST
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO CONTINUE
OUR EFFORTS TO DIVERSIFY THE
TEACHING PROFESSION. THANK YOU
ALL. THANK YOU MR O'DONNELL. IS
THE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THINK I'M I'M SEEING A MAJOR
DISCONNECT AGAIN. BETWEEN THE
CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE TO
SACRAMENTO YOU KNOW ALL THESE
PROGRAMS ARE GOOD I'M SURE THEY
HELP. BUT IF YOU'RE A NEW
TEACHER YOU'RE LOOKING TO GO
INTO THE PROFESSION LOOK AT THE
POLITICAL DYNAMIC OUT THERE. ON
THE LEFT AND THE RIGHT. RIGHT
EDUCATION HAS BEEN WEAPONIZED SO
WHAT'S GOING TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO GET IN THE CLASSROOM WILL
BETTER PAY FOR SURE AND
SOMETHING WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
ENOUGH UP HERE ALL THIS MONEY
INTO PROGRAMS IS GREAT BUT LOWER
CLASS SIZES WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
CLASS SIZES IN THE NATION THAT
SPEAKS TO STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
INSIDE THE CLASSROOM THE SIZE OF
A CLASS ALSO TEACHER MAIL. A SUB
OVER THE FALL THE CLASS SIZES
WERE LOWERBECAUSE MANY STUDENTS
WERE THERE THEY WERE QUARANTINED
RIGHT SO IN A MIDDLE SCHOOL
CLASSROOM HAVE TWENTY TO TWENTY
FOUR STUDENTS SOMETHING MAGICAL
HAPPENS RIGHT THE TONE OF THE OF
THE DAY OF THE CLASS CHANGES SO
I THINK WE NEED TO ALSO TALK
ABOUT WORKING CONDITIONS AND PAY
NOT JUST ALL THESE PROGRAMS TO
LAND PEOPLE TO SCHOOL SITE. BUT
TO KEEP THEM THERE AND AGAIN I
JUST THINK THERE'S A THERE'S A
REAL DISCONNECT AND I APPRECIATE
ALL THESE PROGRAMS I'M NOT
SAYING- THEY SHOULDN'T EXIST AS
MUCH AS I'M SAYING THERE'S A LOT
MORE WE NEED TO DO AND IT'S KIND
OF AGAIN INSIDE BASEBALL HERE
PROGRAMS PROGRAMS PROGRAMS. NOT
SALARY NOT CLASS SIZE NOT
LOOKING AT HOW PEOPLE OVERALL
LOOK AT THE TEACHING PROFESSION
AND IF WE LOOK AT YOU KNOW THE
PROPOSED BUDGET RIGHT NOW HAS A
FIVE POINT 33% KUALA AND THAT'S
CREATING A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT A
LOT OF NEW PROGRAMS IN THE
BUDGET. THEY HAVE SCHOOL
PROGRAMS ALL THAT KIND OF STUFF
GREAT GREAT EVERYONE'S AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS I WANT THEM BUT
LOOK AT THIS FIVE POINT 33% COLA
YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T DECREASE
CLASS SIZES WITH THAT YOU CAN'T
PAY PEOPLE MORE MONEY WITH THAT
THAT'S ACTUALLY CREATING A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT A STRUCTURAL
CLASSROOM DEFICIT WHEN THE ON
GOING TO. LIST FOR STATUS QUO TO
THE EXPENSES FOR NEXT YEAR ARE
GOING INCREASED THIRTEEN POINT
85% ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON
AVERAGE SEVEN POINT 5% CPI PLUS
PROBABLY HIGHER TODAY RIGHT-
INCREASES OF STIRS AND PURSUE
DISTRICTS THIS YEAR AS OPPOSED
TO LAST YEAR TWO POINT 35% THEN
OTHER COST PRESSURES THAT ARE
UNIQUE TO DISTRICTS NON CPA CPI
pTHIRTEEN POINT EIGHTY FIVE IT
EIGHT FIVE PER. AND THE OFFER
NOW. ON THE TABLE BUILT IN THE
BUDGET IS LANDED YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATORS LAPIS FIVE POINT
THREE THREE PERCENT. SO WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO. IF WE'RE
GOING. TO LOWER CLASS SIZES
WHICH WE NEED TO DO. IF WE'RE
GOING TO PAY TEACHERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE SALARY WHICH WE NEED
TO DO IF WE WANT TO KEEP THEM.
NOT JUST GET HIM IN THE
CLASSROOM. WE NEED TO ADD MONEY
INTO THAT BASE ALLOCATION- SO I
TURN IT BACK TO YOU STRUCTURE.
YES I'LL GET TO THAT IN A BIT-
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
AWESOME COMMENTS MR LEE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. I DEFINITELY
WANT TO ALSO SYMPATHIZE AND
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LONG BEACH IS ALL ABOUT
INCREASING THE BASS BUT OVERALL
GENERALLY WANT TO. THANKTHE
PANEL SERVING HERE. AND ALSO
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
CITING THE HIGH COST OF TEACHING
AND LIVING IN MY HOME COUNTY
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IT SEEMS
EVERYONE'S FAVORITE EXAMPLE. IS
MY HOME COUNTY. SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BUT THAT IS I THINK THE
REAL IMPEDIMENT WE HAVE RIGHT
WELL AS WE HAVE. MORE STAB WISH
MORE SENIOR TEACHERS AGING OUT
RETIRING RIGHT NOW. AND FRANKLY
WHO CAN BLAME THEM AFTER THAT
TWO THREE YEARS THEY'VE BEEN
THOROUGH. NOW WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW DO WE INCREASE THE
WORKFORCE OF EDUCATORS AND
EDUCATION STAFF RIGHT. I HAVE A
LOT OF CONSTITUENTS AND A LOT OF
FRIENDS EVEN IN MY AGE RANGE AT
ALL TRYING TO COME TEACHERS. BUT
THERE IS THE ONEROUS REALITY
THAT PICKUP TO BECOME A STUDENT
TEACHER. YOUR PAYING TO WORK AND
THIS IS UNLIKE MANY OTHER FIELDS
WERE IF YOU BECOME A MEDICAL
PRACTITIONER OF SOME SORT YOUR
RESIDENCY YOU GENERALLY HAVE
SOME SORT OF- CUSHIONED- ASH. IT
WOULD APPEAR PROVIDED FOR ABBOTT
THAT'S NOT THE CASE FOR MANY OF
OUR SCHOOLS EVEN IN MY EAR IN MY
SCHOOL DISTRICT ESPECIALLY IN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OR PAT IT IS
VERY VERY EXPENSIVE TO LIVE AND
IT'S A HUGE BARRIER I THINK SO I
REALLY LIKE OBVIOUSLY HAVING OUR
PROGRAMS THAT ENCOURAGE MORE
TIME NEW TEACHERS GET IN LIKE.
THE GOLDEN STATE'S FUTURE
PROGRAMMING THE RESIDENCY
PROGRAM BUT I WONDER SOMETIMES
IF THIS IS IN ITSELF KIND OF
LIKE GOING BACK TO MR DONALD'S
COMMENTS KILEY CREATING MORE
PROGRAMS A BUREAUCRACY FOR SOON
WE HAVE THINK ABOUT HOW TO
INCENTIVIZE BRING IN NEW
EDUCATORS AND NOT SAY WELL OKAY
WHEN I PUT UP ALL THIS WALL YOU
HAVE TO DO ALL THESE LITTLE
STEPS SO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN
ANSWER THIS QUESTION RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE IT MIGHT BE MORE
COMPLICATED I DON'T KNOW IF WHO
WOULD BE THE RIGHT PERSON ASKED
US TO DO IS. YOU KNOW WE'RE
COMMITTING ALMOST A BILLION
DOLLARS IN TE NEXT COUPLE YEARS
TO I INTO DEVISING OR
ENCOURAGING NEW TEACHERS A
RETAINING NEW TEACHERS ALWAYS A
STUDENT TEACHERS WOULD NOT BE
MORE SIMPLE FIGHT EVEN IN JUST
THE SAME CRITERIA TEACHERS TO
JUST GIVE THEM THE MONEY RATHER
THAN DOING ALL THESE ALL THESE
PROGRAMS BUT JUST ENCOURAGE THEM
TO HAVE THIS A WHILE YOUR
STUDENT TEACHER YOU ARE PROVIDED
FOR YOU HAVE COMPENSATION AND
YOU CAN DO THIS AND THEN YOU
COME OF TEACHER RATHER THAN
HAVING TO. WELL MAKE SURE IF I
AM IN THE RIGHT STATE YOU'RE
RIGHT SCHOOL THE RIGHT CRITERIA
ECCENTRIC ETCETERA I AM FILLING
OUT ALL THESE APPLICATIONS DOING
THESE THINGS ON TOP OF BEING A
STUDENT TEACHER WOULD NOT BE
SIMPLER TO THAT I WONDER IF IT
WOULD COST MORE COSTS LESS
THAT'S MYKINDA GENERAL BROAD
BROAD QUESTIONS OUR PANEL SAYS
WOULD IT COST MORE OR WOULD BE
OR COSTS MORE COST LESS TO JUST
PAY INCOMING SIN TEACHERS AT THE
RATE THAT WE'RE HAVING OR SEEN
THEM AT. OUR END WOULD BE.
SIMPLER JUST TO GIVE THEM THE
COMPENSATION. WHO'S THAT
QUESTION DIRECTED TO MR LEE. I
DO NOT KNOW WHO THE BEST PERSON
WOULD BE MAYBE L. A. L. I WAS
THINKING MAYBE C. T. C. A. R.
CITY SOON SURE. WEALTHY I WISH I
HAD A GOOD ANSWER FOR THAT
QUESTION I THINK IN AN IDEAL
WORLD AND IN SOME COUNTRIES THEY
DO JUSTICE THEY PAY FOR THE
PREPARATION OF THE WORK FORCE.
WE IN CALIFORNIA HAVE HAVE
ELECTED TO DO THIS. THROUGH A
VARIETY OF- OF PROGRAMS THAT DO
PROVIDE SOME SUPPORT FOR THE
INCOMING WORKFORCE THE RESIDENCY
PROGRAM. COULD B CONSIDERED A
PAID STUDENT TEACHING PLACEMENT.
OF FOR SOMEONE BRAIDED THAT-
MADE MAKING ALSO OF USE OF THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT WE
HAVE SOME ABILITY TO- TESTS TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT IT CERTAINLY IS.
OF ALL BY ITSELF TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ISN'T NECESSARILY A
LIVING WAGE IN MANY PLACES IN
THAT IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BUT- I THINK IT'S A WORTHWHILE
IDEA IN A WORTHWHILE QUESTION TO
STUDY- FOR NOW WE'RE HAPPY TO.
SUPPORT EVER INVESTMENTS IN THE
WORK FORCE. OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION BUT BEFORE
US. IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR CAN I
AWAY AND QUICKLY SO I ANYWAY
FROM THE ALLEY GO I THINK I
WOULD JUST ADD TO THIS
CONVERSATION THAT. THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAM IN THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM
THOSE ARE MORE TARGETED EFFORTS
THAT FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON THE
AREAS OF CHRONIC SHORTAGE THAT
WE EXPERIENCE OUT THINGS LIKE
SPECIAL EDUCATION IN THE STEM
FIELDS BILINGUAL. AND NOW
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN THESE
ARE VERY INTENTIONAL TARGETS FOR
THESE ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDS I
THINK IN TERMS OF YOUR IDEA IT'S
JUST A CONSIDERING THE TRADE
OFFS BETWEEN BROADER. I'M FUNDS
FOR STUDENT TEACHING VERSES THIS
MORE TARGETED APPROACH THAT THE
STATE HAS TAKEN IN THE PAST.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. OKAY THANK
YOU MR DRY. OKAY YEAH I HAVE A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS SO AS WAS
NOTED BY MR LEE- WE APPROPRIATED
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS TO THESE
ISSUES. LAST YEAR BEING SPENT
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS THIS
YEAR JANUARY BUDGET THIS HAS
FIFTY MILLION CELL I THINK IT'S
BETTER TO LOOK AT THAT BILLION.
OUR HAS BEEN THE NEXT FEW YEARS
THAN JUST FOCUSING SOLELY ON
THE- ON THE FIFTIES OF COURSE
WERE DOING LITTLE OVERSIGHT
TODAY AND THEY GO GOING FORWARD.
I GUESS THE BIG PICTURE WE'VE
HEARD THIS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IS- YOU KNOW RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION. L. WHAT'S MORE
IMPORTANT PROBABLY BOTH
IMPORTANT BUT WE KNOW WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT AS THE- AGENDA NOTES
THAT THE TEACHER. SHORTAGE ISSUE
FOR TWENTY YEARS SO I REMEMBER
WHEN I HAD THIS JOB. TWENTY
YEARS AGO THERE IS A CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS LANGUAGE THE CAL GRANT
T. FOR TEACHERS BECAUSE IT WAS
GOING TO GIVE PEOPLE MONEY TO GO
THE TEACHER PROFESSION. SO WE'VE
BEEN ON THIS CASE FOR. A LONG
TIME. AND HELLO PORTENT SO WHAT
DO WE NEED TO FOCUS ON MORE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION AND IS
IT THAT YOU KNOW THE ISSUE THAT
TEACHERS WHO AREN'T STICKING
AROUND IS THAT IT'S A STRESSFUL
JOB. AND WE'RE NOT GETTING PAID
ENOUGH I MEAN LITERALLY RIGHT
DOWN THE STREET OR HAVING A
DEBATE WITH MY LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT ARE LOCAL TEACHERS.
ASSOCIATION- SO I DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH WE CAN PUT INTO THESE
PROGRAMS THEY ALL GOES BACK TO
ARE WE ADEQUATELY FUNDING. OUR
SCHOOLS. WITH FLEXIBLE MONEY TO
ADEQUATELY COMPENSATE OUR
TEACHERS IN THIS WORK FORCE SO I
THINK WE'LL HAVE IDEAS ON HOW WE
CAN MAXIMIZE MONEY. TO OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE COMING
MONTHS AND SELL WORKED AS PART
THAT FOR NOW BUT BACK TO- THAT
THE MAYBE I CAN ASK- THE L. P.
IRCTC. ARE ARE WE ON THE RIGHT
PATH ARE WE MAKING SURE WE'RE
SPENDING ALL THIS MASSIVE
INFUSION OF MONEY THAT THE
BILLION FROM LAST YEAR AND I
GUESS A FIFTY MILLION THIS YEAR
AND THE RIGHT IN THE RIGHT SPOTS
TO REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE I
KNOW WE NEED TO PAY TEACHERS
WELL TO STICK IN THERE FOR THE
LONG RUN AND- MOST TEACHERS DO
IT NOT TO BECOME RICH BECAUSE
THEY LOVE THE JOB A LOT OF THE
KIDS. IN TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW TAKE CARE THEM ALONG THE
WAY TO THEIR INCENTIVIZE TO
STICK AROUND. BUT OF THESE EXTRA
EFFORTS WERE DOING HOW DO WE
KNOW THAT WE ARE ON THE RIGHT
PATH. I THANK YOU VERY SANTEE
WITH THE COMMISSION. I THINK
IT'S NOT AN EITHER OR-
PROPOSITION- RECRUITMENT OR
RETENTION I THINK YOU HAVE TO
FOCUS ON BOTH. IF WE ONLY FOCUS
ON RECRUITMENT AND WE'RE NOT
INTENDED TO THE RETENTION OF OUR
WORK FORCE. OF WE WERE MISSING A
HUGE PART OF WHAT'S NECESSARY TO
KEEP A STABLE WORKFORCE IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND THAT IS TO PROVIDE
THE WORKING CONDITIONS OF THE-
THE OTHER KINDS OF FACTORS. OF
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY LPI
AND OTHERS. SO IT'S ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO DO BOTH THINGS. I
BELIEVE THAT THE INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAM IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. LONG TERM
IT INITIATIVE- IT THE RESEARCH
ON RESIDENCIES IS THAT THEY ARE
PREPARING- TEACHERS WELL AND THE
TEACHERS WERE COMING THROUGH
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS TEND TO STAY
IN THE PROFESSION. AND THIS IS
KEY THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
ADDRESSING BOTH RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION BY PROVIDING SUPPORTED
WAY INTO TEACHING THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE ITSELF. IS AN
IMPORTANT ARTIFACT THAT WE NEED
TO PROTECT AS WE MOVE FORWARD-
AND IDEALLY BEGIN TO REDUCE THE
SHORTAGES THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING SO I THINK IT'S NOT
EITHER OR- AND I THINK THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS BEING
BUILT RIGHT NOW. AND PROVIDING
THAT THE FUNDING LIKE FOR THE
CLASSIFIED GRANT PROGRAMS FOR
LOCAL REGIONAL GROW YOUR OWN
EFFORTS TO BRING A MORE DIVERSE
COMMUNITY INTO THE INTO THE WORK
FORCE. THESE ARE THESE ARE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS THAT DO BUT
TEND. TO BOTH RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION. SO LET ME FOLLOW UP
ON THAT IS A THERE RESEARCH.
FOCUSING ON. WHEN TEACHERS LEAVE
WHY THEY LEAVE IS BECAUSE IT'S
IF IT WEREN'T PROPERLY PREPARED
TO THE JOB AND RESIDENCIES
REALLY HELPS THAT. MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO SUCCEED AS
ECONOMIC FACTORS OF COURSE PAID
WILL GO AND DO SOMETHING ELSE AS
MUCH STRESS. WHAT DO WE THINK IS
THAT IS THE FACTOR THERE MOST.
REPORTING FACE I KNOW I KNOW
THERE'S RESEARCH OUT THERE AND
I'M WONDERING IF DESIREE CARVER
TANYA LPI. JANICE HERO HE ARE
PROBABLY HAS DONE SOME RESEARCH
IN THIS AREA. YES MY PLEASURE A
DESIREE CARVER THOMAS THAT
LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE AND WE
HAVE STUDIED THE FACTORS THAT
IMPACT TEACHER RETENTION- AND
THERE'S SEVERAL FACTORS THAT-
ARE ARE INVOLVED- ONE ASPECT IS
ACCESS TO- AT CONFERENCE OF
TEACHER PREPARATION. SO WE KNOW
THAT THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ENTER
THE FIELD WITHOUT COMPREHENSIVE
PREPARATION HAVE- TURNOVER RATE
THERE TWO TO THREE TIMES AS
GREAT AS THOSE WINTER WITH. THE
MOST COMPREHENSIVE PREPARATION
WE ALSO KNOW THAT- ACCESS TO
MENTORING AND INDUCTION- IS
ASSOCIATED WITH GREATER
RETENTION- ACCESS TO GREATER
COMPENSATION IS ASSOCIATED WITH
GREATER ATTENTION ENOUGH IS
ALSO. THAT IMPORTANT RECRUITMENT
STRATEGY AS WELL- YOU KNOW
THERE'S- A HOST OF. WHERE
CONDITIONS THAT MATTER AND ONE
OF THE PRIMARY WORKING
CONDITIONS THAT'S ASSOCIATED
WITH- TURNOVER IS ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT SO THE RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT OUR TEACHERS WHO REPORT
THAT THEIR ADMINISTRATOR IT'S
NOT ENCOURAGING OR SUPPORTIVE
LEAVE THE PROFESSION IT OR THEIR
CLASSROOMS THAT OUT MORE THAN
TWICE THE RATE OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO SAY THAT THEIR
ADMINISTRATION. IS SUPPORTIVE
AND SO YOU KNOW THAT I THINK
POINTS TO. THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS OF SOME OF THE- INVESTMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE IN AT AT
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE C. SLA-
FOR EXAMPLE- AND ALSO THE
IMPORTANCE OF- THE INVESTMENTS
IN AS- IN PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THROUGH THE EDUCATOR
EFFECTIVENESS BLOCK GRANT- WHICH
- CAN HELP TO YOU KNOW COULD BE
USED TO- DEVELOP. TEACHER
LEADERSHIP AND- AT AN EFFICACY
SO ALL THESE THINGS ARE ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH- RETENTION AND I
WOULD. JUST ECHO THE POINT THAT
YOUR RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION-
REALLY INEXTRICABLE- WE KNOW
THAT BEING BETTER PREPARED LEADS
TO BEING BETTER RETAINED- AND SO
THOSE THOSE REALLY GO TOGETHER
IN ADDITION. REDUCING TURNOVER
RATES REDUCES THAT THE DEMAND
FOR TEACHERS SO CALIFORNIA HAS
ABOUT AN EIGHT PERCENT-
ATTRITION RATE PEOPLE LEAVING
THE PROFESSION IN THE STATE- AND
THAT IS- ABOUT AVERAGE AT ABOUT
A SIMILAR TO THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE- OF- ADD TURNOVER RATES-
STATES- THERE OTHER STATES. AND
IN OTHER SCHOOL SYSTEMS AROUND
THE COUNTRY AROUND THE WORLD
WHERE- YOU KNOW TEACHERS STATE
OF LONGER THAN THEY DO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO IF WE COULD
REDUCE OUR- TEACHER TURNOVER
RATES TO BE COMPARABLE WITH HIGH
PERFORMING SCHOOL SYSTEMS. IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY AND
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD YOU
KNOW THAT WOULD REDUCE THE NEED
TAPPED TO CONTINUALLY NEED TO
HIRE MORE NEW TEACHERS SO THESE
REAL PEACE THESE ISSUES REALLY
PUT TOGETHER. SO IF YOU LOOK AT
THE TWO FACTORS WITH WITH
ECONOMIC- FACTORS COMPENSATION
AND- A JUST SALARY BUT YOU KNOW
BENEFITS AND SO FORTH WE'RE
SUPPORT WHAT DO WE FIND IS MORE
OF AN INDICATOR AS FAR AS PEOPLE
WERE LEAVING. THE PROFESSION
EARLY ON. YEAH I IT I COULDN'T
SAY THAT WE HAVE ONE FACTOR
THAT- STAND OUT FROM THE REST IT
REALLY IS A FULL PICTURE- AND SO
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SUPPORT
TEACHERS ON ON EACH OF THOSE
FRIENDS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE COMPENSATION SO THAT
THE DOLLARS AND SENSE OF WORK TO
BE A TEACHER- WHETHER THAT'S
THROUGH INCREASED SALARIES OR
LESS THAT. LESS STUDENT DEBT
LIKE THROUGH THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM OR BY
HAVING TO SUBSIDIZE HOUSING SO
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD TO LIVE AND
WORK IN THEIR COMMUNITIES- AND
THEN ALSO THAT YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY COME TO SCHOOL THEY'RE IN
AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEY'RE
SUPPORTED TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND
YOU KNOW I WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE POINT THAT WAS MADE ABOUT
TEACHER DIVERSITY- TEACHER
WORKING CONDITIONS REALLY MATTER
FOR THAT- AND SOMETHING LIKE A
WORKING CONDITIONS SURVEY HELPS
OUT COULD HELP THE STATE. TO
PROVIDE MORE TAILORED-
IMPROVEMENTS ACROSS THE BOARD SO
THAT WE CAN SEE DISAGGREGATE
WILL WHAT ARE THE CONDITIONS FOR
MATH AND SCIENCE TEACHERS WHAT
ARE THE CONDITIONS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATORS WHICH YOU KNOW WE'VE
WRITTEN A REPORT THAT SHOWS THAT
THEY'RE REALLY DISTINCT- WHAT
ARE THE CONDITIONS FOR TEACHERS
OF COLOR IN THE STATE WHERE ARE
THERE PLACES THAT ARE DOING A
BETTER JOB AT RETAINING A
CERTAIN STAFF MEMBERS THAT. ARE
IN HARD TO STAFF POSITIONS- AND
WHAT CAN WE LEARN FROM THAT WAS
AND KIND OF SCALE ACROSS THE
STATE. SO LET'S LAST YEAR AS AS
WAS NOTED BY MR LEAD TO STEPPED
OUT WE HAD IT YOU KNOW ONCE IN
A- GENERATION TYPE OF A BUDGET
DID A LOT OF THINGS WITH. YOU
KNOW. BUT A BILLION DOLLARS INTO
THIS ISSUE. AND THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO LOOK OVER
THE PAST DECADE OR SO AND SO
WHICH PROGRAMS WE THINK HAVE THE
MOST. AMERICAN SUCCESS SO. WE'VE
SPENT THE LION'S SHARE ON THREE.
THAT THE TEACHER GRANT CONSIDER
GRANT PROGRAM TEACHER RESIDENCY
PROGRAM AND THE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES CREDENTIALING. PROGRAM
ON. THE TO MR MEDINA'S QUESTIONS
FAR AS- DIVERSITY IN. IT DO WE
HAVE. ANY INDICATION OF WHICH
ONES OF THESE. WOULD PRODUCE AND
SUPPORT A MORE DIVERSE WORKFORCE
WHEN I WHEN I SAW FOR EXAMPLE
FROM THAT CLASSIFIED TEACHER.
PROGRAM WHICH I WORKED ON THAT.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO. YEAH THE
NUMBERS COMING FROM THAT WERE
OFF THE CHARTS AS FAR AS
DIVERSITY CAN LOOK WHO ARE
CLASSIFIED IN PLACE MOST LIKELY
VERY VERY DIVERSE- DO WE HAVE
ANY INDICATORS IS THAT. MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IN THAT ISSUE ARE
SOME. MORE DIVERSE THAN OTHERS
THE THREE PROGRAMS. DAVID TO
CARE FROM. MISSION OF THE
CREDENTIAL- WITH WE CAN START
WITH LOOKING AT THE CLOCK OF
NINETY. ON EMPLOYEE FRIENDLY
PROGRAM. AND WE FIND THAT OVER
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS- ONLY.
ABOUT 30% OF THE GRANT WENT TO
CANDIDATES WHO ARE WHAT THE
CLERK IS ALWAYS BEEN WHITE SO
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE FUNDS
ARE GOING TO THE PEOPLE OF COLOR
. THE NUMBERS ARE SIMILAR WITH
THE RESIDENCY GRANTS. SO I THINK
THAT THESE TWO PROGRAMS-
DEFINITELY ARE. ATTRACTING AND
MEETING THE NEEDS OF TEACHERS OF
COLOR- I THINK IF YOU'RE-
INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT
RETENTION I THINK WHAT DESIREE
CARVER THOMAS TALKED ABOUT TERMS
OF STATE WHEN I MET STUDIES LIKE
OTHER STATES HAVE DONE THAT MAY
BE SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO LOOK AT SO
THAT YOU ARE GETTING NEARLY
DATA- FROM. THE TEACHERS IN THE
CLASSROOMS AS TO HOW THEY
PERCEIVE- BUT CONDITIONS IN
THEIR SCHOOL YES I GUESS WHAT
I'M LOOKING AT IS IF YOU IF YOU
LOOK AT THAT THIS THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF. PARTICIPANTS IS
IT IS IT ABOUT OF THESE THREE IS
IT ARE THEY ABOUT THE SAME AT
THE EXISTING TEACHER WORKFORCE
WHICH WE KNOW IS NOT GREAT. ARE
THEY SOME MUCH HIGHER AND WHICH
ONES HAVE HAD ART HAS SHOW THE
MOST PROMISE AS FAR AS-
DIVERSIFYING OUR WORKFORCE. SO
THE CURRENT TEACHER WORKFORCE IS
APPROXIMATELY 60%WHITE 40%
TEACHERS OF COLOR- THE RESIDENCY
GRANTS AND THE- CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE GRANTS. ARE
DEFINITELY GOING TO MORE PEOPLE
OF COLOR- SO THOSE ARE THOSE
TARGETED GRANTS ARE WORKING- I'M
NOT SURE ABOUT THE GOLDEN STATE
SO MAYBE SOMEONE FROM C.
SACRAMENTO ABOUT ONE. MCCARTY
THIS IS- JAKE PARTNER WITH THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION I DON'T
HAVE- BRACE THAT NEEDS TO BE
DATA OR DEMOGRAPHIC DATA OF THAT
KIND TODAY WITH ME ON THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM BUT
I'M HAPPY TO GO BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES AND SEE WHAT WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE TO YOU IN THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY. I'M LET'S SEE
BACK TO MR MEDINA COME BACK FOR
A FINAL QUESTION. ALL RIGHT I
WANT TO. THANK A DESIREE- FOR-
LISTING AND ANSWERING OUR OUR
CHAIRS QUESTION ON TEACHER
RETENTION AND TO ALSO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH YOU
KNOW WHETHER OF THE DISCONNECT
BETWEEN SACRAMENTO AND WHAT
ACTUALLY TAKES PLACE IN THE
CLASSROOM- SO I JUST WANTED TO
ADD THAT THERE ARE MANY THINGS
THAT THAT ARE. PERHAPS WITHIN
OUR CONTROL ARE NOT IN OUR
CONTROL RIGHT A TEACHER PAY THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS IN THE
CLASSROOM. YOU KNOW THOSE ARE
FACTORS THAT CERTAINLY AFFECT
TEACHERS. AND IF WE REDUCE CLASS
SIZE WE KNOW WOULD PROBABLY HAVE
BETTER LEARNING OUTCOMES AS WELL
PROBABLY HAVE- HIGHER- TEACHER
SATISFACTION WITH SMALLER LASS
SIZE YOU KNOW I IF WE LOOK BACK
EAST I'VE HEARD OF CLASSES YOU
KNOW OUT IN THE STATE OF
CONNECTICUT WHERE THEY MAYBE
HAVE. TWENTY STUDENTS PER
TEACHER AND- I'M SURE THERE
TEACHERS PROBABLY STAY LONGER
BUT THE AND PAY YOU KNOW I DO
NOT WANNA DIMINISH- HOW
IMPORTANT TEACHER PAY IS WELL I
WHEN I WAS A TEACHER CAME HERE
JOINT PROBABLY TWENTY THOUSAND
TEACHERS AND WE- ARE RIGHT HERE
IN FRONT OF THE CAPITOL. AND
MARCHED HERE OF FOR INCREASED
TEACHER PAY AND WE GOT IT THAT
YEAR. AND FOR THE NEXT THREE
YEARS THAT YOU KNOW TEACHER PAY
WENT UP BUT THOSE ARE NOT THE
ONLY FACTORS THAT AFFECT A
TEACHER SATISFACTION AND THE ONE
FACTOR THAT I WANTED TO ADD- IS
NOT TANGIBLE LIKE THAT. LIKE
THOSE YOU KNOW TO CLASS SIZE OR
TEACHER PAY AND THAT IS TEACHER
EMPOWERMENT THAT HAVE TEACHERS
FELT EMPOWERED IN THEIR SCHOOLS
IN THEIR CLASSROOM. THEY THEY
WOULD STAY LONGER AND THAT DOES
GO TO YOU KNOW THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN. THEM AND THEIR-
ADMINISTRATORS- IT THAT GOES TO
PREPARATION- IN SERVICE BUT IT
TEACHERS FELT MORE EMPOWERED I
THINK THAT WOULD DO A LOT TO-
TEACHER SATISFACTION JUST WANTED
THAT THAT. STRUCTURE OKAY. THANK
YOU. CHARMING MCCARTY YES MARK
LAUDI MARTINA WITH THE UC- YEAH
I JUST WANTED TO I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T COMMENT ON
THAT POINT IN PARTICULAR AND
RETENTION- BOTH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA MAKE GREAT POINTS ABOUT
THE WORKING CONDITIONS OF
PRACTICING TEACHERS BEING ARMED
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND I THINK
NOT. ANY MORE IMPORTANT PROBABLY
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER DO YOU
TO WHAT TEACHERS HAVE BEEN- FACE
WITH A STRUGGLING WITH THIS PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO- MENTIONED THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE INVESTMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE IN
CALIFORNIA SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECT WHICH IS THE STATE'S
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT NETWORK
IN INTERSEGMENT ALL PROGRAMS
THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ADMINISTERS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CSU AND THE
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IT'S DISCIPLINE
SPECIFICS ACROSS ALL NINE-
DISCIPLINES- IN THE STATE AND-
IT SERVES OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
TEACHERS. A YEAR PROBABLY OR NEW
DATA WILL SHOW MORE BECAUSE
WE'VE GONE TO PROVIDING
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES WITH THESE
INVESTMENTS ONLINE EXPANDING
INTO- UNDERSERVED AREAS I THINK
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE HAS BEEN
THAT THESE FUNDS THAT- THESE NEW
THIS NEW INFUSION OF FUNDING IT
IS ONE TIME STATE FUNDS THAT AND
IN SOME CASES FEDERAL FUNDS-
THAT THAT WILL EXPIRE AND SO WE
AREN'T ABLE TO CREATE THE KINDS
OF INFRASTRUCTURE AND- IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS OF THE STATE
AND WITH UNDERSERVED SCHOOLS TO
THE EXTENT THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
PERMANENTLY ON ONGOING BASIS BUT
THESE SERVICES HAVE BEEN I THINK
CRITICAL TO SUPPORTING TEACHERS-
WHO HAVE HAD TO PET IT AND LEARN
NEW STRATEGIES AND OUR NEW AND
DIFFICULT CONDITIONS- SO THIS IS
A PIECE OF THE PROGRAM THE
SUBJECT MATTER PROJECT PROGRAMS
ARE THE ONES WHERE THERE IS A
DIRECT CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
UNIVERSITIES BETWEEN OUR K.
TWELVE DISTRICTS AND PARTNERS
AND. TEACHERS ON THE GROUND
EVERY DAY A YOUR ALL YOUR ROUND
- SO JUST I'M- A WANTED TO RAISE
THAT BECAUSE THAT. WE HAVE
BENEFITTED. THOSE THE INVEST AND
WE ARE SEEING THAT THERE ARE-
PROVIDED A LOT OF SUPPORT FOR
TEACHERS ON AT THIS VERY
CRITICAL TIME. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU I KNOW THE NEXT ISSUE
IS FOCUSING ON SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS AND ONE IS THE
INTEGRATED TEACHER PREP PROGRAM
BUT I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT
OVERALL COMPENSATION IT IT'S NOT
COMPLICATED THAT IF YOU GO TO
SCHOOL FOR FOUR YEARS TO GET A
DEGREE YOU CAN GO GET A CAREER
AND LOOK AT THE AVERAGE SALARY
FOR THAT. YOU CAN GO GET A
TEACHING JOB WHICH WILL BE LESS
THAN THE AVERAGE SALARY YOU HAVE
TO GO TO COLLEGE FOR ONE MORE
YEAR YOU'RE NOT GETTING PAID FOR
THAT YEAR AND YET MORE DEBT SO.
THAT I THINK IS A FACTOR WE
CAN'T IGNORE AS WELL AND SO. I
KNOW WE'RE GONNA GET TO THAT
NEXT. BUT BUT I KNOW WE DIDN'T
HAVE ANYBODY HERE FROM. THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT FROM C-SPAN NEED
FOR- ACCELERATE THROUGH THE
MANAGEMENT SIDE. AND I WONDER- I
KNOW THERE WAS SOME REPORTS AND-
SOME. SOME EDUCATION
PUBLICATIONS LAST WEEK TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE'RE DOING ALL THIS.
PROGRAMS AND GRANTS STOP BUT
THAT DOESN'T REALLY. ON ON THE
GROUND THESE DISTRICTS IS THAT
MAKING MUCH OF A DIFFERENCE SO
THE C. T. O. R. FINANCE RALLY-
HAVE ANY INSIGHTS AS FAR AS-
WHAT DID THAT. WHAT DOES THE-
THE FIELD OUT THERE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SCHOOL BOARDS YOU KNOW
TEACHES THAT WHAT WHAT IT WHAT
DID THEY SAY IS MOST NEEDED TO
HELP ADDRESS THIS. RETENTION
RECRUITMENT TEACHER SHORTAGE
ISSUE. I'M IF I CAN SPEAK TO THE
RETENTION ISSUE A LITTLE BIT I
AGREE WITH THE PANELISTS THAT
SAID IT I THINK WE NEED
INVESTMENTS IN BOTH RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION AND WON- PROGRAM
THAT'S ACTUALLY RAN THROUGH OUR
OFFICE IS THE NATIONAL BOARD-
INCENTIVE PROGRAM THAT WENT
THROUGH LAST YEAR AT THE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- INVESTMENT. AND WE'RE
JUST REALLY EXCITED TO REPORT-
THAT WE HAD OVER TWO THOUSAND
APPLICANTS FOR THE SUBSIDY WHICH
MEANS- TWO THOUSAND MORE
NATIONAL BOARD CERTIFIED TEACHER
IS IN CALIFORNIA AND OVER
APPROXIMATELY I THINK TWENTY
FOUR HUNDRED FOR THE INCENTIVES
SO PEOPLE THAT ARE ALREADY
NATIONAL BOARD CERTIFIED- THAT
WILL GET FIVE THOUSAND A YEAR
FOR FIVE YEARS- THAT BEING SAID
I THINK MANY OF US TEACHERS-
ENTER THE PROFESSION OF COURSE I
ENTERED IT I THINK TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND A YEAR AND I WAS PART
OF THE GROUP THAT GOT THE BUMP
THAT UP TO THIRTY TWO AND THEN
THIRTY FOUR WHICH WAS REALLY
EXCITING. I AM BUT I WAS ALREADY
IN RIGHT I WAS HOOKED IT WE
DON'T DO IT FOR THE MONEY IT IS
A CALLING AND I'M NOT SAYING I
DON'T WANT MY BY FELLOW TEACHERS
OUT THERE TO GET- RAISES THEY
CERTAINLY CERTAINLY DESERVE IT-
AFTER THESE. TOUGH YEARS- BUT
MANY OF US WERE MORE SEEKING
ADDITIONAL- SALARY ARE ONLY
OPTION WE SEE IS TO GO BECOME
ADMINISTRATORS WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT I DID GOT MY ADMINISTRATIVE
CREDENTIAL KNEW THAT THAT WAS
THE ONLY WAY TO DO IT AND THEN
WE LOSE THOSE REALLY GOOD
TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOMS TO GO
BECOME ADMINISTRATORS WHICH WE
ALSO NEED REALLY GOOD
ADMINISTRATORS RIGHT- BUT
NATIONAL BOARD HAS SHOWN. THAT
YOU RETAIN TEACHERS- ESPECIALLY
IN DISTRICTS THAT GIVE THEIR OWN
INCENTIVES SO I KNOW L. A. UST
OFFERS A 15% PAY BUMP UP FOR
NATIONAL BOARD CERTIFIED
TEACHERS AND THEN IN ADDITION TO
THAT THEY'LL GET OUR NEW
INCENTIVE PROGRAM AND LOOK AT
THE FIVE THOUSAND A YEAR FOR
FIVE YEARS- SO PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT THAT CAN KEEP. I'M IN
CLASSROOM BECAUSE THEY CAN THAT
EXTRA. OF FUNDING FOR THEMSELVES
EXTRA SALARY AND THEN ALSO SOME
MORE LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT- AND
MORE YOU KNOW PASSION THROUGH
RENEWING THAT. NATIONAL BOARD
CERTIFICATION I THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT. OKAY THANK YOU CHOI.
REGARDING THE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION- I WONDER IF OF THAT
WERE SET ANY STUDY- REGION TO
REGION ARE THEY ARE LIVING COSTS
IS AT THE FRONT EVEN CITY TO
CITY AND LIVING COSTS IS
DIFFERENT TO THE CITY I COME
FROM A CITY OF IRVINE IN ORANGE
COUNTY. IS MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE-
AT THE GASOLINE PUMP- OKAY LEARN
- THAT LAST WEEK ALL PAY THE
REGULAR WAS- SIX DOLLARS TO
ELEVEN WHY EVEN- LA WAS SO
STATED FIVE EIGHTY NINE OFF.
BELOW IS A IS. SIX DOLLARS SO
AMONG OTHER FOOD PRICES- HOUSING
COSTS OF OUR CD AT THE MINIMUM
ONE BEDROOM WOULD BE- OVER
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED I BELIEVE
BUT OUR BALLPARK MONTH TO START
LIVING COSTS IS MUCH MUCH HIGHER
. SO I WONDER IF US THE
TEACHERS- AVERAGES SALARY IS A
STEP AND COLUMN ALL PAY DOING
THE VOICEOVER WHEN THEY ENTER IN
EVEN ORANGE COUNTY LA ALL
VENTURA- ONE SAN FRANCISCO OF
THE ARTS EIGHTEEN. WELL IDEA ANY
CONSIDERATIONS THE LEAVING COST
OF A SUDDEN RETURN MY CITY. DR
TRIED THE NEW A DIRECT THE
QUESTION TO- ANYBODY I DON'T
KNOW WHO'S GOING OFF TENS OKAY.
WAS IT TAKEN SENATE. L. A. L.
YES WE CAN TAKE A SHOT AT THAT
THEM IN WITHOUT OUT TRY TO AN
THAT QUESTION IF ANY OTHER
PANELISTS WANNA JUMP AND SO ARE
SO AS SEVEN CALL. THEY TO COME
LAW THAT NOT GO ON A ON A BY
LEVEL AND SO OFTEN TIMES YOU DO
HAVE BURDEN UNITS DO ASKING FOR
MORE HI YOU'RE A HIGHER SALARIES
AND COMPENSATION TO REFLECT
HIGHER COST OF LIVING WE'D SO WE
DO SEE REGIONAL DIFFERENCES IN
AVERAGE SALARY PER TEACHER. IF
THAT'S HELPFUL. AND ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS OF THAT I KNOW I SERVED
ON THE IRVINE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT- IN ON BOARD- IN MY
EARLY. CAREER AND THE TROUBLE-
FOR THE IRVINE LOSS OF
STRUCTURAL REFORM INTO LAW- THE-
OF MY SCHOOL DISTRICT RECEIVED A
MUCH MUCH LESS I DON'T KNOW WHAT
KIND OF FORMULA WHEN IT WAS
CLASSIFIED AS A RURAL AREA NOT
ALWAYS HAVE TOLD A DIFFERENT
STORY AFTER YOU KNOW FORTY FIVE
YEARS SO. ARM AT THAT SHOULD BE
REFORMULATED ABOUT THE I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PIE IS TO
SAY IS NOT GROWING. SO IF OUR-
IRVINE DE DEMO ALLOCATION DONE
SOMEBODY HAS TO GET THE
NECESSARY LIES OF THE PIES SO
THEREFORE LIKE THAT- LA SQUID
WOULD FIGHT TO DEATH- AND WOULD
NOT ALLOW DESSEL. IT HAS BEEN
AVERAGE ABOUT THE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A LAST POST CHILDREN IN
COMPARISON- A DISTRICTS- SO.
THEY HAD TO COME UP WITH YOU
KNOW TRYING TO MAKE UP BOB FOR
DIFFERENT SYSTEM. FROM PRIVATE
DONATIONS SO- PUBLIC SCHOOL
FOUNDATION HAS BEEN WORKING SO
HARD TO RAISE- YOU KNOW MONEY
YOU KNOW FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR
SO THEY BEEN COMPENSATING BUT
NOT. WHEN THEY ARE BUDGET IS
UNDERFUNDED- ADEN. IT THOUGH
THEY- WANT. ARE ATTRACTED.
INCENTIVIZE SOME TEACHER OVER
THE TEACHERS JOB- NO BUDGET IS A
FIX DONE IS NOT GROWINGBECAUSE
OF THE ARE OLD FASHIONED OFF
FORMULA SO THEY ARE STUCK SO I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER IRVINE
SCHOOL- THE BEGINNING TEACHERS
ARE PAID THE MORE THAN NOT LIKE
A COTTON GROUP FOR EVEN OF THOSE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO AN ORANGE
COUNTY. I THINK WHAT OUR BOTTOM
LINE. IS THAT THE- STATE HAS TO
REPEAT THINGS IF I EDUCATION IS
OUR PRIORITY I KNOW ARADIA A NEW
A 60% OF ALL STATE BUDGET IS
ALLOCATED FOR EDUCATION BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO. EXPAND THE
AND- THE TEACHER IS SO NOBLE JOB
BAR AND- WE ARE A PROPERLY
COMPENSATED- AND THE PEOPLE WILL
IN ALL. OF CRAZY TO BECOME A
TEACHER FOR EVEN FOR GOOD- THE-
STARTING SALARY AND ALSO
PROVIDING. A HOUSING. FOR MIDDLE
INCOME- EMPLOYEES ARE LIVING IN
THAT THE- THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE- OF
HOMELESSNESS A SITUATION AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NO LOW INCOME
BUT THE- WAY IT TEACHES TO BE
LONG. OUR THE OUR LOW LOW INCOME
ON A MIDDLE INCOME BUT THAT THEY
ARE NOT HIGHLY ARE NOT- HI
HIGHER INCOME OWNERS DEFINITELY
. MAYBE WE CAN SAY YA- LOW
MEDIUM LEVEL INCOME EARNERS SO
WHEN THEY BEGIN SO HOW CAN THEY
LIVE IN THE CITY WITH A SALARY.
OF TWENTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE- BUT-
I DON'T. I THINK THAT MAY COME
OUT TO BE MAYBE FIFTEEN TWENTY
DOLLARS TO POWER- SO YOU CANNOT
AFFORD TO LEAVE- IN HIGH COST-
ASSIDUOUS ADVOCACY OF IRVINE SO
I. THINK WE NEED TO- REALLY-
BRIEF. OUR FUNDING- AND LOOK TO
A- SECTOR. OKAY THANK YOU. WE
COME. LIVE NOW OKAY AT WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE WHICH IS RELATED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSALS FOR THE EDUC EDUCATOR
PIPELINE THIS OF COURSE IS ON
TOP OF THE ONE BILLION OR SO
THAT WE ALLOCATED LAST YEAR
WHICH ARE MULTI YEAR- EFFORTS.
SO WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO FINANCE
LMAO THE COMMUNICABLE CHANCES
OFFICE CVE NCTC. GOOD MORNING
MEGAN PROVIDES PERMANENT
FINANCE. THE TWENTY TWO YEAR
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
INVESTMENT OF FIFTY FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
EFFORTS TO ENHANCE THE ABILITY
OF SCHOOLS TO HIRE QUALIFIED
TEACHERS AND SUBSTITUTE. THIS
FUNDING BUILDS UPON TWO POINT
NINE BILLION DOLLARS IN
INVESTMENTS FROM THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT TO PREPARE
TRAIN AND RECRUIT A DIVERSE
EDUCATOR WORKFORCE AS DISCUSSED
IN DETAIL DURING THE PRIOR
PANEL. AND TO REPLACE THE
MEDICAL INVESTMENT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DESIGNED TO
ADDRESS THE STATE'S TEACHER
SHORTAGE INCLUDE TWENTY FOUR
MILLION AND ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO WAIVE CERTAIN TEACHER
EXAMINATION FEES IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE FISCAL
YEAR. TWELVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO EXTEND THE
CURRENT WAIVER OF FLAT
CREDENTIAL AND PERMIT CREDENTIAL
FEES FOR INDIVIDUALS ENTERING
THE EDUCATOR WORK FOURTH THROUGH
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE FISCAL YEAR I'M FUNDING
FOR ONE POSITION AT THE
COMMISSION TO SUPPORT THOSE
PROGRAMS. ADDITIONALLY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES TEN
MILLION AND ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR THE COMMISSION TO
ADMINISTER A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
INTEGRATED TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAM. FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM. THE PROPOSAL WILL BUILD
ON PREVIOUS INVESTMENT PROVIDED
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND ALLOW FOR
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
COLLABORATIVE. IN PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND AND
FUNDING FOR TWO POSITIONS TO
REESTABLISH THE PERSONNEL
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE TEAMS
PROGRAM. IBM IS DESIGNED TO
ASSIST LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES AND APPROVING HIRING
AND RECRUITMENT PRACTICES. I'M
IN THE GOVERNOR BUT IT ALSO
PROVIDES A ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FIND-
FOR EIGHT POSITIONS AT THE
COMMISSION WHICH WILL SERVE AS
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT IN CAREER
COUNSELORS FOR PROSPECTIVE
EDUCATORS. AS WELL AS ONE
POSITION WHICH WILL WORK TO
DEVELOP A MULTI FACETED PORTAL
TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT
FOR INDIVIDUALS WANTING TO MAKE
THAT TRANSITION INTO A P. RT K.
THROUGH TWELVE CAREER.
ADDITIONALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND ONE POSITION ON
GOING FOR THE COMMISSION TO
CONTRACT FOR PUBLIC OUTREACH TO
HIGHLIGHT THE VALUE AND BENEFITS
OF EDUCATIONAL CAREER IN
CALIFORNIA PRE K. THROUGH GRADE
TWELVE SCHOOL. WHICH I'M SURE
THE GOAL HERE IS THAT THAT
PERSONAL MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE
TEAM WAR TEAM MAP PROGRAM. OR IN
POP I REACHED. WILL WORK TO
COMPLEMENT EACH OTHER TO CREATE
A COHESIVE SYSTEM TO IMPROVE
RECRUITMENT AND THE EFFICIENCY
OF THE STATE'S TEACHER CAREER
PIPELINE. APERTURE REALLY AIMED
AT ENSURING THAT ALL THE
INFORMATION ON HOW TO BECOME A
TEACHER IS AVAILABLE TO A
PROSPECTIVE TEACHER. THE LAST
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INVESTMENT BUT
I'LL TOUCH ON IN SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THREE THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND FOR FIVE POSITIONS AT THE
COMMISSION TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR THE NUMEROUS LOCAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS. AND PROGRAMS
FUNDED THROUGH THE COMMISSION IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET AND
THESE INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT
NECESSARILY LIMITED TO A TEACHER
RESIDENCY IS CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE CREDENTIALING GRANT
INTEGRATED TEACHER PROGRAMS AND
COMPUTER SCIENCE AT ONE AND
THREE AUTHORIZATION. GRANTS- FOR
THERE IS SOME. BILLING WHICH
EXTENDS FLEXIBLE FOR SOME.
TEACHERS AUTHOR. ANY OF THE
CREDENTIAL PERMIT ISSUED BY THE
COMMISSION TO SERVE IN A
SUBSTITUTE TEACHING ASSIGNMENT
ALIGNED WITH THAT AUTHORIZATION
INCLUDING PERFECT AGENCIES. AT
BRACKETT SIXTY CUMULATIVE DAYS
FOR ANY ONE ASSIGNMENT- LASTLY
THERE IS SOME TRAILER BILL
AMENDING THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
LEADERSHIP PROGRAMS. AT THIS
LINK WHICH ADDRESSES TWO ISSUES
THE FIRST THERE ARE CURRENTLY NO
CONSISTENT METRICS TO EVALUATE
THE PROGRAM. I MEAN THE LANGUAGE
DEFINED CRITERIA TO MEASURE AND
ASSESS PERFORMANCE AND THEN BACK
IN THE LANGUAGE REQUIRED THAT
GRANTEES PARTICIPATE IN ANY
EXTERNAL ABOUT ITALIAN RATIO
COORDINATED BY. AND BY THE
COLLABORATIVE. AT BUT I COMPLETE
MY REMARKS ON GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL- IN THE EDUCATORS FACE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANYQUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE. TIME THANK YOU
NEXT L. L. IN NEARLY WITH L. A.
L. SO THERE ARE SEVERAL EDUCATOR
WORK FOR PROPOSED UNDER THE ITEM
I PLAY TO WALK THROUGH OUR- FOR
EACH OF THESE FOR. STARTING ON
PAGE NINETEEN OF YOUR AGENDA.
THERE STARTING FIRST WITH THE
GOVERNORS OF NEW TEACHER
RECRUITMENT ACTIVITIES WHICH
PROPOSES ONGOING GENERAL FUND TO
CDC FOR NEW A CAREER COUNSELOR
IS A NEW TEACHER RECRUITMENT WEB
PORTAL AND A STATEWIDE PUBLIC
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN. WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE MODIFY THESE
PROPOSALS TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
ONE OF THE EXISTING ENTITIES
THAT ALREADY DO THIS WORK ATHER
THAN CTC FORGET SINCE BOTH CD
AND THE CENTRE ON TEACHING
CAREERS ALREADY OPERATES AN
ONLINE PLATFORM TO RECRUIT NEW
TEACHERS TO THE PROFESSION. AND
PROVIDE INFORMATION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING REQUIREMENTS THE
CENTER ALSO HAS EXPERIENCE
RUNNING STATEWIDE PREFER
PROMOTIONAL ACTIVITIES AS WELL.
THE PROPOSED ACTIVITIES FOR CTC
WHAT ESSENTIALLY DUPLICATE
EXISTING EFFORTS RATHER THAN
ESTABLISH ONE COORDINATED
AUTHORITATIVE PLATFORM THAT ALL
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS CAN GO TO
GUIDE THEM THROUGH A RATHER
COMPLEX PROCESS. WE ALSO THINK
THAT C. D. E. OR THE CENTER
WOULD BE BETTER POSITIONED TO
ACT SWIFTLY IN RESPONSE TO ANY
PANDEMIC AND DRIVEN TEACHER
SHORTAGES SINCE BOTH ALREADY
HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
PARTNERSHIPS IN PLACE TO HIT THE
GROUND RUNNING THE LEGISLATURE
WILL WANT TO CONSIDER THE
VARIOUS TRADE OFFS ASSOCIATED
WITH FUNDING EITHER ENTITY
INCLUDING EXPERTISE
ACCESSIBILITY OF THE ONLINE
PLATFORM AND FUNDING SOURCE.
PUZZLE TO REAR. THE ON.
ASSISTANT TEAMS HE NOTS
RECOMMENDS THE LEGISLATURE
REJECTED THIS PROPOSAL. THE
DISTRICTS ALREADY HAVE ACCESS TO
PERSONAL MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE
EXPERTISE THROUGH THE FISCAL
CRISIS AND MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE
TEAM FICK MATT AND CURRENT-
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
CURRENTLY DISTRICTS CAN REQUEST
VIC MATT TO STUDY AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO STREAMLINE
AND IMPROVE THE DISTRICT'S
TEACHER HIRING PROCESS TEACHER
RETENTION GREAT AND SUPPLY OF
HIGHLY QUALIFIED TEACHERS. WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT P. MATS COULD
HAVE SOME LIMITATIONS ESPECIALLY
IF THE DISTRICT'S CURRENT
PRACTICES ARE DRIVEN BY
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
WHICH PAYMENTS ARE UNLIKELY TO
CHANGE. WE ALSO THINK THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD REJECT THE
PROPOSED TEACHER EXAMINATION AND
CREDENTIALING FEE WAIVERS WE
THINK THESE WAIVERS ARE UNLIKELY
TO ATTRACT MORE TEACHERS TO THE
PROFESSION. AND ADDRESS THE
CURRENT TEACHER SHORTAGES
ESPECIALLY SINCE MOST TEACHERS
DO NOT KNOW ABOUT THESE WAIVERS
BEFORE APPLYING TO THESE PROPER
GRAMS. OTHER EFFORTS SUCH AS
STREAMLINING THE STATE'S COMPLEX
CREDENTIALING REQUIREMENTS COULD
EFFECTIVELY LOWER BARRIERS TO
BECOMING A TEACHER. LASTLY WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
INTEGRATED UNDERGRADUATE TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS THESE
PROPOSALS THESE PROGRAMS OFFER A
COST EFFICIENT AND QUICKER WAY
FOR INTERESTED UNDERGRADUATES TO
RECEIVE. TRAINING AND BECOME
TEACHERS AFTER GRADUATING I'M I
WILL PASS IT OVER TO PAUL STEEN
HOUSING MY COLLEAGUE AT THE
ALLEY- TO COVER THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM PROPOSAL
NEXT. THANK YOU BOSSINEY WITH
THE ANALYST'S OFFICE AS YOUR
GENDER NOTES ON PAGE EIGHTEEN
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. FOR THE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM. AS CONTACTS THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. BUDGET PROVIDED
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
FOR THE SAME PROGRAM AND IT
FUNDED THREE PILOT PROGRAMS
WHICH ARE ON YOUR- IN YOUR
AGENDA ON PAGE EIGHTEEN. JUST
WANTED TO MAKE CLEAR THIS IS NOT
THE TWO PLUS TWO PROGRAM THAT
YOU HEARD ABOUT IN ISSUE TWO-
THIS IS A DIFFERENT GRANT IT WAS
SET UP TO ALLOW ASPIRING
TEACHERS. WHO ALREADY HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE TO TRAVEL TO A
PARTICIPATING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND THERE ARE THE IDEAS THAT
THE- STUDENT WOULD SIT IN A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CLASSROOM OR A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COMPUTER LAB.
AND TAKE ONLINE TEACHER
PREPARATION COURSEWORK. THROUGH
A CAL STATE UNIVERSITY OR OTHER
UNIVERSITY TEACHER PREP PROGRAM
SO THESE ARE NOT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS USER POST
BACCALAUREATE STUDENTS AND A
TEACHER PREP PROGRAM TAKING AN
ONLINE CLASS. IN PERSON AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. SO START YOU
REQUIRES OUR OFFICE TO EVALUATE
THE PILOT PROGRAM AND THAT
REPORT IS DUE TO THE LEGISLATURE
IN APRIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE AS
YOUR AGENDA NOTES. AS FAR AS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE THINK IT
WOULD BE PREMATURE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE A NEW
INFLUX OF MONEY TO THIS PROGRAM
WHEN THE CURRENT ONE HASN'T BEEN
EVALUATED. YOU KNOW A LOT HAS
CHANGED OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS AS YOU MENTIONED EARLIER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA. OUR
FINANCE MENTIONED THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS. IS X. INTENDED TO
EXPAND. OPPORTUNITIES FOR REMOTE
INSTRUCTION WE DO NOTE THAT
ONLINE CLASSES ARE COMMONPLACE
NOW SINCE THE PANDEMIC. THE
STATE HAS CONTINUED TO INVEST
HEAVILY IN LAPTOPS AND OTHER
EQUIPMENT AND EXPAND BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE. HOLD
OFF REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR THIS YEAR. HAVE
SOME TIME. TO LOOK INTO THIS
PROGRAM AND HOW IT'S WORKING AS
I MENTIONED THE LA ALWAYS GOING
TO DO A REPORT ON THIS BY NEXT
APRIL IT'S IN STATUTE. AND WE
HOPE THE LEGISLATURE. WOULD FIND
THIS REPORT USEFUL SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE THE ADMINISTRATION
COME BACK NEXT. SPRING OR NEXT
JANUARY WITH THE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FOLLOWED BY C. D. E. AND THEN C.
T. C. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
PARTY MEMBERS OF THE- EDUCATION
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE LISETTE
NEVER AT EXECUTIVE VICE USER.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT
PROPOSALS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OR
A SPECIFIC TO THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES. I'M GONNA FOCUS ON ON
THE TOPIC THAT THE ALLEY I WAS
JUST TALKING ABOUT WHICH IS THE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PARTNERSHIP. AS YOU MAY RECALL
THIS WAS ESTABLISHED BY SENATE
BILL FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR DODD AND AS WAS SHARED
WAS CREATED- TO PROVIDE DISTANCE
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. THOSE WHO
ALREADY- POSSESSED THE GREASY
AND- WE'RE SERVING AND SHORT
TERM- CAPACITIES- OR HAD
LIMITED. ACCESS TO COMMISSION
APPROVED TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS THE FOCUS REALLY WAS I
TEACHER SHORTAGES IN RURAL
AREAS- AN ASTHMA SHARED WHEN
THIS WAS AUTHORIZED THE INTENT
WAS JUST TO PROVIDE CAPACITY. TO
PROVIDE A SPACE SO THAT THESE
TEACHERS DID NOT HAVE TO LEAVE
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND FURTHER
EXACERBATE THE TEACHER SHORTAGE.
GRANTS WERE PROVIDED TO THREE
DISTRICTS FEATHER RIVER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
MONTEREY PENINSULA AND YUBA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THE PILOTS
JUST CONCLUDED THEIR PLANNING
PHASE SO AS A SHARED LIMITED
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE. BUT
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT A LOT HAS
CHANGED- CALIFORNIA ME COLLEGES
NOT TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PARTNERSHIP REALLY EXPOSE SOME
POTENTIAL FOR A MORE FRUITFUL. A
COLLABORATION- AND CREATING A
TEACHER PIPELINE ON WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED IS THAT COMEY CALLS
COMPLAIN IMPORTANT ROLE
INCREASING FUTURE WORK FORCE
ESPECIALLY IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
ADD. IN LEVERAGING OUR EXISTING
CHILD DEVELOPMENT LABS AT
CENTERS IN TEACHING WHAT LABS.
ARE WE CAN PROVIDE GREATER
ACCESS TO PROGRAMS THAT BENEFIT-
BY PROVIDING GREATER ACCESS TO
DIVERSITY AS WE SERVE THEIR
GREATEST PROPORTION OF- DIVERSE
STUDENTS ACROSS ALL OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. I'M IN A MORE
INTENTIONAL DESIGN OF THIS
PROGRAM COULD REALLY HAVE-
INCREASE RETENTION IMPROVING
ACCESS TO QUALITY TEACHING AND
LEARNING ESPECIALLY IN AREAS
THAT HAVE LOW COLLEGE GOING
RATES SO. WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD
TO DISCUSSING MORE THIS PROGRAM
AND HOW WE CAN CREATE A MORE
SPECIFIC PIPELINE THE TEACHER
CREDENTIAL PROGRAMS- AND
LEARNING FROM WHAT WHAT IS
CHANGED IN THE LAST TWO YEARS IN
THE EDUCATION FIELD- I'M WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU C. D. E. N. N. C. T. C. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND AGAIN I'M
CHERYL COTTON DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
INSTRUCTION MEASUREMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION BRANCH. OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND PRESENTED TODAY ON
BEHALF OF OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMAN WITH ME
AGAIN IT'S KRISTIN CHRIS ALLEN
FROM THE EDUCATOR EXCELLENCE AND
EQUITY DIVISION. WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S TEACHER
SHORTAGE AS I MENTIONED IN MY
PRIOR REMARKS NOT ONLY ARE WE
FACING AN EDUCATOR WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE THAT WAS EXACERBATED BY
THE PANDEMIC BUT WITH
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN PRE
K. THROUGH TWELVE PROGRAMS. WE
ARE SEEING SCHOOLS STRUGGLING TO
IMPLEMENT THESE IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS DUE TO DIFFICULTIES IN
HIRING QUALIFIED STAFF. THERE'S
NO QUESTION THAT TEACHERS ARE
BEING ASKED TO TAKE ON
ADDITIONAL IMMENSE WORKLOAD AND
NAVIGATE NEW CHALLENGES OF THIS
NEW REALITY AND IT'S IMPORTANT
TO FOCUS ON WORK FORCE PROPOSALS
THAT INCENTIVIZE. AND ASSIST
TEACHER CANDIDATES ENTERING THE
TEACHING PROFESSION SO SCHOOLS
CAN RETAIN THEIR TALENT AND
REDUCE TEACHER TURNOVER THAT IS
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC IN HIGH
NEED SCHOOLS. FURTHER AS SCHOOLS
BEGIN TO IMPLEMENT UNIVERSAL PRE
KINDERGARTEN AND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN EXPANSION WE NEED
TO SUPPORT DIVERSE TEACHER
PIPELINES TO HAVE ADEQUATE
STAFFING. FOR THESE IMPORTANT
EARLY GRADES. WITH THIS THERE IS
ALSO A NEED TO INCENTIVIZE AND
SPARK INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. TO MORE QUICKLY
ADAPTED SUPPORT COURSES AND
PATHWAYS TO CREATE MORE
CREDENTIALED AND PERMITTED
TECHERS AND PARA EDUCATORS. AS
THESE CANDIDATES GRADUATE FROM
PROGRAMS WE NEED WAYS TO SUPPORT
THEM AS THEY TRANSITION FROM
GRADUATE PROGRAMS TO FULL TIME
INSTRUCTION. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE AND RELEVANT STATE
ENTITIES AS WE DETERMINE THE
BEST WAY TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THESE WORKFORCE PROPOSALS AND
ARE READY TO HELP SUPPORT THESE
PROGRAMS IN ANY WAY WE CAN.
THANK YOU AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN VERY BIG SEE SANDY WITH
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. THE INVESTMENTS
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REPRESENT AN ALIGNED
EFFORT AT THE STATE REGIONAL
LOCAL AND INDIVIDUAL LEVELS THEY
CAN SUPPORT AND GROW THE
EDUCATION WORKFORCE IN THE NEAR
AND THE LONG TERM. I WOULD AGREE
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
THAT THE STATE NEEDS A
COORDINATED AUTHORITATIVE
PLATFORM THAT ALL PROSPECTIVE
TEACHERS CAN USE TO GUIDE THEM
THROUGH A COMPLEX PROCESS OF
BECOMING A TEACHER. I WOULD ALSO
ARGUE THAT THIS IS NOT A ZERO
SUM GAME. WELL IN ANY AND EVERY
EFFORT SHOULD BE COORDINATED.
THEY TEACH CALIFORNIA DOT ORG
SITE HOSTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS AN
IMPORTANT BEACON THAT SHOULD
HAVE A HOME AT THE STATE
EDUCATION AGENCY. IT PROVIDES
INTRODUCTORY INFORMATION IN A
HIGHLY ENGAGING FORMAT FOR
INTERESTED TEACHERS AND DOES NOT
COMPETE WITH THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING- OR EXCUSE
ME THE COMMISSION OR THE CENTER
FOR TEACHING CAREERS IN HOLDING
THAT SPACE. MANY PEOPLE GO TO
THE CD AS A FIRST STOP ON THEIR
WAY TO CONSIDERING A CAREER IN
TEACHER. A TEACHING SIMILARLY
THE CALIFORNIA TEACH DOT WORK
SITE HOSTED BY TELLER COUNTY
PROVIDES INVALUABLE INFORMATION
FOR JOB SEEKERS AND AGAIN
INTRODUCTORY INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW TO ENTER TEACHING. THE
CENTER IS WELL POSITIONED TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE TEACHING
PROFESSION AND SERVE AS A
COMPREHENSIVE JOB WORK. THE
COMMISSION REMAINS HOWEVER THE
LICENSING AGENCY ALL APPLICANTS
MUST COME THROUGH THE COMMISSION
IN ORDER TO BE CREDENTIAL. THE
CAREER COUNSELORS INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
WOULD BE USED TO MAKE THAT VERY
CLEAR NEEDS THE CALIFORNIA'S
POTENTIAL AND CURRENT EDUCATORS
HAVE FOR INFORMATION REGARDING
EARNING A CREDENTIAL AND WORKING
IN CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
OVER THE LAST DECADE THE DEMAND
FOR CUSTOMER SERVICE FROM THE
COMMISSION'S CERTIFICATION
DIVISION HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED CURRENTLY THE
COMMISSION STAFF RESPOND TO
APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND EMAIL
AND ENGAGING FORD FIVE HUNDRED
ONLINE CHATS WERE WEAK. THAT. IS
AROUND SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND
EMAIL ONE FOURTEEN. OR FOR
THOUSAND LIVECHATS TODAY- THAT-
STAFFER ENGAGED WITH PROSPECTIVE
OR CURRENT CREDENTIAL HOLDERS
AROUND CREDENTIALING ISSUES.
THIS IS LIKELY DUE IN PART TO
THE EXPANSION OF OPTIONS AND
PATHWAYS TO ME CREDENTIAL
REQUIREMENTS IN RECENT YEARS
INCLUDING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
UNDERGRADUATE INTEGRATED
PROGRAMMING DEGREE PROGRAMS.
INTERNSHIP ROUTES INTO TEACHING
THE DEVELOPMENT OF RESIDENCY AND
CLASSIFIED STAFF PATHWAYS INTO
TEACHING. WE ACCREDIT EIGHT
EIGHTY ABOUT EIGHTY INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER EDUCATION AND THE
OTHER ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ELEAZAR AND ACROSS THESE
PROGRAMS WE HAVE MAYBE A
THOUSAND DIFFERENT PROGRAM
PATHWAYS THE CANDIDATES CAN
CHOOSE FROM IT IS A COMPLEX.
ARRAY OF OPTIONS THESE NEW
OPTIONS FOR PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS
AS WELL AS THE RECENT EXPANSION
OF OPTIONS FOR MEETING BASIC
SKILLS AND SUBJECT MATTER
REQUIREMENTS. MAKE THE PROCESS
OF COMPLETING PREPARATION AND
EARNING A CREDENTIAL MORE
COMPLEX AND OFTEN CONFUSING FOR
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS. IN MANY
WAYS IT WOULD BE EASIER TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS BY
ISSUING FEWER TYPES OF
CREDENTIALS AND REDUCING THE
OPTIONS FOR MEETING CREDENTIAL
REQUIREMENTS. BUT MAINTAINING
MULTIPLE ACCESSIBLE PATHWAYS
INTO TEACHING IS KEY TO
DIVERSIFYING AND GROWING THE
RANKS OF OUR TEACHING FORCE. THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE ARE GETTING
FROM CANDIDATES SHIFT FROM HELP
HOW DO I BECOME A TEACHER HOW
DOES ANYONE BECOME A TEACHER. TO
REALLY HOW CAN I BEST WHAT'S MY
BEST PATHWAY FOR BECOMING A
TEACHER GIVEN. MY UNIQUE
SITUATION. POST CAREER K. WERE
BE DEDICATED TO CREATING AN
ONLINE SYSTEM THAT LEADS A
PROSPECTIVE TEACHER THROUGH
THEIR UNIQUE QUESTIONS WHILE
ALSO PROVIDING INDIVIDUALIZED
SUPPORT WHEN NEEDED. IMPROVED
ACCESS TO ONLINE INFORMATION
ABOUT PATHWAYS OPTIONS FOR
MEETING CREDENTIALS REQUIREMENTS
PROGRAM AND GRANT OPPORTUNITIES
COUPLED WITH DEDICATED STAFF
ASSISTANCE WILL ASSIST ALL
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS IN
NAVIGATING THE CREDENTIAL
PROCESS. IN SHORT COMMISSION IS
EXPECTED TO BE THE AUTHORITATIVE
SOURCE TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
AND SUPPORT NAVIGATION WITH
PRUDENTIAL ANALYST IN
PREPARATION PROGRAMS AND FEEL.
THE COMPLEXITIES OF RUNNING A
CREDENTIAL. I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. OKAY THANK YOU I'M GOING
TO FIRST APP POSE A QUESTION
THAT MR O'DONNELL. ASKED ME TO-
TO LOOK AT HE HAD TO STEP OUT OF
ITS WAY TO THE- TO THE TO THE
FOUR YEAR PROGRAM DESIGN FROM
THE TRADITIONAL FIVE YEAR DESIGN
. YOU KNOW WE THERE'S SOME MONEY
FOR ADDITIONAL PLANNING OF
COURSE WE STARTED THIS A FEW
YEARS AGO- THE QUESTION HE HAS
IS THAT. WHY I HAPPEN TO BE
RECEIVE MORE PRODUCT OUT OF THIS
AND WHY ARE WE STILL TALKING
ABOUT PLANNING. SO AS THESE
PROGRAMS TAKE SOME TIME TO
DEVELOP- WHY HAVEN'T WE SEEN
MORE PRODUCT IS AN INTERESTING
QUESTION I SUPPOSE IT IS THAT
GOES TO THE CHOICES. THAT
UNDERGRADUATE TEACHERS ARE
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS HAVE
ABOUT WHAT CAREER PATHWAYS THEY
MIGHT LACK. LET ME REPHRASE THAT
SO I THINK THIS WAS CREATED
YEARS AGO SUSAN BUT HE HAD A
BILL AUTHORIZING THIS AND SOME
PILOTS AND WE STARTED THIS. AND
WE'VE BEEN. IN THE PLANNING
STAGES SO WHAT IS IT THAT THAT
WE NEED TO DO TO REALLY MAKE
THESE A REALITY AND NOT JUST. IF
CAMPUSES MONEY TO PLAN FOR IT I
THINK. IT'S NOT. SOMETHING THAT
CAN'T BE REPLICATED. WE'VE SEEN
SOME FOR YOUR KIDS COLLEGES HAVE
THIS SO I CAN WE JUST GET GOING
ON MOVE IT AND HELP STUDENTS
GRADUATE WITHIN FOUR YEARS
ALLOWS MUCH STUDENT DEBT AND-
THE DRESSER. TEACHER SHORTAGE
ISSUE HEAD ON. IT'S EMIR MAY NOT
BE A CASE OF IF YOU BUILD IT
THEY WILL COME- SO AND CERTAINLY
HAVING OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
HAVING RECRUITMENT AND OUTREACH
EFFORTS ARE GOING TO YOU KNOW
CREATE INFORM PEOPLE ABOUT THE
OPTIONS THAT LIE BEFORE THEM- I
THINK IF YOU DO USE A STEADY THE
UNDERGRADUATE INTEGRATED SPACE
WE FUNDED AND THE LAST GO ROUND
WITH WITH GRANTS WE FUNDED FORTY
ONE- GRANT OPPORTUNITIES AND
DEVELOP PROGRAMS ACROSS FORTY
ONE INSTITUTIONS THAT LEAD TO
THE UNDERGRADUATE PATHWAYS-
EIGHT. WE DO WE DO HAVE I THINK
A VERY IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY IN
FRONT OF US AS WE LOOK AT EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IN THE
MOVEMENT TOWARD TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN OF THE WE'RE
LOOKING TO PROBABLY BRING
ANOTHER ELEVEN THOUSAND TEACHERS
INTO THE SYSTEM OF WHO WILL BE
WORKING IN THAT TRANSITIONAL
KERR KINDERGARTEN SPACE AND THE
UNDERGRADUATE INTEGRATED PROGRAM
ROUTE- IS IDEALLY SUITED FOR
MANY OF THEM WHO HAVE BEGUN
THEIR WORK WITH THE TWO YEAR
PROGRAM- AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND CAN TRANSITION OR TRANSFER
INTO A FOUR YEAR INSTITUTION.
AND IF WE CAN CREATE THESE
PROGRAM PATHWAYS FOR THEM THAT
WOULD BE A READY- AND I THINK A
VERY EFFICIENT PATHWAY FOR
BRINGING THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
WORKFORCE IN THAT BUT WE NEED TO
BRING IN- SO BEYOND THAT I THINK
THAT THE MOST OF THE TEACHERS
WHO ARE COMING THROUGH AND I
GETTING TEACHING CREDENTIALS ARE
DOING SO THROUGH ADDITIONAL
FIFTY YEAR PROGRAM STILL. OF WAR
THROUGH INTERNET PROGRAMS ARE
SEEING REAL GROWTH IN THE
INTERNET SPACE HOPING TO SEE
GROWTH OF THE RESIDENCY SPACE
BUT THERE IS A PLACE FOR THIS
PARTICULAR INFRASTRUCTURE THE
UNDERGRADUATE PATHWAY IN- AND I
THINK IN PARTICULAR FOR THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD. WORKFORCE THAT
WE NEED TO RECRUIT. OKAY AT NEXT
QUESTION FOR YOU FOR YOU AGAIN-
MERRY SANDY IS. DURING THE PRIOR
YEAR WE HAD THAT WAVING OF THE-
THE FEES THE HUNDRED DOLLAR
FEES. AND WANT TO ASK YOU DO WE
SEE AN INCREASE IN ACTIVITYIN
APPLICATIONS COMPARED TO PRIOR
YEARS WITH THE WAIVING THE FEE.
I'D LIKE TO INVITE- ERR IN
SCHOOL ARE DIRECTOR OF
CERTIFICATION TO RESPOND TO THAT
QUESTION. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING- AT WE DID SEE A- AN
INCREASE IN OUR CREDENTIAL
APPLICATIONS- THERE WAS AN
APPROXIMATE TWENTY SIX POINT 8%
INCREASE OVER THE EIGHT MONTH
PERIOD WHEN THAT- COMMISSION
OFFERED THE FEE WAIVER. AS
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR AND THAT
WOULD BE THE 202-020-2020 TWENTY
ONE YEAR- BUT WE KNOW THAT WAS A
COOL WITH YOUR SO WE DID LOOK
BACK- TO BOTH EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AND NINETEEN TWENTY FOR THAT
SCENE EIGHT MONTH PERIOD. AND
THERE WAS AN APPROXIMATE 13%
INCREASE- OTHER APPLICATIONS
OVER THAT TIME PERIOD WOW. OKAY
SO DO YOU THINK THAT IT WAS
WORTHWHILE THEN YOU SHOULD HAVE
IT IN PERPETUITY. I'M I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE CAN ATTRIBUTE ALL
OF THAT INCREASE TO THE FEE
WAIVER BUT I DO THINK IT WAS
PART OF A MULTI PRONG- APPROACH
THAT THE- GOVERNOR- PUT FORWARD
TO SUPPORT THE INCREASE IN
TEACHER CREDENTIALING AND SO I
DO THINK THAT IT DID INCENTIVIZE
MANY INDIVIDUALS TO- APPLY FOR
TEACHER PREPARATION AND TO APPLY
FOR ESPECIALLY SUBSTITUTE
PERMITS WE DID SEE A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN SUBSIDY PERMITS OVER
THAT PERIOD OF TIME. OKAY AN
AMBER ALEXANDER WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IF I MAY JUST CHIME
IN AS WELL- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THAT WAS
THE FIRST YEAR OF THE FEE WAIVER
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES
INCLUDE SOME- INVESTMENTS AND
AROUND COULD THAT GUIDANCE
COUNSELORS AS WELL AS THE-
PUBLIC OUTREACH CAMPAIGN THAT WE
ANTICIPATE WILL PUTMORE
AWARENESS AND OUT INTO THE FIELD
ABOUT AND THE AVAILABILITY OF-
YOU KNOW PROGRAMS TO GET INTO
THE TEACHER'S BASE INCLUDING
THAT THE WAIVER SO WE WOULD
ANTICIPATE- DEMAND TO INCREASE
IN FUTURE YEARS. OKAY BACK I ONE
MORE QUESTION TO. MERRY SANDY
WITH THE C. T. C. AB THIS ALSO
IS IN THE AGENDA ARE THERE ANY
OTHER PANDEMIC RELATED
FLEXIBILITIES. OR CAPACITY THAT
CDC WOULD RECOMMEND FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR. ACTUALLY WE WOULD
NOT RECOMMEND ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITIES STATE THE INITIAL
FLEXIBILITIES THAT WERE PUT IN
PLACE OF TWENTY TWENTY MANY OF
THEM HAVE TO DO WITH- LOWERING
TO THE TESTING BARRIER. OF DUE
TO TESTING CENTER CLOSURES AND
THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR TOOK
ACTION TO EXPAND OPTIONS FOR
MEETING BASIC SKILLS
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL AS THE
SUBJECT MATTER REQUIREMENTS. OF
GREETING OPTION OPTIONS TO THE
C. BEST TEST AND THE SEAS THAT
PASSED ON AND THAT WE THINK IS
GOING TO HAVE IT A VERY
INTERESTING IMPACT THAT WILL BE
TRACKING IN THE COMING YEARS- TO
SEE HOW THOSE FLEXIBILITIES THAT
WERE INITIALLY COVERT
FLEXIBILITIES HAVE BECOME NOW. A
NEW- SET OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE WHO WENT INTO TEACHING-
WE THINK IT IT'S TIME TO. LEARN
FROM THE LESSONS OF KOBE AND PUT
THE RIGHT STRUCTURES BACK IN
PLACE BASED ON WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED- AND THAT'S. REALLY WHAT
WE WOULD ADVISE AT THAT STAGE.
OKAY THANK YOU. MISTER MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANTED
TO GO BACK TO THE INTEGRATED
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAM- AND
QUESTIONS ON ON THAT- MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS THAT IT WAS A
AN INVESTMENT OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IS THAT CORRECT YES
THAT'S CORRECT AND WE HAVE A
THIRTY THREE INSTITUTIONS OF
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM.
EIGHTEEN A CS USE TO UC'S AND
SEVERAL- PRIVATE COLLEGES AND I
DID THAT I DON'T HAVE IN FRONT
OF ME BUT I DID SEE- FIGURES OF
HOW MANY TEACHERS- THOSE
INSTITUTIONS HAVE A CREDENTIAL
TO MY RIGHT. SO THAT THEY THEY
HAVE PRODUCED FEATURES THEY HAVE
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS ALL THOSE
ALL THOSE INSTITUTIONS. AND IT
IS MY UNDERSTANDING YES RIGHT SO
IT ALL THE MONEY HAS NOT JUST
GONE INTO PLANNING. WELL LET ME
JUST CLARIFY THAT THE TEN
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT THAT WAS
PROVIDED A WAS EXPLICITLY AND
ONLY FOR PLANNING IT PROVIDED
SUPPORT TO DESIGN A PROGRAM. AND
NOW THE PROGRAM IS NOT FUNDED
THE INTEGRATED PROGRAM IS NOT
FUNDED TO RECRUIT OR DEVELOPMENT
AND THE TEACHERS WHO. WHO CAME
OUT OF THOSE PROGRAMS THERE
THERE HAVE BEEN TEACHERS HAVE
COME OUT OF THOSE PROGRAMS.
THERE HAVE BEEN BUT THEY WERE
NOT THEY DID NOT GET ANY OF THE
GRANT FUNDING TO SUPPORT THEIR
COMPLETION WAS ALRIGHT BUT
THEY'RE THERE AND THEY DID GET
SUPPORT IS THAT CORRECT THEY DID
GET FINANCIAL SUPPORT. NOT NOT
FROM THAT GRANT THAT THEY NOT I
GOT IT FROM SOMEWHERE. THEY MAY
HAVE GOTTEN. A FINANCIAL AID AND
PARTICIPATED IN OTHER TYPES OF
FINANCIAL AID PELL GRANTS AND
OTHER THINGS LIKE THAT BUT THERE
WAS NO DESIGNATED. SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR CANDIDATES TO
COMPLETE THE INTEGRATED PROGRAMS
AT THAT TIME. CERTAINLY THEY
HAVE ACCESS NOW TO THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT THAT COULD
HELP THEM. ALONG THE WAY BUT
THERE IS NO DESIGNATED FUNDING
TO SUPPORT ENROLLED CANDIDATES
IN AN INTEGRATED PROGRAM SO THE
HUNDRED MILLION. THAT THAT-
CALVARY SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION- INCREASE IN IN THAT
PROGRAM- AND I DON'T KNOW WHO
ELSE MIGHT BE OUT THERE TO HELP
ANSWER MY QUESTION A- INCREASE
OF THE PROGRAM TO A HUNDRED
MILLION OF THE INTEGRATED
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAM.
DOES THAT ANY OF THAT MONEY GO
DIRECTLY TO HELP OTHER STUDENTS
GET THROUGH THE CREDENTIALING
PROGRAM. IF WE WERE TO INCREASE
IT TO A HUNDRED MILLION. I DO
NOT KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION I SEE THAT. RT I THINK
IF I REMEMBER BUT YOU KNOW IF I
MAY YES REMAINED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WHAT I
WOULD SAY IT'S TWO TWO MEMBER
MCCARTY'S EARLIER STATEMENT-
CHAIRMAN PARTIES EARLIER
STATEMENT TO THE EXTENT THERE
STUDENTS FINISHING IN FOUR YEARS
AND SAID A PIPE THROUGH AN
INTEGRATED PROGRAM. THAT IS
CERTAINLY A FINANCIAL BENEFIT TO
THE STUDENT BECAUSE THEY'RE ABLE
TO COMPLETE IN A MORE TIMELY
FASHION THEREBY NOT INCURRING
ANOTHER YEAR OF YOU KNOW COST OF
LIVING- NON TUITION CULTURE EVEN
TUITION COSTS SO THERE IS A
FINANCIAL BENEFIT TO STUDENTS
FROM FINISHING THOSE PROGRAMS.
IN FOUR YEARS INSTEAD OF FIVE
THANK YOU BUT THE MONEY DOESN'T
GO DIRECTLY TO IT'S IN ANY WAY
TO SUPPORT THE STUDENT HIMSELF
IN IN GRANT AND IT'S MONEY TO%
THE INSTITUTION TO EXPAND THOSE
PROGRAMS. THAT IS ACCURATE. BUT
THANK YOU AND THAT THAT. THE
HELPS CLARIFY- BUT IF STUDENTS
WERE ABLE AS WE WERE JUST THEN
SAYING AND BE ABLE TO FINISH IN
FOUR YEARS INSTEAD OF FIVE- AND
YOU HAVE A T. A CREDENTIAL WHEN
THEY'RE FNISHED IN FOUR YEARS.
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO TAKE AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTH YEAR WHICH IS I
THINK- MISTER LEE'S POINT ABOUT
WORKING FOR FREE- IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL AND I HAVE HERE- IN
FRONT OF ME THAT IF WE DID
INCREASE IT. WE COULD SEE AN
INCREASE OF TWO UP TO TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
UGH COMING OUT OF THIS PROGRAM.
SO I DO WANT TO SPEAK OUT IN
SUPPORT OF INCREASING THE
PROGRAM THE INTEGRATED TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAM. AND TO SEE
THE INCREASE IN THE BUDGET FROM.
TO THE HUNDRED MILLION. WOULD
BE- WOULD I WOULD SUPPORT OKAY
THANK YOU. PHILLY NOTED THEY ALL
RIGHT WE WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE-
OPEN AND PROCEED NO ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR EDUCATOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND SUPPORT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A LEO AND
CD. BY FINDING. THE TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED SEVERAL
MULTI YEAR EDUCATOR PREPARATION
RETENTION AND TRAINING
INVESTMENTS AND SOME OF THESE
INCLUDE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
IN ONE TIME OPPOSITE PROP
KEEPING PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FINE OVER FIVE YEARS FOR
THE EDUCATOR EFFECTIVENESS BLOCK
GRANT. TO PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR TRAINING
RESOURCES FOR CLASSIFIED
CERTIFICATED PARA PROFESSIONAL
AND ADMINISTRATIVE SCHOOL STAFF
IN. IN FACT THE BITE HIGH NEED
TOPICS AT FORTY FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
OUR GENERAL FUND AVAILABLE
THROUGH AND BE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR KISCO YEAR FOR
THE FRESNO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION TO EXPAND THE
CALIFORNIA EARLY MATH
INITIATIVE. TO DELIVER HIGH
QUALITY PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AND PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
FAMILIES AND EDUCATORS IN
MATHEMATICS BUT EARLY LEARNERS
STATEWIDE. AND THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDED FIFTY
MILLION IN ONETIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
BUILD ON THE STATE'S MULTI
TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE TO CREATE A WIDE
RESOURCES AND PROVIDES
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT ON
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING AND
TRAUMA INFORMED PRACTICES. I'M
AN ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND WAS PROVIDED
FOR THE SUPERINTENDENT FOR
PURPOSES OF AWARDING GRANTS TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SUPPORTING LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF HIGH QUALITY
INTEGRATED ACADEMIC BEHAVIORAL
AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING
PRACTICES. AND FINALLY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SUBJECT
MATTER PROJECT PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING FOR
TEACHERS ACROSS THE STATE IN
NINE CORE SUBJECT AREAS AS
LISTED IN THE AGENDA AND HE'S
HE'S TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET FOR THE SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECT TOTALED EIGHT POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS. B. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT PROVIDED
SEVEN MILLION AND ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THE EXISTING
SUBJECT MATTER PROJECT OF WHICH
FIVE MILLION WHAT PROVIDED. TO
MITIGATE LEARNING WHAT'S IN CORE
SUBJECT NOW KIND AREAS AND TWO
MILLION COULD I FOR TRAINING AND
RESEARCH. I'M ON AT STUDIES
CONTACT AT CONCLUDE MY REMARKS
ON DEVELOPMENT PRO HAPPENING AT
THEIR QUESTIONS THE TIME. AT THE
YOU NEXT L. A. EMILY WITHOUT L.
SO FINANCE JUST PROVIDED AN
OVERVIEW OF THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS THAT WERE
FUNDED AND CURRENT YEAR AND WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD BUT
WE ARE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CITY. THE
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN I'M CHERYL
COTTON DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE INSTRUCTION MEASUREMENT
ADMINISTRATION BRANCH OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. I'M PRESENTING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMAN AND
WITH ME IS KRISTIN CHRIS ALLEN.
FROM THE EDUCATOR EXCELLENCE AND
EQUITY DIVISION. WE KNOW THAT
ONGOING PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
FOR EDUCATORS IS INTEGRAL. TO
ATTAINING POSITIVE SCHOOL AND
STUDENT OUTCOMES BUT IT TAKES ON
NEW URGENCY WHEN CONSIDERING THE
CONTEXT OF SCHOOLING. THE
PANDEMIC FORCE TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS TO TAKE ON NEW
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH SAFETY AND
WELL BEING OF THEIR STUDENTS.
WHILE ALSO RETHINKING WAYS TO
APPROACH THIS STUDENT GAUGE MINT
AND LEARNING ACCELERATION. AT
THE SAME TIME THEY HAD TO
CONTEND WITH IMMENSE STUDENT AND
FAMILY TRAUMA AND STRESS. IT'S
FOR THESE REASONS WE BELIEVE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING AND
SUPPORT HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
APPARENT I'M SORRY IMPERATIVE.
FOR CALIFORNIA EDUCATORS A HIGH
QUALITY PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
SYSTEM DOES MORE TO HELP BUT
DOES MORE THAN HELP. EDUCATORS
MASTER DISCREET CONTENT AND
INSTRUCTIONAL STRATEGIES IT
CONTRIBUTES A BROADER PROCESS OF
TRANSFORMING PRACTICE AND HAS A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION. SCHOOL CULTURE
AND CLIMATE LABOR MANAGEMENT
DYNAMICS EDUCATOR EQUITY AND
STUDENT AND EDUCATOR OUTCOMES.
AND EFFECTIVE PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING SYSTEM ATTENDS TO THE
NEEDS OF SCHOOL LEADERS AND
TEACHERS. SCHOOL LEADERS LEARN
FROM EXPORT EXPERT MENTORS
COACHES AND PEERS ABOUT HOW TO
BECOME TRUE INSTRUCTIONAL
LEADERS. THEY WERE COLLABORATIVE
LEE WITH STAFF TO CREATE THE
CULTURE AND STRUCTURES NECESSARY
FOR CONTINUOUS PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
STUDENT LEARNING NEEDS AND TO
MAKE DATA TO SIFT DATA DRIVEN
DECISIONS ABOUT CONTENT AND
PEDAGOGY. AND ASSESS LEARNING IN
A WAY THAT MAINTAINS HIGH
EXPECTATIONS. EATERS ARE
PROVIDED REGULAR PROTECTED AND
SUPPORTED OPPORTUNITIES IN THEIR
SCHEDULE TO MEET IN GRADE LEVEL
OR CONTENT AREAS. A TEEN AREA
TEAMS AND THEY SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR STUDENT
SUCCESS. THESE LEARNING TEAMS
FOLLOW A CYCLE OF CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT THAT INCLUDES
EXAMINING STUDENT DATA TO
DETERMINE AREAS OF GREATEST
STUDENT AND EDUCATOR NEEDS
IDENTIFYING CREATING LEARNING
EXPERIENCES TO ADDRESS EDUCATOR
NEEDS AS WELL. DEVELOPING
EFFECTIVE LESSONS AND
ASSESSMENTS APPLYING NEW
CLASSROOM STRATEGIES REFINING
LESSONS AND ASSESSMENTS BASED ON
NEW LEARNING REFLECTING ON THE
IMPACT OF STUDENT LEARNING AND
THEN REPEATING THE CYCLE AS
NICHOLS EMERGE. IN RESPONSE TO
THE TO THE DISPARITIES AND
CHALLENGES EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC HIGH QUALITY
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING SUPPORT
EDUCATORS TO IMPLEMENT TRAUMA
INFORMED AND HEALING CENTERS
PRACTICES RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PRACTICES CULTURAL RESPONSIVE
AND ANTI RACIST TEACHING
PRACTICES. RELATIONSHIP CENTERED
SCHOOLS FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
PRACTICES IN OTHER WHOLE CHILD
PRACTICES WITHIN A SCIENCE OF
LEARNING AND DEVELOPMENT
FRAMEWORK. COOL SCHEDULES
INCLUDING DEDICATED INCLUDE
DEDICATED DEDICATED PAID
INDIVIDUAL PLANNING AND GROUP
COLLABORATION TIME EDUCATORS
HAVE ACCESS TO SYSTEMS AND
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ALLOW THEM TO
SHARE RESOURCES AND KNOWLEDGE
STAFF RETREATS AND TEAM BUILDING
ACTIVITIES HELP REBUILD
RELATIONSHIPS AFTER THE
ISOLATION OF DISTANCE LEARNING.
AND PROGRAMS AND PRACTICES ARE
MADE AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT STAFF
AND HEALTH AND WELL BEING. AND
SOME ARE EDUCATORS DESERVE HIGH
QUALITY PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT SUPPORT THEM
TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS WITH
PARTICULAR EMPHASIS ON THE
STRUCTURES AND CONTENT WE NOW
LEAD TO POSITIVE OUTCOMES AMID
THE PRESSING NEEDS. OF THIS
EXCEPTIONAL TYPE OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION. I'M JOINED WITH
KRISTEN CHRIS ALLEN FRUIT FROM
OUR EDUCATOR EXCELLENCE AND
EQUITY DIVISION WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
RIGHT. THANK YOU JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION IS THIS IS A QUESTION.
YOU GOT THAT. GROWING PAINS. ARE
THERE ANY EDUCATOR INDUCTION OR
MENTORSHIP PROGRAMS- THAT ARE
NOT SUFFICIENTLY FUNDED TO ALL
ELEAZAR. AT THE BOTTOM PART OF
THE FINANCE- FINANCE RECOGNIZES
THAT EVERYBODY WILL HAVE A
DIFFERENT INTERPRETATION FOR
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE SUFFICIENTLY
FUNDED- I'LL NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT TEACHER INDUCTION AND-
PROMOTE MENTORSHIP OPPORTUNITIES. OKAY. THAT'S ALL THE QUESTIONS
I HAVE FOR THIS ITEM NO ONE ELSE
IS HERE SO PROCEED TO ISSUE
NUMBER HOLD IT OPEN WELL THAT
OPEN TILL OUR MAY REVISE HEARING
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE CAREER AND
COLLEGE READINESS. AND L. A. O.
CD E. THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
AND THE OFFICE OF. PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION.
OKAY WE'LL START WITH L. A. L.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BRUCE
MICHAEL FEATHERS WITH THE
ILLEGAL. A PROVIDING A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF CT RELATED ISSUES
AND THE STATES KEEP ON FIFTY
PROGRAMS. OF A BEGIN BY SHARING
A FEW STATISTICS ABOUT
GRADUATION AND COLLEGE AND
CAREER READINESS. THE LEADERS
THAT WE HAVE ACCESS TO SO THAT
THE CALIFORNIA'S FOR YOUR HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION RATES. ARE
ABOUT 86% WHICH IS SIMILAR TO
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE. ALL OF THE
STATE'S GRADUATE 54% ENROLLED IN
COLLEGE AFTER GRADUATING HIGH
SCHOOL. OF THOSE ENROLLING IN
COLLEGE FIFTY FIVE PERCENT-
ENROLLED IN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE 30% ENROLLED IN EITHER
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OR THE
USE USE USE YOUR SYSTEM. NOW
WITH THE REMAINING 50% ENROLLED
EITHER OUT OF STATE OR PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS. OF THE STATE HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES ABOUT HALF
COMPLETED THE COLLEGE
PREPARATORY COURSEWORK REQUIRED
TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE FRESHMAN
ADMISSION TO UC AND CSU SYSTEMS.
KNOWN AS THE A. THREE G. SERIES
- GAPS EXIST FOR CERTAIN
SUBGROUPS FOR EXAMPLE 40% OF
GRADUATES WERE LOW INCOME-
COMPLETED THIS A THREE G.
SERIES. AND ONLY 12% OF FOSTER
YOU'VE WELCOME TO H. TWO G.
SERIES. WHAT IS IT AS NOTED IN
YOUR AGENDA THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET INCLUDED ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION. FOR
THE R. EIGHT THREE G. COMPLETION
IMPROVEMENT GRANT PROGRAM. WHICH
WAS AIMED AT ON INCREASING IF
THE REGION COMPLETION RATES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. AND ENGLISH LEARNERS.
AS PART OF THE STATE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM THIS
REPORT VARIOUS L. COMES. TO THE
STATE WHICH IS THEN DISPLAYED ON
THE PUBLIC'S WEBSITE ON A SCHOOL
DASHBOARD. UNDER THE STATE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE POOR
PERFORMANCE. FOR ONE OR MORE
STUDENTS OF GROUP BASED ON THE
INDICATORS MUST EXAMINE. ON THE
REAL ISSUES AND ACCESS SUPPORT
TO HELP THEM TO IMPROVE. THE US
COULD ASK FOR INPUT ON INCLUDES
A VARIETY OF DATA INCLUDING
STANDARDIZED TEST SCORES
GRADUATION RATES IN SUSPENSION
RATES. ANOTHER KEY INDICATOR IS
THE COLLEGE AND CAREER INDICATOR
WHICH COMBINES ALL INFORMATION
ABOUT STUDENTS. OF COURSE
COMPLETION CITY PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION. AND TEST SCORES
OF THE INDICATOR ALLOWS MULTIPLE
WAYS FOR THE DISPLAY FOR
STUDENTS TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
THEY ARE PREPARED OR PROPORTION
PREPARED. OF SUCH AS ON LOW
COMPLETING FIRST USE YOU AT HOME
AND YOU SEE REQUIREMENTS-
PARTICIPATING IN CITY PATHWAYS
PROGRAM. A COMPUTER AP
COURSEWORK SO BEING PREPARED
WOULD BE IN THAT THEY- COMPLETED
TWO OF THOSE CRITERIA AND
APPROACHING REPAIRS JUST
COMPLETING ONE AND NOT PREPARED
IS- NOT. COMPLETING ANY OF THOSE
INDICATORS. MMHM AND 209044% OF
THE STATE HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
WORD AGAIN PREPARED 17% WERE
APPROACHING PREPARED. AND 39%
WERE NOT PREPARED. AS A FIGURE
ON PAGE THIRTY ONE OF YOUR
AGENDA SHOWS. THERE ARE OFTEN
GAPS IN THEIR OWN COLLEGE
READINESS. ABOUT RACIAL
SUBGROUPS. MMHM THE STATE HAS TO
K. TWELVE FIFTY PROGRAMS VIA A
CRITICAL EDUCATION A FDERAL
GRANT ONE OF THE FEW TOOK
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE CITY
AND THE K. TOOLS FROM WERE FIRST
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE CCC
FERIA CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ON
THE PROGRAMS BOTH PROVIDE
COMPETITIVE GRANTS TO SCHOOLS
WITH DIFFERENT FORMULAS TO
CONSIDER FACTORS SUCH AS- FIFTY
PROGRAM FIVE AND BOTH PROGRAMS
HAVE A LOCAL MATCH REQUIREMENT
OF. TWO DOLLARS FOR EVERY ONE
DOLLAR BEEN THINKING- WHERE THE
CITY THE FIFTY PROGRAM IS.
INTENDED TO COVER A BROADER
RANGE OF GOALS. BEYOND FOR FIRST
TRAINING SUCH AS STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT AND CAREER
EXPLORATION. THE K. TWELVE FROM
OUR FIRST PROGRAM IS PRIMARILY
INTENDED TO ADDRESS REGIONAL
WORKFORCE NEEDS. AND CORKER
SCHOOLS TO PARTNER WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. BOTH PROGRAMS
WERE FUNDED AT A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING ON THE
LAST FISCAL YEAR BUT AT THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET.
DOUBLED THE FUNDING FOR C. TWO
TO THREE HUNDRED MILLION- IN
ADDITION TO THE K. TWELVE FIFTY
PROGRAMS. THERE ARE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PROGRAMS. THAT ARE
ALIGNED WITH THE PROVIDE SUPPORT
TO EXISTING K. TWELVE PROGRAMS.
THAT PROMOTE COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS THE STATE PROVIDES.
TWO HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FOR THE-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR OUR FIRST
PROGRAM. WHICH SHARE THE SAME
REGIONAL STRUCTURE WITH THE KIDS
WILL STRONGER FOR PROGRAM. ON
BOTH PROGRAMS ARE REQUIRED TO
FOCUS ON- REGIONAL WORKFORCE
NEEDS WITH THE CABLE PROGRAM
INTENDED TO. FEED INTO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DEGREE AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS. IN
ADDITION IF THEY PROVIDE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND YOU
AND YOU WILL BE. IN A PORTION OF
FUNDING TO- SUPPORT DUAL
ENROLLED STUDENTS. WITH THE HELP
OF ALSO PROVIDES A HUNDRED ONE
POINT EIGHT. MILLION ONGOING AND
PULP AND PROGRAM SUPPORT FOR
MIDDLE COLLEGE EARLY HIGH
SCHOOLS. ON THE EVE. BECAUSE OUR
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR CHARTER SCHOOL IN A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO OPERATE A
HIGH SCHOOL ON A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUS. ON THAT
CONCLUDES OUR COMMENTS ON. ON
THE OVERVIEW THIRTY. THOUSAND
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MICHAEL. AT
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO CITY CORRECT
THANK YOU. A GOOD MORNING GERMAN
PARTY AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS P. CALLOUS ON THE
DIVISION DIRECTOR OF THE CAREER
COLLEGE TRANSITION DIVISION AT
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TODAY I'M- HERE TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMAN. THE
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
CENTER GRANT PROGRAM WAS
ORIGINALLY ESTABLISHED BY THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY FIFTEEN
WITH ONE TIME INVESTMENT OF NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO COVER
A THREE YEAR SPAN. AND ACTED AS
A BRIDGE FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO SUPPORT CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
UNTIL THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WAS FULLY FUNDED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT. THE C. TAG
IN THE K. TWELVE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS WERE EACH
ALLOCATED A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDS
THE DISSIDENT AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION WAS
PROVIDED ANNUALLY TO ESTABLISH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
IN WORKFORCE PATHWAY QUARTERS IN
SUPPORT OF BOTH STATE
INITIATIVES. THE C. TAKE AND K.
TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY. THE CITY IS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
K. TWELVE STRONG WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS CURRENTLY ADMINISTERED
BY THE CALIFORNIA THREE COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT C. TAKE
FUNDING WAS INCREASED TO THREE
HUNDRED MILLIONDOLLARS ANNUALLY
WITH NO CHANGE IN THE REQUIRED
ELIAN MATCH OF TWO TO ONE. SEAT
IS MINUTE CD HAS ADMINISTERED
TWO ROUNDS ROUND SEVEN A. AND
SEVEN B. FOUR REQUEST FOR
APPLICATIONS DURING THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL
YEAR. CD RECEIVED THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY APPLICATIONS AROUND
SEVEN A. AND FUNDED THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO GRANTEES
WITH ALLOCATION TOTAL
DISTRIBUTION OF APPROXIMATELY.
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS BROWN B. IS
CURRENTLY IN THE SCORING PROCESS
CITY RECEIVED FORTY APPLICATIONS
FOR C. TAKE AROUND SEVENTY WITH
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE FOR FUNDING.
THE FUNDING ALLOCATIONS FOR L.
E. A. IS BASED ON A FORMULA WITH
NINE VARIABLES THAT INCLUDE
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE ALONG
WITH EIGHT POSSIBLE. POSITIVE
CONSIDERATIONS FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. L. A. ALLOCATION IS THE
LESSER OF THE FORMULA
CALCULATION. OR THE TWO TO ONE
MATCH. AS A TOTAL FUNDS
AVAILABLE INCREASE THE MATCH
RATIO OF TWO TO ONE LIMITS THE
ABILITY FOR C. D. E. TO
DISTRIBUTE ALL OF THE AVAILABLE
FUNDS. FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WITH THE ONE TIME
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE THERE
WAS FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE WITH A ONE TO
ONE MATCH. AND CD WAS ABLE TO
ALLOCATE. ALL OF THOSE FUNDS. CD
IS GRATEFUL FOR THE PROPOSED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. FOR THE CG
PARTICULAR EDUCATION INCENTIVE
GRANT PROGRAM. I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
AND I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU MANY COLLEGES.
GOOD MORNING- WAS I NEVER WRITE
WITH COMPANY COMING BECAUSE SHE
ANSWERS OFFICE- I WILL FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON THE K. TWELVE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM AND
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE CURRENT
IMPLEMENTATION THE ULTIMATE GOAL
OF THE K. TWELVE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM IS TO FUND AND
SUPPORT A. TWELVE LTA IS IN
CREATING AND EXPANDING CTE
COURSES OR SEQUENCE PROGRAMS OF
STUDY AND PATHWAYS. FOR STUDENTS
TRANSITIONING TO SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION TO A LIVING WAGE
EMPLOYMENT ON THE FOCUS REALLY
IS ON BUILDING THE FOUNDATION
FOR A CAREER PATHWAYS AND SKILLS
AND ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE
THOSE ALL LEAD TO INDUSTRY
VALUED CERTIFICATES CREDENTIALS
AND TRANSFER OPTIONS THE CHANCES
OF HIS JUST COMPLETED THE FOURTH
ROUND OF FUNDING OF K. TWELVE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM.
KANTOR'S OFFICE WORKS CLOSELY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
EDUC OF EDUCATION ON THIS
PROCESS FOR A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND OF HOW AWARDS ARE
PROVIDED LOCAL ALLEY ETS SUBMIT
APPLICATIONS IN EARLY AUGUST AND
A SELECTION COMMITTEE
REPRESENTATIVE OF A REGION'S
WORKS TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
APPLICATIONS ARE REVIEWED AND-
ARE SELECTED- IN A TIMELY MANNER
SO THAT FUNDING CAN GO OUT
HUNTING IS CONSISTENTLY GONE OUT
THE FIRST PRINCIPLE
APPORTIONMENT- TO ENSURE THAT
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE. THIS
YEAR TWO HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
APPLICATIONS WERE AWARDED ACROSS
EIGHT REGIONS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK TO EXPAND THE OBJECTIVES OF
THIS PROGRAM MEETING THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATION AS WELL AS
THE POTENTIAL ALIGNMENT BETWEEN
OUR WORK- AND EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CAREER
DEVELOPMENT EDUCATION AT HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU NEXT IS THE
OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION. MORNING AND THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY MY
NAME IS BARBARA CAN'T MINOR AND
THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION I AM HAPPY FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE
PROGRESS ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE REGIONAL K. SIXTEEN
EDUCATION COVERAGE GRANT PROGRAM
WITH YOU TODAY. ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION IS A MINISTER IN
THE COMPETITIVE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR. REGIONAL
K. SIXTEEN EDUCATION CLUBBERS
GRANT PROGRAM THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET ACTS. THE PSC
WAS SELECTED DUE TO OUR DECADES
LONG EXPERIENCE AND
ADMINISTERING THE SCHOOL
FACILITY PROGRAM AND OUR
FAMILIARITY WITH THE K. TWELVE
SCHOOL DISTRICT POPULATION.
ACTUALLY ALSO AUTHORIZED THE USE
OF A THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR
FOR PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION. AND
THE FOUNDATION FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WAS SELECTED
AS THE THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR
AND IS ACTIVELY WORKING WITH THE
PSC ON THE ON THE PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT. FOUNDATION CCC
BRINGS A STRONG BACKGROUND WITH
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS AT
ALL LEVELS AS WELL AS BACKGROUND
GRANT PROGRAMS AND THEY HAVE
PRIOR EXPERIENCE WITH CONGRESS
AS WELL. GENERAL STATUS ON THE
PROGRAM AND PROGRAM THAT REACHES
READ TO DATE THERE HAVE BEEN TWO
INFORMATIONAL WEBINARS THE FIRST
OCCURRED IN DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THIS WAS A- A
BROADER OVERVIEW OF THE PROGRAM
AND THE PROGRAM GOALS. AND THE
SECOND OCCURRED ON FEBRUARY
FIFTH AND IN FEBRUARY THIS WAS
AN EXPANSION OF THAT OVERVIEW
AND ALSO SHARE THE GENERAL
OUTLINE OF THE PROGRAM WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. TO SEEK FEEDBACK
ON AND THE PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION. THIS DEBATE TO
THE CREATION OF A SHARED
INTEREST LISTS SO THAT MEMBERS.
OF THE POTENTIAL PARTNERS FOR
THE COLLABORATIVE COULD REACH
OUT TO OTHERS IN THEIR REGION TO
CONNECT AND SEE IF THERE WAS
SOME INTEREST IN JOINING FORCES
AND SUBMITTING AN APPLICATION.
THERE IS ALSO AN ADDITIONAL
WEAPON ARE SCHEDULED FOR APRIL
EIGHTH FROM TEN THIRTY TO ELEVEN
THIRTY AND THIS WEAPON ARE IS
GOING TO WALK THE INTERESTED
APPLICANTS THE ROOM LOOKS. THE
ACTUAL GRANT APPLICATION ITSELF.
SO THE PROGRAM THAT WEBSITE IS
LIVE IN ITS NEW FORMAT OKAY YES
HE HAD ESTABLISHED A TEMPORARY
HOLD A SPOT FOR THE PROGRAM AND
THAT INITIAL STAGES FALCONS WERE
GETTING STARTED. BUT WE HAVE
TRANSITIONED OVER TO THAT NEW
WEBSITE AND ALL NEW INFORMATION
IS NOW FOUND AT. W. W. W. DOT K.
SIXTEEN COLLABORATIVE DOESN'T
WORK. AND IT DOES INCLUDE A LIST
SERVE AND FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS DOCUMENT. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE PROGRAM DESIGN AND- ONE OF
THE THINGS WE HAVE OPTED TO USE
THE ESTABLISHED REGIONS THAT
ALIGN WITH THE SURF REGIONS THE
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC RESILIENCE
FUND REGIONS. IT MADE SENSE TO
LINK UP WITH THIS COMPONENT OF
THE PROGRAM WITH SIR BECAUSE OF
THE SIMILARITIES. FOR THE TWO
PROGRAMS. YEAH THE INTENT OF
THE- PROGRAM IN TO ANSWER.
REGIONAL EDGE. OR WORKFORCE. AS
A TO MAKE A SICK. IMPACT ON THE
REGIONAL ECONOMY SO IT'S
IMPRACTICAL TO KEEP THE REGIONAL
BOUNDARIES AT THE SAME FOR THOSE
TWO PROGRAMS. WE DO ANTICIPATE
HAVING ONE AWARD HER SERVE
REGION. AND THE PROGRAM WAS
DESIGNED IN TWO PHASES AND THE
FIRST PHASE IS COMING UP VERY
SOON AND THIS IS GOING TO BE.
AND WE'RE CALLING IT OUR FAST
TRACK THING IS THIS IS FOR THE
MORE ESTABLISHED COOPERATIVES
WHO ARE ESSENTIALLY READY TO GET
STARTED WITH THIS GRANT FUNDING.
SO THIS IS THE PHASE ONE GROUP
AND THE APPLICATION FILING
PERIOD FOR THIS GROUP ACTUALLY
BEGINS NEXT WEEK ON APRIL FIRST
AND CLOSES ON MAY SECOND. GRANT
AWARDS WILL BE ANNOUNCED ON MAY
TWENTIETH AND THERE IS A SELF
ASSESSMENT TOOL ON THE NEW
WEBSITE THAT APPLICANTS CAN USE
TO DETERMINE IF THEY ARE A GOOD
FIT. FOR THE PHASE ONE
APPLICATION PROCESS. DURING THE
M. B. DURING THE DISCUSSIONS THE
PROGRAM DEVELOPMENTS AND IT IT
BECAME. BECAME EVIDENT THAT
THERE WERE A LOT LOT OF
POTENTIAL PARTNERS FOR THE
COLLABORATIVE'S THAT WE'RE
INTERESTED IN THIS EFFORT BUT
MAYBE WE'RE NOT QUITE READY TO
GO THEY DIDN'T HAVE ALL THE
PARTNERSHIPS IN PLACE AND WILL
NOT NECESSARILY BE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT AND THE
STUDENTS SO THAT PROGRAM DESIGN
INCORPORATED. A PHASE TWO FOR
FUNDING AND THE SECOND PHASE
INCLUDED AN INITIAL PLANNING
GRANTS AS WELL AS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO APPLY FOR AN IMPLEMENTATION
GRANT LATER ON SO THE FAMOUS TO
PLANNING GRANTS THOSE
APPLICATIONS WILL BE LAUNCHED ON
SEPTEMBER FIRST OF THIS YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND AWARDS
WILL BE ANNOUNCED IN OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND THEN THE
IMPLEMENTATION GRANT PERIOD WILL
FOLLOW ABOUT A YEAR LATER SO
SEPTEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE THE APPLICATION WILL BE
LAUNCHED IN AWARDS WILL E
ANNOUNCED ON OCTOBER TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY THREE. WE
ARE ANTICIPATING THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS FOR BOTH
PHASE ONE AND PHASE TWO WILL BE
IN THE RANGE OF FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS PER
COLLABORATIVE AND THE PLANNING
GRANTS WILL RANGE FROM A HUNDRED
TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND WE DO ANTICIPATE
THAT DIFFERENT COLLABORATORS
WILL HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS WITHIN
THOSE FUNDING. OF PRINTERS. IN
JUST A FEW ADDITIONAL NOTES ON
THE- THIS WE DO HAVE A GRANT
AGREEMENT AND- DEVELOPMENT FOR
THE PROGRAM AS WELL AS REGULAR
REPORTING PERIODS. AFTER AUDITS
AND CHECK INS RELATED TO BOTH
EXPENDITURES ON PROGRESS. AND WE
EXPECT SOME CASE STUDIES TO COME-OUT OF THIS AS WELL AS OTHER
TYPES OF DATA COLLECTION. AND IN
CLOSING WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING THE APPLICATIONS COME IN
VERY SOON WE HAVE. SEEN A LOT OF
INTEREST SO FAR ACROSS THE STATE
AND- ALL AREAS SO WE'RE EXCITED
TO SEE WHAT THE APPLICANTS PUT
FORTH IN THERE AND PROPOSALS.
AND WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE
AMOUNT OF INTEREST THAT WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN SO FAR AND- RELATED
TO THIS EXCITING PROGRAM. AND
WITH THAT I AM AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU I DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR YOU. THIS
IS A UNIQUE PROGRAMMING
CATHERINE AT THE END LAST YEAR
NOT. CERTAIN THE- VIA THE MERITS
OF THIS AND WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE BUT- YOU HAVE TO MOVE ON TO
OTHER STUFF. I'M I THINK THE ONE
ISSUE THAT THAT WE ARE CONVINCED
APPEAR ON THE BODY AT.
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE TWO. CD
PROGRAM HAS A GREAT LOVE FOR C.
T. AND WE'RE NOT CERTAIN WHY WE
HAVE TO PROGRAM SO. AND MR
DONNELLY STRONG OPINIONS ON THIS
AND PENDING LEGISLATION AGAIN.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM LA- WHAT WE
THINK ABOUT THE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM. AND THE PROGRAM
CDP WHICH WE- STRONGLY SUPPORT
AND DOUBLE OUR STATE SUPPORT FOR
LAST YEAR AND HAS ON GOING DOWN
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN PLANNING
MAKE AN ONGOING. PRIORITY DOES
IT MAKE SENSE TO HAVE TWO
PROGRAMS WE CONSOLIDATED INTO
ONE. WHAT'S YOUR TAKE. FROM A
RECORD BROUGHT THE LEADS WE
DON'T **** WITH WE DON'T HAVE
ANY SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATION- ON
THIS ISSUE AND THEY DO THE
PROGRAMS DO SIR SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT- GOLD HERE SO I THINK
PART OF THE ISSUE IS YOU KNOW TO
WHAT LEVEL OF- YOU KNOW AND
INFINITE. PUBLIC ON BOTH THE
MINERAL DUNFORD DOUBLES
PREFERENCE FOR THIS THE TECH
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN TERMS OF DESIGNING THAT
PROGRAM LOOKS LIKE. THEY HAVE TO
BE VERY SPECIFICALLY ALIGNED TO
THE I KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE A
RECCO YOU DON'T HAVE ONE FOR US
TODAY BUT DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD
CONTINUE GOING FORWARD IN.
CALIFORNIA YOUR EDGAR KING FOR
THE DAY IN CITY. WOULD YOU HAVE
TO COMPANION THINGS ARE. FOCUSED
ON. ON ONE PROGRAM WHERE WE CAN
MAXIMIZE. WITH REGARD TO GET
DEPENDS ON WHETHER YOU THINK
THAT THESE. CALLS ARE CLEAR BUT
YOU'RE CLEARLY GETTING DIFFERENT
THINGS FROM BOTH PROGRAMS THAT
YOU LIKE- AND IF YOU DO THEM
THAT MAYBE THERE'S A REASON TO
HAVE THEM SEPARATE BUT- IF THE
PROGRAMS ARE. ESSENTIALLY
SERVING FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU FIND
OUT THAT. ON THE GROUND
DISTRICTS ARE USING THEM FOR
SIMPLY THE FAME PROGRAM BUT THEY
HAVE TO DEAL WITH DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF REQUIREMENTS AND
DOUBLE THE APPLICATIONS THEN
YOU'D HAVE MORE WE WOULD HAVE
MORE CONCERNS. A POSITIVE FOR
SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T HAVE
SPECIFIC INFORMATION ON THAT
LEVEL THE DIVIDING EVERYTHING
THAT'S- OUT OF THE WAY WE WOULD
THINK ABOUT- DECIDING WHETHER
YOU THINK THAT. IT'S WORTH
HAVING THE TWO PROGRAMS THAT I
AGREED IN GENERAL AND WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THIS WHEN WE GET TO THE
NEXT. THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
IS. YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS THAT
DISTRICTS HAVE TO HAVE DIFFERENT
RULES AND UNDERSTAND HOW EACH OF
THESE DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAMS
WORK. WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS THERE IS CLARITY AND
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING THAT WE'RE
GETTING SOMETHING DIFFERENT HERE
AND THAT IT MAKES. THERE'S LIKE
A CLEAR CLEAR CASE FOR WHY NOT
WHY THAT SHOULD OCCUR. OKAY AND
THEN FROM THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
PERSPECTIVE. WE HEARD FOR YEARS
THAT THEY NEEDED ONGOING NOT
JUST ONE TIME TO DO PROPER
PLANNING. AND DO WE THINK THAT
SINCE WE NOW HAVE HAD ONGOING
THAT ALL DISTRICTS HAVE STEPPED
UP AND BASICALLY BROUGHT BACK
THEIR PROGRAMS THAT MAYBE DIDN'T. EXIST DURING THE RECESSION.
YES I THINK THAT'S- WHERE. YOU
KNOW I THINK WHEN THESE PROGRAMS
WERE DEVELOPED I THINK FROM. YOU
KNOW THIS WAS ALL. COMING
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
ALFIE FF THERE WAS A- ADDITIONAL
FUNDING PROVIDED FOR THE HIGH
SCHOOL FOR HIGH SCHOOL. EIGHTY
EIGHT WITH THE IDEA THAT THAT
WOULD BE USED IN PART FOR. THE
D. E. IN THESE PROGRAMS WERE
WERE CONTINUED IN PART BECAUSE
THERE MIGHT NEED TO BE SOME
FUNDING TO KEEP THE PROGRAM
GOING. MIGHT BE NEED SOME ONE
TIME ACTIVITIES. ARE YOU MIGHT
WANT TO FUN WITH THESE GRANTS. I
THINK OUR OFFICE IN GENERAL HAS
TENDED TO. RECOMMEND YOU KNOW.
USING VLC OF ADD ON OR ELSE IF I
PROCESS AS A WAY TO FIND T. T.
E. SO I THINK. IT IT IT DOES
SEEM LIKE AT THIS POINT IF YOUR
CONCERN WAS. GETTING YOU KNOW.
PROGRAMS GOING AWAY ANY PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN MAINTAINED OVER TIME
ADDING THE QUESTION THEN BECOMES
LIKE. YOU KNOW. IF THEIR
INTERESTS ARE AND NEED FOR.
ADDITIONAL START UP. FUNDING FOR
NEW PROGRAMS TO BE DEVELOPED.
OKAY ENDED THAT CHARACTER MANY
COLLEGES MUST NEVER AT ONE IN-
RESPOND THEN. WHY WE THINK THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE TWO PROGRAMS IN
YOUR UNIQUE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM. SIMILARLY WE DON'T HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION THE ONLY
THING THAT WE WOULD HIGHLIGHT IS
THAT- AS YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT
HOW TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BOTH
IN THE BUDGET AND POLICY- IF THE
LEGISLATURE WORD TO TRANSITION
THE PROGRAM WOULD. THAT WE'D
REQUEST THAT IT BE DONE BEFORE
THE FIFTH ROUND OF GRANTS BEGAN
IN AUGUST AND DID THAT THE FULL
PROGRAM TRANSITION AS YOU KNOW
THE CANCERS OFFICE PROVIDES THE
CAPACITY FOR THESE GRANTS THAT
ESSENTIALLY ALL GO. TO K. TWELVE
SO WE ARE SHOULDERING THE
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION WE DO SEE
THE BENEFITS AND ALIGNING- THOSE
TRANSITIONS FROM ME OR FROM K.
TWELVE TO- TO A HIGHER READ- AS
ALL OF THESE PARTNERSHIPS THAT
RECEIVED GRANTS AND FUNDING THE
TWO HUNDRED AND ELEVEN. DO YOU
HAVE A HIGHER AND PARTNER AT THE
WORK CLOSELY IN THE DESIGN. BUT
IF- THAT LEGISLATURE WORD TO
DESIRE THIS TO LIVE IN A
DIFFERENT PLACE AGAIN WE WOULD.
ASK THAT THE FULL PROGRAM BE
MOVED AND NOT JUST PARTS OF IT.
OKAY THANK YOU MR DONALD. I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT I THINK WHAT
YOU'VE ALREADY COVERED I JUST
WALKED IN I WAS IN ANOTHER
MEETING I THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
THAT IS JUST THAT WE SHOULD
COMBINE THE TWO- THE STRONG WORK
FORCE SLIDE BACK UP SLIDE OVER
TO SEE WHERE IT BELONGS IF YOU
LOOK AT THE AUDIT WE SHOULD
ENSURE CODE IT WHAT'S BEEN GOING
ON OVER THERE HAS NOT WORKED-
AND I KNOW YOU'RE AN OVERWORKED
IT I KNOW THAT. THE CHANCES
OFFICES AN OVERWORKED OFFICE I
GET IT- BUT I JUST THINK FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS- PUTTING THE
STRONG WORK FORCE OVER IN CD IS
A MUCH BETTER THING FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN AND
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY WITH THAT
BACK TO YOU MR. S. THANK YOU
100% CURRENTS AND WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD WELL THIS IS SHE WAS
JUST INFORMATIONAL LAST YEAR'S.
BUDGET AND ONGOING. A C. T.
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA AT ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE IS RELATED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSALS RELATE TO COLLEGE AND
CAREER READY. I'M SORRY. THE
ISSUE SIX YES THANK YOU AND
WE'LL HAVE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ELLIE LCD AND THEN THE CHANCES
OFFICE ONCE AGAIN. THE CHAIR OUT
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH ART IN
FINANCE- ALL TRY TO KEEP MY
COMMENTS RELATIVELY BRIEF Q. AND
HE HAS TO EXPAND THE OFFERING OF
SEAMLESS PATHWAYS FROM HIGH
SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND CAREER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION. ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF PATHWAYS PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY
IN THE FIELDS OF TECHNOLOGY
HEALTH CARE EDUCATION AND
CLIMATE RELATED FIELDS- THROUGH
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE GOLDEN
STATE PATHWAYS PROGRAM. THE
FUNDS WOULD BE USED FOR TWO
TYPES OF AWARDS A PLANNING-
AWARD AND AN IMPLEMENTATION
AWARD- FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE WOULD
BE AVAILABLE THROUGH JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN-
AS A CONDITION OF RECEIVING A
GRANT UNDER THE- GOLDEN STATE
PATHWAYS PROGRAM A RECIPIENT
WOULD COMMIT TO. IDENTIFYING
LONG TERM RESOURCES TO SUSTAIN
THE ONGOING OPERATIONAL COSTS OF
THE- PATHWAYS PROGRAMS. THAT ARE
DEVELOPED- THERE'S A LOT A FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO
SUPPORT. AND EXPAND ACCESS TO
DUAL ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS- WHICH
WE KNOW FROM RECENT RESEARCH
FROM THE WHEEL HEALTH CENTER AT
UC DAVIS- AS WELL AS THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA-
DUAL ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS HAVE.
SHOWN TO BE AN EFFECTIVE WAY OF
INCREASING OUR PATHWAYS. FOR
STUDENTS TO ENTER COLLEGE FROM
OR UNIVERSITY FROM HIGH SCHOOL-
WITH GREATER PERCENTAGES OF
STUDENTS WHO HAVE PARTICIPATED
IN. A DUAL ENROLLMENT COURSES
ULTIMATELY ENROLLING IN COLLEGE
OR UNIVERSITY- ADDITIONALLY
OTHER INVESTMENTS IN THE SET THE
SPACE THAT ARE NOTED IN THE
AGENDA INCLUDE A TWO MILLION
DOLLAR ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT TO SUPPORT THE-
AGRICULTURAL CATION- EDUCATION-
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. THERE IS-
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME TO
SUPPORT THE- PATHWAYS GRANT
PROGRAM FOR HIGH SKILLED CAREERS
WHICH IS- ADDED AN INNOVATION OF
AN EXISTING A ONE TIME GRANT
PROGRAM PREVIOUSLY FUNDED IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FISCAL
YEAR- WE PROPOSE. A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF HEALTHCARE ROTATIONAL-
PATHWAYS THROUGH ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAMS WITH A SPECIFIC FOCUS.
ON ENGLISH LEARNER PROFICIENCY
COURSES AND PATHWAYS- AND WITH
THAT I WILL. TURN IT OVER TO.
ALL BE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU. HELLO. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU AGAIN- CHAIRMAN OR THE
COMMITTEE I GOT FED UP WITH THE
ILLEGAL WE HAVE PUBLISHED A MORE
DETAILED ANALYSIS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON OUR WEBSITE A
LITTLE KEEPER COMMENTS HERE- TO
A HIGH LEVEL OF FOCUS AND TO
SECURE KEY ISSUES. REGARDING THE
GOLDEN STATE PATHWAYS PROPOSAL
OUR FIRST CONCERN IS THAT IT
WOULD ADD MORE COMPLEXITY TO THE
STATE'S APPROACH TO FUNDING
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS THE
PROPOSAL HAS SEVERAL ELEMENTS
THAT ARE SIMILAR TO THE STATE TO
VISIT TO EXISTING HIGH SCHOOL
CTE PROGRAMS HOWEVER THE SET THE
PROGRAM HAS A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF ADDITIONAL PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS HAVING A
PATHWAYS BE ALIGNED WITH USE YOU
AND YOU SEE A COURSE
REQUIREMENTS AND PROVIDING
STUDENTS WITH INTEGRATED SUPPORT
SERVICES. THERE COULD BE
BENEFITS TO ENCOURAGING SCHOOLS
TO IMPLEMENT SCHOOL PROGRAMS OF
THIS TYPE AS THEY CAN PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH GREATER OPTIONS
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL HOWEVER THE
PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE SCHOOLS
OFTEN OPERATING PROGRAMS WITH
THREE DIFFERENT SOURCES OF
FUNDING AND THREE DIFFERENT
PROGRAM RULES THIS CAN MAKE
IMPLEMENTING WELL L. PROGRAMS A
MINISTRY TO FLEE AND FISCALLY
CHALLENGING FOR US SCHOOLS. OUR
SECOND CONCERN IS THAT ALTHOUGH
THE PROPOSAL HAS CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS FOR THE TYPES OF
PATHWAYS THE PROGRAM GRANT
RECIPIENTS MUST DEVELOP AND ALSO
REQUIRES THEM TO SUBMIT OVER
BLESSED OF OUTCOME DATA
COLLECTION CRITICAL DETAILS AND
LEAVES A FEW A KEY DECISIONS THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION AND THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION SUCH AS- GRANT AMOUNTS
AND ALLOWABLE USES OF THE
FUNDING WITHOUT THESE DETAILS IT
IS DIFFICULT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO ASSESS. THE PROGRAM'S
POTENTIAL BENEFITS. A TO THESE.
WERE RECOMMEND THE- REQUEST
MINISTER PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION ON THE PROPOSALS
FROM ALL. PARTS OF MY REVISION
MANY OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WE
HAVE HAVE BEEN INCORPORATED INTO
GENDER. A FULL LIST OF OUR
QUESTIONS IS ON YOUR AGENDA
STARTING ON PAGE FORTY THREE.
REGARDING THE DORMER PROPOSALS
OUR PRIMARY CONCERN IS THAT THE
MINISTRATION HAS NOT IDENTIFIED
WHAT PROBLEMS CURRENTLY EXIST.
WITH ONE WOMAN IN PARTICULAR
DEMONSTRATION IS NOT SPECIFY
WHAT BARRIERS LEDS CURRENTLY
FAITH. AND- IMPLEMENTED TO
ENROLLMENT. THIS IS PARTICULARLY
THE CASE FOR THE- A COLLEGE AND
CAREER ACCESS PATHWAYS PROGRAMS
BECAUSE HE KEPT PROGRAMS WHICH
HAVE FISCAL INCENTIVES FOR BOTH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THE ENROLLMENT FOR
THE C. CAP PROGRAMS HAVE GROWN
SUBSTANTIALLY OVER RECENT YEARS
EVEN DURING THE PANDEMIC AGAINST
THE OVERALL TREND OF THE MOMENT
THE CLIENT AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. ON THE LAST CONCERN WE
HAVE A PLACE TO BOTH OF THE
PROPOSALS. ON WHAT IS THAT THEY
BOTH DO LITTLE TO TARGET FUNDING
TO SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS WILL
BENEFIT THE MOST. THE
ADMINISTRATION GIVE PRIORITY TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS WITH AT LEAST HALF OF
THE STUDENT POPULATION
CONSISTING OF ENGLISH LEARNERS
AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS. AMONG
OTHER METRICS SUCH AS HAVING
HIGHER THAN AVERAGE DROPOUT
REEF. BUT BASED ON JUST ON THAT
NUMBER OF- INVESTORS A LOCUM
STUDENTS WE FIND THAT AT LEAST
TWO THIRDS OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
MEET THE THRESHOLD FOR. PRIORITY
SUCH A BROAD DEFINITION IS
UNLIKELY TO HAVE MUCH EFFECT ON
STUDENTS THAT COULD MOST BENEFIT
FROM THE PROGRAM. IF THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTS A PROPOSAL WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER OTHER WAYS TO TARGET
FUNDING TO SCHOOLS. AND STUDENTS
WITH THE HIGHEST NEED. OF FOR
EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER INCREASING THE
THRESHOLD FOR PRIORITY FOR
DISTRICTS WITH SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF THEIR STUDENT
POPULATION- BEING LOW COMPARING
MR STUDENTS. OF THE LEGISLATURE
COULD ALSO REQUIRE GRANTEES TO
DEMONSTRATE. THAT THEY WILL BE
IMPLEMENTING THESE PROGRAMS
EQUITABLY ACROSS VARIOUS SCHOOLS
FAITH. AND IN A WAY THAT IS
TARGETED TO BENEFIT STUDENT
SUBGROUPS WITH LOWER COLLEGE AND
CAREER. OUTCOMES I'LL NOW TURN
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE ALLELE
OF POSTING HOW OFTEN. THANK YOU-
OSTEEN HOUSE WITH THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. I WILL TALK ABOUT TWO
ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS THAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE INTRODUCED
THAT'S THE PATHWAY GRANT PROGRAM
FOR HIGH SKILLED CAREERS AND
HEALTH CARE VOCATIONAL EDUCATION
THROUGH THE ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAM. AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES ON
PAGE THIRTY SIX IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
THE PATHWAYS GRANT PROGRAM WHICH
IS FORMALLY KNOWN IN STATUTE AS
THE CALIFORNIA STEM PATHWAYS
GRANT PROGRAM. BUT JUST TO MAKE
THE CONNECTION WITH THE
PROPOSALS YOU'VE JUST HEARD THE
PATHWAY GRANT PROGRAM IS REALLY
A UNIQUE TYPE OF DUAL ENROLLMENT
IS DESIGNED TO HAVE A CLOSE
CONNECTION INDUSTRY YOU HAVE
COHORTS OF STUDENTS START IN
NINTH GRADE AND THEY RECEIVE
INDIVIDUALIZED SUPPORT. SO THEY
CAN PROGRESS AT THEIR OWN PACE
AND THEN THE PROGRAM. ONLY MATES
IN A ASSOCIATES DEGREE THE
LEGISLATURE IS BEING ASKED TO
FUND TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS MORE
IN THESE PROGRAMS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR THEY'D HELP THE LEGISLATURE
MAKE A MORE INFORMED DECISION ON
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY WOULD BENEFIT
FROM A STATUS UPDATE FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ON HOW THE
CURRENTLY FUNDED PROGRAM IS
GOING. THE LEGISLATURE COULD ASK
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE FOR
INFORMATION SUCH AS HOW MANY
STUDENTS INITIALLY STARTED THESE
GRANT FUNDED PROGRAMS HOW MANY A
COUPLE YEARS AND ARE STILL
ENROLLED BUT THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
THE STUDENTS WHAT KIND OF
PROGRESS ARE THEY MAKING TOWARD
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA AND
GETTING COLLEGE CREDITS. AND I
UNDERSTAND IS THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE HAS COMPILED SOME INITIAL
DATA. OF FROM THE GRANTEES
LEGISLATURE COULD USE THIS IN
SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO.
THE SIDE AND WEIGH WHETHER TO
FUND THIS PROPOSAL IN THE BUDGET
YEAR OR TO USE THE MONEY FOR
OTHER- HIGHER PRIORITY PURPOSES.
WITH REGARD TO HEALTH CARE
VOCATIONAL EDUCATION THROUGH THE
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM THIS IS
AIMED AT ENGLISH LEARNERS. THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARD IN A PRIOR
HIGHER READ OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
MEETING ABOUT HOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ENROLLMENT HAS DECLINED
SIGNIFICANTLY AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC. NOW ENROLLMENT IN
ADULT EDUCATION WHICH FOCUS OF
FOCUSES ON PRE COLLEGIATE LEVEL
INSTRUCTIONAL WORKFORCE
TRAINING. HAS ACTUALLY DECLINED
EVEN MORE SIGNIFICANTLY
ENROLLMENT DATA FOR THE ADULT
SCHOOLS THROUGH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NON CREDIT PROGRAMS SHOWS THAT.
ADULT EDUCATION SERVING ABOUT
FIFTY THOUSAND FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS FEWER. THAN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC SO DECLINE
OF ABOUT A THIRD OF STUDENTS
THAT THEY'RE SERVING. NOW BASED
ON PRELIMINARY INFORMATION ADULT
EDUCATION ROMANCES RECOVERING
SLIGHTLY IN THE CURRENT YEAR BUT
PROVIDERS ARE STILL WELL BELOW
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS THEY WERE
SERVING- IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. NOW THOUGH
ENROLLMENT IS DOWN PROVIDERS
FUNDED BY THE STATE'S ABILITY
CATION PROGRAM ARE ACTUALLY- HAD
NOT SEEN A REDUCTION IN THE
FUNDING LEVEL. THAT'S BECAUSE IN
STATUTE. THE CREATED THE ADULT
EDUCATION CATEGORICAL PROGRAM.
THE PROVIDERS GET THIS MONEY
REGARDLESS OF ENROLLMENT SO IN
THE CURRENT YEAR THEY'RE GETTING
FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ACTUALLY WHICH IS AN
INCREASE FROM THE PRIOR YEAR SO
AS A RESULT PROVIDERS LIKELY
WILL HAVE SIGNIFICANT-
INSUFFICIENT CAPACITY NEXT YEAR
TO SERVE MORE STUDENTS WETHERBY
IN ENGLISH A SECOND LANGUAGE IN
THE HEALTH CARE TRAINING OR
OTHER TYPES OF ADULT EDUCATION
INSTRUCTION. WITH US RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. AND INSTEAD
RE DIRECT FUNDS TO HIGHER
PRIORITY- PURPOSES IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND HAVE THE ADULT ED
PROVIDERS SERVE THESE ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS IF THEY CAN ENROLL THE
STUDENTS USING THE FUNDS THEY
ALREADY HAVE. GIVEN ALL THE
EXCESS CAPACITY CURRENTLY HAVE
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU WHEN
THE GO AGAIN TO SEE THE E. AND
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THANK
YOU TERRY MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CALLAS THE
DIVISION DIRECTOR OVER THE
CURRENT CALL TRANSITION DIVISION
HERE ON BEHALF OF TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY THURMAN.
PROPOSED ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS
PROGRAMS THE PROPOSED PROGRAM
LANGUAGE FOR THE GOLD C.
PATHWAYS HAS MANY SIMILARITIES
TO LANGUAGE FOR THE CURRENT
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP ACADEMIES
PROGRAMME. CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP ACADEMY PROGRAM HAS
BEEN IN CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
CODE FOR OVER THIRTY FIVE YEARS
IS A HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
IS FOCUSED ON INTEGRATED COURSES
ACROSS A SPECIFIC PATHWAY
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP CALORIES HAVING A
THREE G. COMPLETION RATE OF
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FIVE
PERCENT. WHICH IS SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER THAN THE STATE AVERAGE OF
43% AND A HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
RATE OF ABOVE 95% IT IS ALSO
ABOVE THE STATE AVERAGE OF
EIGHTY SEVEN POINT THREE
PERCENT. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED OPPORTUNITIES FURTHER
DISCUSS THE SUSTAINABILITY PLAN
FOR THE GOLDEN STATE PATHWAYS
PROGRAM ALSO REGARDING THE
PROPOSED EXPANSION OF DORM ROOM
AT PROGRAMS OUR DIVISION HAS
SUPPORTED EARLY COLLEGE HIGH
SCHOOL AND MIDDLE COLLEGE HIGH
SCHOOL PROGRAMS ALONG WITH DUAL
ENROLLMENT ACROSS THE STATE. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY
TO FURTHER EXPAND DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS WHICH IN OUR
SECONDARY SCHOOLS AND POST
SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY AND I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
PROPRIOCEPTIVE THANK YOU-
COMMUNICATE LEGIS. AFTERNOON
GOOD YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN-
MEMBER PARTY MEMBER O'DONNELL-
UNDER THIS ITEM I'LL FOCUS MY
REMARKS ON THREE AREAS IT DUAL
ENROLLMENT UNDER THE- COLLEGE
AND CAREER ACCESS PATHWAYS KNOWN
TO SEE CAP. ADULT EDUCATION AND
TO THE CALIFORNIA STEM PATHWAYS
GRANT. WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE
THAT I DO ONE ROLE MANAGER C.
CAP WAS ELEVATED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CURRENTLY
SEVENTY SIX COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PARTICIPATING C. CAB. RIDING
NEARLY THIRTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
WITH ACCESS TO. EARLY COLLEGE
AND THESE PATHWAYS THAT ARE
PROVEN. THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SPECIALLY APPLIED THE
PROPOSAL TO REMOVE THE SUNSET ON
THIS PROVEN PROGRAM. THE SUNSET
HAS BEEN A BARRIER TO EXPANDING
PATHWAYS EXPANDING PARTNERSHIPS
WITH K. TWELVE DISTRICTS. AND IN
CREATING LONG TERM PLANNING TO
RECRUIT. AND ENGAGE UNDER
REPRESENTED AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES- WE ALSO URGE THAT
THE CONTINUED FOCUS ON DOING
ROMAN EXPANSION- BE FOCUSED ON
TRADITIONALLY UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS STUDENTS OF COLOR. AND
ENCOURAGE EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT
DUAL CREDIT. I AND THAT
STUDENTS- FIND OUT MORE ABOUT
THESE PROGRAMS YOUR GREATER AND
TARGETED. ENGAGEMENT AND
OUTREACH. WITH REGARD TO ADULT
EDUCATION AND VOCATIONAL- A
PROPOSAL- WE FIND THE GOALS A
LAUDABLE BUT CURRENTLY DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION NO WAIT FOR
FURTHER DETAILS AND DISCUSSION.
AROUND THE CALIFORNIA STEM
PATHWAYS GRANT AND THIS IS A
RELATIVELY NEW PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES- AS WAS SHARED BY THE
YELLOW- GRADES NINE THROUGH
FOURTEEN EDUCATIONAL PATHWAYS
AND- TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING AND
MATH ALL INDUSTRIES. THAT ARE
GROWING HAVE. PROVEN CREDENTIALS
THAT PROVIDE LITTLE LIVING WAGES
FOR STUDENTS AND ALSO ARE KNOWN
FOR NEEDING ADDITIONAL DIVERSE.
AND GREATER ACCESS PATHWAYS FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS THESE
PARTNERSHIPS ESTABLISHED
PATHWAYS BETWEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HIGH SCHOOLS AND
INDUSTRY EACH OF THESE PROGRAMS
HAVE AN INDUSTRY PARTNER THAT
WORK SIDE BY SIDE WITH THEM. THE
GENERAL GENERALLY THE GRANTS
HAVE SUPPORTED HIGH SCHOOLS THE
COLLEGE ONLINE PROGRAMS WITH A
DIRECT CONNECTION TO ENTRY LEVEL
JOBS THAT LEADER PROVIDE A
CAREER LADDER FOR STUDENTS. ARE
THE PROGRAMS RECENTLY LAUNCHED
AS I MENTIONED IN TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND CURRENTLY
SERVE JUST OVER SIX HUNDRED
STUDENTS. T AN INITIAL REPORT
IS NOT DUE UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE BUT WE WILL WE ARE
COMPILING SURVEY DATA SO THAT
YOU CAN GET A SENSE OF THIS
PROGRAM AND- AND ITS POTENTIAL
AND BENEFITS. EARLY SURVEY DATA
INDICATES THAT THE PROGRAM IS
MEETING THE INTENT- AND
PROVIDING GREATER ACCESS TO DUAL
ENROLLMENT SPECIFICALLY IN STEM
TO TRADITIONALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS WE
THINK THIS IS A WORTHY EFFORT.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU. THE
FIRST QUESTION I HAVE IS FOR THE
DUAL ENROLLMENT PROPOSAL. SO
THAT BEFORE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YEAH I GUESS YOU NEED.
YES THERE ARE BIG FANS OF DUAL
ENROLLMENT I THINK IT CAN BE A
GAME CHANGER FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND ACCESS AND- GETTING
THROUGH COLLEGE QUICKER RATE
LESS DEBT YOU KNOW LOTS OF
PLUSES. SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS
STUDENT ROLES THEY GET ETA OF
COURSE AND THE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES HAVE A PIECE OF IT TO.
SO WHAT IS THIS PROPOSING TO DO. SO THERE THERE ARE TWO KEY
COMPONENTS TO IT THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DO THE FIRST IS TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO ALLOW AN
ABEL AND ELLY EIGHT TO ENTER
INTO A C. CAP AGREEMENT AND THEN
TO A ULTIMATELY DEVELOP BUT OF
COURSE- FOR LIKE CATALOG OF
AVAILABLE COURSES FOR STUDENTS-
AFTER. AFTER SCHOOL FIGHT THE
SECOND AND PROBABLY LARGER
COMPONENT- TO THE PROPOSAL
ACTUALLY TO PROVIDE RESOURCES
TO- ROB PROVIDE SUPPORT SERVICES
TO STUDENTS ON THOSE CAMPUSES SO
IT'S NOT JUST- YOU KNOW THE
TEACHING COMPONENT BUT IT'S ALSO
TO PROVIDE. SOME LEVEL OF
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR TUTORING OR
ACCESS T THOSE TYPES OF
SERVICES AFTER THOSE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT ARE ENROLLED IN
THESE COURSES. SO CAN I ONE TIME
YOU WANT ONE TIME PLANNING MONEY
TO HELP. IT OUT- THE DYLAN ROMAN
. INDUSTRY ROUGHLY IN CALIFORNIA
. SO THAT THAT'S THAT'S ONE
COMPONENT YES OF THE PROPOSAL
THAT THE GRANTS THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE THAT'S THE SMALLEST
COMPONENT IT'S ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT FOR SCHOOL
SITE- BUT BOTH THE LARGER
COMPONENT WHICH IS FOCUSED ON
THE STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES IS
INTENDED TO BE USED OVER BY
SCHOOLS OVER A MULTI YEAR PERIOD
TOOK A PRIVATE TO PROVIDE THOSE
SUPPORT SERVICES SO IT'S NOT
JUST PLANNING IT SAID ADULT
SERVICES ACTUAL THOUGHT AROUND
HOW WE CAN HELP THOSE STUDENTS
BE SUCCESSFUL THROUGH THOSE
COURSES. BECAUSE ULTIMATELY IT'S
NOT JUST ACCESS THE TOLL FOR
SUCCESS IN THOSE COURSES YES SO
YOU WE OFFER THE COURSES SO IS
IT LIKE SUPPORT IS A FINANCIAL
IS A FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE WE GIVING TO THE
STUDENTS WHO IS A KOREAN. ROCK
LIKE INVESTED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. IS GOING TO. NOW
HIRING JOHNSON HIGH SCHOOL.
THINK OF IT SAC CITY COLLEGE FOR
ONE MOMENT. WHAT WILL THEY NOW
HAVE BECAUSE OF THIS PROPOSAL.
CERTAINLY I THINK WHAT WHAT WE
ENVISIONED AT THE PREDOMINANT-
MAJORITY OF THE FUNDS TO BE USED
FOR WOULD BE YOU KNOW SERVICES
LIKE TUTORING SERVICES LIKE
SUPPLEMENTAL- INSTRUCTION IF YOU
NEED HELP I IN YOUR COURSE-
THAT'S SORT OF WHAT WE ENVISION
THE BULK OF THE MONEY TO BE USED
BY SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE IT CAN
ALSO PROVIDE- YOU KNOW FOR
COUNSELING FOR THOSE STUDENTS TO
THE- TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY ARE
INTERESTED IN FINDING OUT WHAT
THEIR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITIES
COULD BE. AND HOW TO ENGAGE IN
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES YOU KNOW
ONCE THEY'RE THERE YOU COMPLETED
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL. CAREER OKAY.
THANK YOU.
SO IT IS THERE EVER BEEN A
THOUGHT FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I KNOW WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO NOT INAPPROPRIATELY SPENT ONE
TIME MONEY TO DO OUR BEST WE
HAVE THIS INFUSION OF ONE TIME
MONEY AND SO ASKED ISSUE AND
SOME THAT THINGS ARE KIND OF A
STRETCH AND- WE PUT THIS ONE
TIME MONEY OUT THERE AND- I'M
SEEING THIS LOCALLY WITH MY OWN
SCHOOL DISTRICT HERE. BUT THE
LOOMING STRIKE IS THAT THERE'S
ONE TIME FEDERAL MONEY AND- YOU
KNOW. COVERED MONEY AND IT'S
HARD TO. SPEND ON PEOPLE IS
THERE THE DISTRICTS ARE NERVOUS
ABOUT HAVING IT THERE SO. HAVE
YOU EVER THOUGHT ABOUT LIKE
BUNDLING THIS MORNING USING IT
OVER YOU KNOW FIVE TO TEN YEAR
PERIOD SO THEY CAN ACTUALLY HAVE
SOME CERTAINTY IN ACTUALLY. OUR
PEOPLE TO DO THE STUFF WE WANT
TO DO BECAUSE YOU'RE RUNNING
INTO THE SAME ISSUE OVER AND
OVER WE HAVE THESE GRAND IDEAS.
FOR ONE TIME AND WHEN THE RUBBER
HITS THE ROAD OUT THERE. DOESN'T
QUITE WORK. YES THE CERTAINLY
WORK MORE TEMPTING TO YOU KNOW
WE UTILIZE THE RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE OVER A MULTIYEAR PERIOD-
YOU KNOW WHERE WE THINK WE CAN-
DO THAT PRETTY SUCCESSFULLY- SO
YOU KNOW WE TRY TO BUILD THAT
INTO THIS PROGRAM- ESPECIALLY ON
THE SUPPORT SERVICE SIDE- SO
CERTAINLY WERE OPEN TO A
CONVERSATION AROUND. YOU KNOW IF
POTENTIALLY WORK WE'RE LOOKING
AT A TIME FRAME THAT'S TOO
SHORT- AND WE SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE
UP FURTHER BUT CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW THIS TIES BACK TO THE WORK
FORCE SHORTAGES THAT WE'RE
SEEING THROUGHOUT INDUSTRY RIGHT
NOW RIGHT WHERE. FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS WILL HELP WITH CREATING
COLLEGE GOING CULTURES HELP WITH
TRANSITIONS FROM- YOU KNOW
BETTER OR CAN COLLEGE COMPLETION
IN A MORE TIMELY FASHION BECAUSE
WE'LL START WITH SOME UNITS-
WHEN YOU ENTER A CULTURE
UNIVERSITY SO WE DO THESE
PROGRAMS REALLY IS SORT OF
HELPING. TO PUSH STUDENTS
THROUGH THE HIGH SCHOOL SYSTEM
AND INTO THE COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM AND THEN
ULTIMATELY WITH OUR INVESTMENTS
IN THE YOU KNOW THE HIGHER
EDUCATION SPACE IT'S PULLING
THOSE STUDENTS INTO THAT SPHERE
AND ULTIMATELY TRAINING UP FOR A
LOT OF THESE AREAS WHERE WE SEE
THESE RECOGNIZE PRONOUNCED. IN A
WORK FORCE SHORTAGES RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU- WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN AND THAT WILL-
CONCLUDED THIS ITEM WE ARE GOING
TO NOT HERE ISSUE NUMBER THE
LAST ISSUE ON THAT CAREER. A
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM
WE'LL HAVE THAT AND THAT. AND OF
THE FUTURE HEARING- WILL PROCEED
NOW WITH PUBLIC COMMENT SO IF
YOU HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
LINE UP OR IF YOUR- CALLING IN
POLICE- PREPARATIVE TO PRESENT
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR ONE
MINUTE OR LESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE IN OUR LAST PLACE.
HELLO MY NAME IS MICHELLE
ANDREWS I AM THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE ASSOCIATED
STUDENTS OF UC DAVIS AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION- TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONGEST SUPPORT FOR THE
INCLUSION OF TWENTY TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION AN ONGOING FUNDING.
FOR THE UC STATE CUT PROGRAMS-
SAY POP IS ONE OF THE STRONGEST
AND- MOST INFLUENTIAL TOOLS THAT
THE UC HAS TO INCREASE DIVERSITY
AND EQUITABLE ACCESS TO COLLEGE-
FOR CALIFORNIA'S MOST
UNDERSERVED HIGH SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES- AND SO WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CENTER SAY POP IN
YOUR CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
COLLEGE READINESS PROGRAMS- FOR
THE STUDENTS WHO NEED IT MOST IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE URGE YOU TO
INCLUDE TWENTY TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION AN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
IT IN THE MAY REVISE THANK YOU.
HELLO MATT PATTON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION MY COMMENTS ARE
SPECIFIC TO ITEM NUMBER SIX.
THANK YOU FOR THE AUGMENTATION
OF THEIR CONSENT OF GRANTS IN
THE CURRENT PROPOSED BUDGET WERE
VERY APPRECIATIVE. AND IT WOULD
ASK FOR AN INCREASE IN THAT
AUGMENTATION TO SERVE AT JUNIOR
HIGH SCHOOLS THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JASIM
PRASAD VICE PRESIDENT
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIVE. AND ON BEHALF OF
THE STUDENT ASSOCIATION AT FOR
THE COMMUNE CALLED SYSTEM WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE ASSEMBLY TO
SUPPORT THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO STRENGTHEN
AND EXPAND IT TO ENROLLMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW WE'LL GO TO A PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE PHONE WE HAVE EIGHT
CALLERS ON THE LINE PLEASE
PROCEED MODERATOR SIXTY SECONDS
OR LESS. THANK YOU FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. WE
WILL GO LINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE MARKET YET D. A. UNION
OF EDUCATORS IN CLASS BY
PROFESSIONALS I WANTED TO THANK
THE CHAIR MEMBERS PANEL IS IN
FACT FOR ALL THEIR WORK. I WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF A FAMILY
MEMBER- DONALD ABOUT THE
COMPENSATION AND CONDITION
CONDITIONS OF OUR TEACHERS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS. TO
ATTRACT THEM TO THIS. NOBLE
PROFESSION AND QUOTING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI BAND THAT THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE DISCUSSION.
OVERALL OF THE CONDITIONS AND
JUDGE SURE THAT WE HAVE ALSO.
OUR CLASSIFIED WORK FORCE TO
PLAY THE CENTRAL ROLE OF
CREATING GREAT CONDITIONS FOR
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS TO THRIVE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF
YOUR COMMENTS AND- EMPHASIS ON
DIVERSITY FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
PLACE. YOUR WORK ONLINE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PEOPLE AT THE
AIRBAG RIGHT ADAMS CHARLOTTE.
WHITE FOURTEEN LINE IS OPEN AND
- YEAH I CAN OKAY THE NEXT
BIGGER MODERATOR THANK YOU WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
MEMBERS ON THE BUS ON THE THAT'S-ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY
SCHAAF CALLING IN REGARDING
ISSUE NUMBER TWO JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS GRATITUDE FOR THE
ALLOCATIONS YEARS PAST IN THIS
PAST YEAR FOR THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY GRANT PROGRAM- REALLY
PLEASED WITH THE WAY THE PROGRAM
IS GONE AND OUR COMMUNITY
HOWEVER WE DO SEE A SIGNIFICANT
EQUITY ISSUE. WITH THE REST OF
THE PROGRAM THAT IS HOW ANY
EDUCATOR IN THE PROGRAM THE
LIABLE FOR REPAYMENT OF FUNDS
REGARDLESS OF RECENT EVENT
COMPLETION- WE FEEL THIS
LIABILITY STATUTE IS A
DISSERVICE TO THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATE AND ARE UNABLE TO
COMPLETE THEIR SERVICE- AND MANY
OF THEM DO NOT HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT ALTERNATIVE SOURCE
OF INCOME SO WITH THAT. WE JUST
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH R. ELEAZAR THE
LEGISLATURE AND COMMITTEE STAFF-
AND LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION. TO
ADDRESS THE EQUITY ISSUE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE TEAM THAT I NEED IS NOT TO
NOT TO HAVE THE CHILDREN NOW ON
ISSUE NUMBER THREE TEACHER
PIPELINE BUDGET PROPOSALS. WE
AGREE THAT STATE LEVEL
LEADERSHIP AND COORDINATION ARE
CRITICAL TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
CHRONIC TEACHER SHORTAGE WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN CPEC
STAFFING NO OTHER AGENCY IS
BETTER INFORMED ON THE MARRIED
CREDENTIALING REQUIREMENTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES. ON ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR EDUCATOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SUPPORT WE URGE YOU
TO CONTINUE TO INVEST INTO A
LANGUAGE LEARNER AND ENGLISH
LEARNER TEACHER TRAINING AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
SUPPORT- TECHNICAL EDUCATION
EFFECTIVE LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
STRUCTURE IN WE ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH PARTNERS CABIN CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER AND URGED INCLUSION OF
A ONE TIME TEN MILLION DOLLAR
PROCREATION. TO BRING BACK THE
BILINGUAL TEACHER PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS WE ALSO
REQUEST A ONE TIME TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROCREATION TO
CONTINUE TO EDUCATE A WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT GRANT PROGRAM AS PART
OF THE ENGLISH LEARNER ROAD MAP
POLICY IMPLEMENTATION GRANT
PROGRAM. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. A LINE OF A TWENTY.
WELL ONE OF TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS CREEPING UP THE LEFT
SIDE OF THE CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER BUT ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION.
ORGANIZATIONS OF WORK WILL BE TO
GREATER BUDGET PRIORITIES AND
WITH THE ADDITION OF UTK HAS
CREATED A NEED TO INCREASE THE
TAPE CAPACITY OF BILINGUAL
TEACHERS IN ORDER TO DEVELOP
ENGLISH AND HOME LANGUAGE
PROFICIENCY OF DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AND YOUTH PROGRAMS.
CONTINUE TO WORK TOADDRESS THE
SYSTEMATICALLY BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS ARE RECOMMENDING A
TEN MILLION APPROPRIATION TO
BRING BACK THE BILINGUAL TEACHER
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
THE B. T. P. TEAM. WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO REQUEST AN INCLUSION OF
THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
APPROPRIATION AND STFU BUDGET
INCREASE STUDENT ENROLLMENT IN
BILINGUAL AUTHORIZATION PROGRAM.
THROUGH THE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION OF FULL TIME FACULTY
IN THE COLLEGE OF EDUCATION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER PLACE. THANK YOU I GOT A
LINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS
JESSICA SOCCER ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW IN RESPONSE TO
ITEMS FIVE AND SIX- WE SUPPORT
THE INTENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
GOLDEN STATE PATHWAYS PROGRAM
GRANT PROPOSAL BUT AGREE WITH
THE LA- THAT BETTER ALIGNMENT IS
NEEDED WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE CP INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AND K.
TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE. WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT PROVIDING ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS WITH
ONGOING COST. WE ALSO SUPPORT
THAT AND GOVERNORS PATHWAY GRANT
PROGRAM FOR HIGH SCHOOL CAREERS
AND THE EMPHASIS ON EDUCATION
AND EARLY EDUCATION CAREERS.
FINALLY WE SUPPORTED NATIONAL
FUNDING FOR DUAL ENROLLMENT BUT
AGREE WITH THE LA-
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT FUNDING BE
TARGETED TO SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS
WITH THE HIGHEST NEEDS. THANK
YOU THANKS BAKER IS THAT IT-
THANK YOU KNOW WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY SIX ALIGN IS OPEN THANK
YOU. GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON CHERYL
CARTY AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MAINLY THE GUYS COMING UP THAT
YOU CAN SHE TRUST WHAT OURS DID
NOT ISSUE A NUMBER SIX TO ONE
MOMENT. WHILE WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO
SCALE UP AND EXPAND DUAL
ENROLLMENT BECAUSE WE CAN
SUPPORT EDUCATIONAL RECOVERY BY
RE ENGAGING STUDENTS RECOVER
CREDIT. FOR ON TIME HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION AND STRENGTHEN THE
COLLEGE CAREER READINESS HI WHAT
ARE WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU SOME
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL AND WORK
TO STRENGTHEN THE IN. PLACE SO
THAT THE GREEN SHARING BUTTONS
FIND INCREASED ACCESS FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS- THROUGH. GOAL SETTING
OR EXPLICIT PRIOR CONVICTION
LANGUAGE SIMILAR TO WHAT THE
OTHER YOUNG BLACK MEN. INSURING
DUAL CREDITS FOR THESE COURSES
TO BOTH HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE
CREDIT. PROVIDING STUDENT PARENT
. ABOUT THE ONE MOMENT OF THE
STRATEGY VIA COMMS OR MARKETING
STRATEGY. REQUIRING A ADVISORY
COUNCIL TO HELP INFORM EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDAMENTALIST
BEST PRACTICES FROM THE FIELD
AND FINALLY ADAM REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO RESPOND TO DATA
COLLECTION. ON THE OUTSKIRTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE SEVEN
NO IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
OF GREAT OF AND HEALTH COLLEGE
YOU KNOW. ON BEHALF OF THE MORE
THAN THIRTY SCHOOLS OF EDUCATION
AMONG OUR MEMBERSHIP JUST WANTED
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
INTEGRATED TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAM CALLED THE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM. AS WELL AS THE FUNDING
FOR TEACHER RESIDENCY THANK YOU
. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHURCH
MEMBERS BENJAMIN TREND WHEN
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE LOS ANGELES I'M CALLING-
YOU TO INVEST IN PRODUCING MORE
ASIAN LANGUAGE ACCREDITED
TEACHERS TO TEACH IN BILINGUAL
AND DON'T WORRY AND COSTUMES ARE
CROSS THE STATE. WE ARE
REQUESTING FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE COURSE O FOUR YEARS TO
SUPPORT THECURRENT HEAT YOU
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN STUDENTS AND
PROFESSORS IN INVESTMENT TO
INCREASE DIVERSITY TO THIS
TEACHER CREDENTIALING PIPELINE.
THANK. YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER PLACE. THANK YOU-
ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY MONEY I CAN
ALTHOUGH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA C. T. E. GPA
COALITION CALLING REGARDING ITEM
NUMBER SIX WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INVEST
MORE MONEY INTO CP PROGRAMS AND
PATHWAYS HOWEVER WE ARE
CONCERNED AS AS MENTIONED IN THE
ANALYSIS WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
THE PROPOSAL ESTABLISHES YET
ANOTHER COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM WITH A NEW SET OF
APPLICATION REQUIREMENTS. RATHER
THAN ADDING THE PROPOSED PLANS
INTO PROVEN EXISTING CTE
PROGRAMS IN ADDITION OUR
COALITION MEMBERS HAVE DECADES
OF SUCCESS IN PREPARING STUDENTS
FOR BOTH COLLEGE AND CAREER WE
BELIEVE THAT PLANS FOR C. T.
SHOULD BE ALIGNED WITH THE
SCHOOL AND BALANCE COLLEGE AND
CAREER READINESS AND SHOULD NOT
EMPHASIZE COLLEGE. OVER CAREER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BECAUSE WE ALL GOT ALONG. WELL
MY THIRTY SIX YEAR LINES OPEN.
THE MORNING WITH THE FEARLESS
WITH EACH CLASS- ON BEHALF OF
OUR TEACHING TELL THEM YOUR
DISTINCT ITEMS THREE AND SIX WE
APPRECIATE A COPY OF THE REPORT
THE HEARING WERE PLEASED TO SEE
THE PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN
BUILDING THE CAPACITY OF THE CTC
AND HOPE THAT HERE'S BETTER
COORDINATION BETWEEN ALL THE MPS
THEY'RE INVOLVED. IN A TEACHER
PIPELINE ONE ELEMENT THAT WE
WANT TO FLAG IT WAS NOT ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS AN
INVESTMENT IN THE ROLLOUT OF THE
PROVIDE CALIFORNIA STANDARDS FOR
THE TEACHING PROFESSION THE CDC
IS EXPECTED AS DOC REVISED
STANDARD WHEN I FELT- VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL BUT
THIS WILL INVOLVE- MULTI LEVEL
IMPLEMENTATION DESIGN. AND JUST
A TECHNOLOGY THE SHIFT IN THE
NEWER STANDARDS IF THEY'LL BE
LOST IN THE SHUFFLE WE DO NOT
INVEST AT ALL LEVELS OF THE CDC
THE PREPARATION PROGRAMS AND
ELEAZAR WE ALSO ON ITEM FIX OUR
TEACHERS ARE THRILLED TO SEE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
PATHWAY SPECIFICALLY FOR
EDUCATION EARLY EDUCATION. WE
BELIEVE THE TEMPLATE IMPORTANT
ROLE IN BUILDING A ROBOT. YOUR
PIPELINE BY FOSTERING HIGH
SCHOOL PROGRAMS YOU'RE KIDDING
FORCING COMMUNITIES WITH THE
GREATEST NEED TO SEND A LETTER
WITH SOME RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
HOW WE CAN MAKE THAT PROGRAM
STRONGER AND OUR TEACHERS ARE
EAGER TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION AND BE AT A COURSE
OF A. RESOURCE FOR YOU AS YOU
MAKE DECISIONS. NEXT A LITTLE
THIRTY SEVEN LINE AS THOUGH.
GOOD AFTER MR MEMBERS I'M NOT
ABOUT THE WHAT THE CALIFORNIA X.
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FOR DUAL ENROLLMENT
OPPORTUNITIES WE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY URGE OUR STATE
LEADERS TO INCLUDE ADULT
LEARNERS AS PART OF THIS
INVESTMENT TO ENSURE INCLUSIVITY
OF ALL STUDENTS THAT ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS DUAL ENROLLMENT. PROGRAMS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN OUR
FINAL PUBLIC COMMENT WILL COME
FROM A LINE OF THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHRIS BRIEF ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION FIRST ONE TO COME
AND THE CHAIR AND THANK HIM FOR
THIS HIS CONTINUED EFFORTS. TO
HELP ADDRESS OUR STATE'S TEACHER
SHORTAGE AND DRUG THAT IS
WORKING IN SYRIA AS WELL AS I
THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
HER WORK ON THIS AGENDA- WANTED
TO OFFER THANK CUSTOMER MEDINA
FOR RAISING. THE SBA'S BUT IT
ASK FOR THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE INTEGRATED
TEACHER EDUCATION PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY FOR UNDERGRADUATE
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS. THIS IS
A REQUEST THAT IS DISTINCT AND
SEPARATE FROM THE ADMINISTRATORS
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL- TO HELP
PROVIDE DIRECT GRANTS TO
STUDENTS OR WHO WILL OR ARE
ENROLLING IN. THESE PROGRAMS-
THE GOLD THE PROPOSAL IS
THREEFOLD- TO. PRODUCE QUALIFIED
CRITICAL TEACHERS IN THE SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME POSSIBLE REMOVE
FINANCIAL DISINCENTIVE TO INTO
INDIVIDUALS WHO COULD BECOME
QUALIFIED TEACHERS. AND REDUCE
THE DEBT LOAD PROSPECTIVE
TEACHERS TAKE ON AND COMPLETING
THEIR TEACHING COMPUTING THEIR
TEACHING CREDENTIAL- BY
INVESTING A MODEST AMOUNT OF
STATE FUNDING THIS PROGRAM TO
THE PROGRESSION PATHWAYS- MISS
PROVEN TEACHER PREPARATION
PATHWAY THIS TAKEN SIGNIFICANTLY
ACCELERATE AND EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF QUALIFIED TEACHING
CANDIDATES. WHO CAN ENTER THE
PROFESSION WITHIN. THREE TO FOUR
YEARS THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. THEN WE HAVE NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT IN Q. THANK YOU
SO MUCH WITH THAT WE WILL
ADJOURN.